foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome
day one of the fide World Blitz chess
championships
we just had three days of insane action
for the world rapid and of course the
world women's rapid where we saw Magnus
Carlsen added to his current collection
of world titles he is now classical and
Rapid world champion is he gonna add a
third by becoming wild Blitz Champion
holding onto that Trifecta which he has
done before
wouldn't be the first time but it's been
a while since Magnus has held all three
titles in the women's we saw a fantastic
performance by tan Georgie solid and
efficient is she going to do the double
in the Blitz
we'll see well let's have a look at what
stake in at stake in these tournaments
before I do that though it would be
remiss of me of course not to introduce
my partner in crime my good buddy
grandma said David Howe David
it's been uh it was a fantastic three
days uh if the rapid but the blitz is
really the Fan's favorite
yep you're right Lawrence it's not just
the Fan's favorite it is the player's
favorite you mentioned some of the names
there Magnus Carlson tanzong Yi in the
women's section also remember Hikaru
Nakamura had a tough time in the rapid
11 draws out of 13 games lost a bunch of
rating points but he was undefeated and
he's going to come into this section as
one of the favorites and yesterday was
dramatic with those playoffs with
everything decided just in the last few
minutes the last few moves but today
it's going to be the same there's even
more games and as you mentioned Lawrence
a lot at stake today and tomorrow
Sun's at stake let's have a look uh it's
the same format as the rapid it's a
Swiss tournament so the more points you
get are the greater chance you have to
win the tournament of course if there's
a tie at the top we didn't get that it
looked and sorry we didn't get that in
the open it looked as though uh there
was a bunch Carlson and Kmart and the
like looked as though there was going to
be a playoff there wasn't in the end
Magnus went outright in the women's we
did see a playoff between sanjongji and
cereal kasova if we have to have the
playoff again we will of course cover
that
same deal when it comes to the prizes
sixty thousand dollars in the open and
in the women's section uh breakdown
Enterprises here we can see forty
thousand dollars
for first massive prize thirty thousand
for second twenty thousand for third and
so on tons of prizes fifteen prizes
total
uh and uh in the open
sixty thousand for first
massive prize for at least 150 000 per
second forty thousand for third and so
on and so forth so of course tons of
Pride becoming Blitz World Champion
prizes are serious as well David uh
you've played in this tournament before
you've played in a bunch of these
tournaments how how big a prize fund is
that relative to other tournaments
it is huge you very rarely get this type
of money in any over-the-board
tournaments uh let alone Rapid or Blitz
we saw for example in the women's
section just yesterday 15 year old
Savita got uh joint third place I
believe and for her that is
life-changing money I think she got in
the region of 20 30 000 and that will
set her up with coaching that will set
her up for the years to come in terms of
playing opportunities travel expenses
and uh for a lot of the players this is
crucial a tournament like this it could
be that big breakthrough could propel
them forward uh in their careers and
meanwhile we see the players getting
ready in the auditorium Anish giri uh
Ganguly there Eric icy on the right
Sagar Shah now we see Nakamura as well
uh taking his place on board two uh for
the blitz tournament but let's check out
some of the top seeds Lawrence uh in
both sections in the women's Blitz
tournament we see Katarina lagno starts
as the uh favorite at least on paper in
terms of rating tanzongi the world rapid
Champion 2022 she starts in second place
some huge names there go
yachikinaru Alexandra costenuk and uh
Sarah cardemp from Iran as well
stefanova former women's world champion
so many big names it's going to be just
as tight just as close at the top I feel
in uh the women's Blitz as it was in the
rapid uh portion of the event only 17
rounds we should mention in the women's
compared to 21 rounds in the open
section but still lots of action to come
let's check out those pairings
yeah so uh yeah board one we have left
no white against Tokyo Genova uh we have
Eric uh Jovana or against tanjong
jionpoint
on board three uh you know it's Blitz
anything can happen right that's where
you know we do see a ton of blunders a
ton of upsets a ton of back and forth
and drama so we will get uh many more
Underdog opportunities I feel in in the
blitz especially with some of the
younger players uh so I'm really looking
forward to seeing that
and of course let's look at the the open
section David uh it is not Magnus
Carlsen as top C but rather Hikari
Nakamura current world number one in
Blitz
uh he is ranked top and perhaps
quite surprisingly Fabiano caruana is
seeded number two ahead of Magnus
Carlson
yeah we would assume that Magnus is the
favorite for any tournament he starts in
especially in the blistering form he
showed yesterday however lit's ratings
do fluctuate Nakamura has been doing
very well in Blitz over the last few
years Carolina had a bit of a hot streak
as well uh over the past 12 months and
we see some maybe less expected names we
see Yu Yang Yi in fourth uh as fourth
seed there vladislava Tammy have as well
showed his credentials yesterday Blitz
ratings yeah they do go up and down but
all of these guys and plenty more they
will have a shot don't be surprised if
we do see some uh some underdogs some
really surprise names up there in the
first two rounds it's about how you
start and
um yeah this the splits tournament I do
think Nakamura has a score to settle
he's never won a World Blitz or rapid
title that's the only thing pretty much
missing from his CV right now and he'll
want to set the score straight it's
gonna be uh yeah it's gonna be
fascinating to see how these top seeds
do in the initial rounds as they try to
avoid any potential upsets any banana
skins
it is and worth pointing out as well
tendency there mvl is current lit world
champion let's not forget uh mvl would
love to go back to back uh more than
capable of doing it we can see some
other big names there Alexander grishuk
has had success in the past as well what
about irrigation uh he's obviously you
know informed we've seen him everywhere
recently had a good streak at least in
the rapid uh yesterday and we've got
some other Blitz Specialists let's say
Dimitri andrakin very very tough Blitz
player Federal Sav had a wonderful rapid
tournament as well we've got the likes
of sarin who is no slouch Mama Groff who
is no slouch the list goes on so uh
gonna be super super tough
the pairings for round one are on the
board now uh we can see board one
covaliev against Carlson Jacob boyev
against Nakamura
and karawana against sargassian the top
three pairings
um
it's funny we can we we can actually see
a shot here David of the of the players
getting settled in we can see I can see
out the corner Nakamura here sporting an
aronian like shirt has to be said he's
probably uh asked Lev for some fashion
tips uh which is a major blunder may I
just say uh ask David Howe for fashion
tips that I can tell you if you want to
look sharp and Suave
uh that we have Fabiano caruana Fabi who
is playing against the hero for many of
uh the Olympia team
for Armenia sargassian they came ever so
close
to
pulling a major upset in the Olympia
didn't they this year David's nearly
nearly winning it uh the old experienced
Armenian team
yeah this is how tough the first round
uh is this is how tough the blitz
tournament is gonna be already in round
one we see some huge pairings now we see
andrekin well-known Russian Superstar up
against Lehman a very famous streamer
from Vietnam also very very successful
online in Blitz to Blitz Specialists uh
you mentioned Caron against sargassian
two super Grand Masters and this is only
round one and we're getting these
incredible pairings already there's
gonna be no easy games for anyone
they're gonna have to do it the hard way
anyone who wants to win this tournament
here we see cavallev waiting for the
arrival of the world rapper Champion
miraculous Carlson and uh I'm assuming
once Magnus does arrive we'll have a
couple of announcements from the
Arbiters the players will be told all
the rules and uh they will get going we
should mention Lawrence it is three
minutes on the clock for each player in
the blitz section gaining two seconds
after every move so it will be very very
fast once they start and we will be
focusing on one game at a time but
there'll be action everywhere and we'll
try and keep you up to date with as much
as possible here we see young Kristoff
Duda with black up against I think Pavel
ponkratov from Russia another very very
strong the medical opponent in Blitz
um yeah I'm pretty sure Lawrence we're
going to see some surprise results in
the early rounds
we will we'll see it almost every round
uh it's just uh you know it is Blitz
it's very volatile very high variance
um and
yeah but the cream does tend to rise to
the top as the tournament goes on 12
rounds today for the open section
so plenty of Chess
Magnus would absolutely love to win this
tour now that he's won the rapid to win
the blitz to hold all three titles he's
going to be gunning for it make no
mistake he's not taking this tournament
lightly this is deadly serious stuff we
can see there uh some of the top women
Katarina lachner uh in uh playing white
there she is playing against
um
uh talking over who I think is
originally from
Uzbekistan
uh originally she's young I believe she
she's uh she's been in the US for a
while now
uh talented player lad now though I can
tell you this David I've played against
lucky no at least twice in official
Blitz events yeah over in Germany
I've just a force I really feel how
strong she is yeah I've played
a lot of these guys at Blitz and I can
tell you that she is really super strong
at Blitz I think she's
she's uh she's favorite for a reason at
least on paper
uh yeah here we have he's very good
yeah I was going to say the customer
go on David
I know sorry Lawrence um yeah the uh
ceremony of first move by one of the
sponsors or local dignitaries I believe
and I think they want to make the first
move on magnus's board as well but where
is he where is the world champion is he
just keeping us guessing is it the Mind
Games again or is he just genuinely late
I uh I heard rumors he was off skiing
this morning here we see Yu Yang Yi up
against Timo Gareth uh yeah looking
smart to more gray of that uh just uh
having a chat with his opponent before
the game and yeah I'm itching to get
going Lawrence what are your predictions
who do you hold let's forget about the
ratings who do you hold as the favorite
in each of the sections you've mentioned
some names already
yeah I I can't help but uh say that in
the women's section I think laugh noise
is is quite quite a big favorite that
said koyage came out she's got the the
Royal talent and the strength to be
there humpy is also not bad and may I
point out Alexandra castenyuk I I've
I've I've slept on Alexandra really not
not really mentioned putting her in the
in the conversation but she very much is
I mean Alexandra castanoke is a
fantastic
uh Blitz player and uh you know she's
she's won everything world champion
Russian champion
uh uh she she is actually
something to be you know a player to be
uh to be uh considered she won the rapid
championship last year it was I said
whatever who won the Blitz
now do I think that's going to be
repeated
um I don't I think bibisara she had you
know one of those uh fantastic runs but
since then I don't think her form has
been good enough
for her to really have a realistic shot
at this when I see the strength and
depth of this field
I don't think that's wherever is
actually going to repeat her success
because Daniel went back to back last
year as well so I think kristenyuk is in
the picture as well
Lawrence it looks like we have liftoff
in the world Blitz Championship despite
some of the players not being there yet
uh we have started some of the games and
okay kuvalev he tried to tell the
Arbiter not start the clock but the
clocks have been started insisted where
is Magnus Carlson there's only three
minutes on the clock for the whole game
and they've started without him will he
lose on time will he arrive in time the
world champion
or would he be defaulted that would be a
huge shock I think they waited long
enough
um they're well within the rates to
start now uh here we see Nakamura it's
early days in his game it looks like the
Dutch defense to begin his campaign but
uh look at this Nakamura peering around
wondering where is Magnus Carlson is he
going to give a one-point Head Start to
everyone else to the pack
Lawrence dramatic times already and it's
only round one what is happening
yeah people looking around that is
shocking actually I don't recall I mean
Magnus of course he's been late before
but it is shocking to
to see him not uh at the board
uh you know it's about six past the hour
so it is a fair
amount of time it's not been one or two
minutes you can't just hold the
tournament up for Magnus
by the way look at what yakuboyev has
played he's played an awesome opening
and nakamuri is looking around but I if
I was him I'd be looking at the at the
board because
we've got a position where this is
potentially dramatic well maybe yeah
it's thematic but got to be careful here
with black surely
yeah and we will update everyone we will
update you with when Magnus Carlson
arrives I think we'll even see it on
hikaru's face when uh Carson does
eventually stride in he's already lost a
minute on the clock there Magnus uh and
counting but meanwhile as you say Laura
it's dramatic here it's the Dutch
defense white has thrown the H Pawn
forward sacrificed a rook sacrifice The
Exchange on H5 but this is mightily
scary that White Queen teaming up with
her Knights the black king in Mortal
danger here uh Nakamura I'm pretty sure
he's analyzed something like this before
otherwise you don't play instantly into
this type of position as black or just
be suicide or to allow this without some
prior knowledge but yeah playing with
fire in round one I think Hikaru he was
the only undefeated player in the rapid
section but uh he would have been
frustrated he only got two wins in those
13 rapid rounds he wants to put uh yeah
he wants to put at least one win on the
board in the early rounds here just to
show that uh well showed to himself as
much as anyone that he's back in form
and then while Magnus does arrive
looking very casual while the world
champion I think he's lost around two
minutes on his clock must be yeah he'll
have to play bullet chess pretty much
yeah I think we'll have to switch over
let's go there
let's go over to Magnus Carson wow he's
got 30 seconds on his clock to start
this game giving time odds to his
opponent uh Magnus with just over 30
seconds uh kovalev with almost three
minutes and it's the French defense The
Exchange variation so kovalev not
playing the most aggressive not the most
uh testing opening Magnus at least he'll
survive and kovalev is thinking a lot at
this early stage
Lawrence what would your strategy be
would you just try to flag Magnus would
you try and win on the clock or would
you do what kovalev's thinking pause
take your time pretend it's a normal
Blitz game
this is surprising stuff now foreign
yeah I don't think there's any need to
spend this much time but I certainly
wouldn't try to flag Magna so someone
who's played uh tons of bullet against
Magnus he's not really flaggable uh
especially when remember it's three plus
one
so you don't want to do that but at the
same time this is kind of poor by
Cavalia view there's just no need to
spend 30 seconds there's just no need to
spend 30 seconds on Knight C3 castles
just you know play C5 Play Bishop B2
play what you have to play take on D5
whatever it is but you can do it quickly
it's all of this you know 20 seconds per
move stuff it's just not necessary uh
he's a strong enough Grandmaster
yeah Lawrence it's not just uh it's not
just three plus one it's three plus two
so Magnus does get two seconds after
every movement yeah I mean kovalev he's
giving too much respect to Magnus is he
just trying to show some good
sportsmanship is he just trying to slow
down and catch Magnus up on the clock
because he has so many natural moves
he's not even moving now and also we
mentioned dress code earlier Hikaru
looking sharp but Magnus wearing a
hoodie here has he just got out of bed I
mean did someone drag him out with two
minutes of the two minutes before the
round this is really I mean it's hard to
explain all of these things Kavala have
now finally moving but Magnus is already
catching up on the clock and showing no
urgency in his play two seconds is not a
lot in over the board chest in online
chess you can pre-move you don't lose
any time but it physically takes one or
two seconds to make the move on the
board so I think kavalev missed a trick
there if he wants to take down Magnus
that was when Magnus was at his most
vulnerable before he was ready before he
was fresh focused and with only 30
seconds on the clock
uh suddenly white is a pawn up but that
white D5 Pawn is dropping
and how calm how casual this Magnus 20
something seconds on the clock and he's
playing as if this is uh he's got two
hours this is incredible and position
wise looking pretty balanced Lawrence
well I think actually it's you know
Magnus has come out of this really well
I mean why it's got an isolated Queen's
Pawn
here on D4 but when you have that
isolated Queen spawn normally it comes
with a lot of initiative and I don't
really feel that initiative here black
has managed to establish a blockade of
that pawn with the Knight on D5 he can
reinforce that blockade with the move C6
which he does after Bishop F3 and you
have to ask yourself what has white
actually got in this position in fact it
wouldn't surprise him if he just lops on
D5 here with the Knight accepts that
he's got nothing uh okay he plays Queen
B3 also makes a bunch of sense
um but this this really is very very
little and on top of that he's only a
couple seconds up on the clock now I
think it's pretty full form
it's extremely dramatic on the clock
Magnus down to around 15 seconds uh
Cavallo now down to 20 seconds it's
hyper bullet it's Ultra bullet now
um it's just gonna be a mess and neither
player is going to be able to navigate
this perfectly
um things are simplifying slightly after
you mentioned all of those exchanges or
the Queens disappear from the board it's
Cavallo just trying to go into safety
mode it feels like he doesn't really
want to punish Magnus for that later
rival now kavalov going down to just a
few seconds five seconds of finally he
leans forward
I mean the position is balanced if
anyone you would take black because of
the bishop pair uh but it's small
margins here and it's just going to be
about who manages the clock quicker
finally Magnus showing some impatience
the arm coming out Rook A4 it looks like
on the board attacking White's Central
Pawn
threats are mounting up if I live on the
back foot
on the clock Lawrence
how are they going to manage this it's
just five seconds each pretty much every
single move
yeah with the with the additional two
seconds though they're going to be okay
we can see the moves flicking through
real quick uh black is better as you
said this Knight is not great and this
is the typical position we see Magnus
win uh the Knight just cannot really get
into the action but objectively probably
it's holdable for white because the
white Rook covers both of the big
weaknesses and they're on dark squares
so it's very difficult to do anything
and here actually I think of olive has
done really well like right around here
you know white just plays G4 here for
example or just moves his King I would
go G4 as as white if I could to stop
like going F5
but uh I think as though I think white
is fine white is just solid enough yeah
he does go G4 and I think that's about
as much of a kind of uh
fortresses as you would ever want yeah
Rook D1 is good preventing The Rook
coming to the other side
and should be a draw with best play
let's think that but it is Magnus
Carlson we know all about the Magnus
effect in end games and anyone else in
the world you would be confident of
holding this one with white but black is
putting on the pressure look at this
black B Pawn moving forward Black's
light Square Bishop has found its way
into the position
my output
yeah you've got to be careful there's
mating threats against that white king
Black's Rook is coming round Lawrence I
wouldn't wow
what did he do
Black's Pawn structure now perfect look
at those Queen side pawns White's d-pawn
is just gonna drop and
I think Magnus is going to take this all
of white pawns a week look how active
that black Rook is now I don't think it
was ever equal actually a film Magnus
was always on the front foot and the
momentum's on his side he's been playing
instantly the whole game kovalev just
too slow in the early stages he will get
punished look at this end game Magnus
mopping up black has won a pawn white
g-pawn is also about to fall
straightforward 101 in terms of end
games easy stuff now
no chances
very very surprising in many aspects and
but uh yeah that's enough Cavalia does
resign
uh
think he did everything wrong in that
game actually good value you know you've
got two and a half minutes extra on the
clock you've got to play faster you just
have to play faster in the opening and
then when you have that equal position
as well just made some poor decisions I
think you'll be very disappointed let's
go to Fabiano the next game
let's jump right into this game with
Fabiano against sargassian sargassian
Great end game player but he is two
pawns down it's a pure Knight end game
Fabi has double G pawns can he convert
Lawrence black wants to give up his
Knight for both white pawns but maybe
one of those white pawns Will Survive
it's an uphill struggle for black to say
this what do you think here is he gonna
make it Fabiano the bar says yeah
yeah I I don't see this being saveable
at all for black the double G
Performance here
uh or an asset you can't win both and
all you have to do is find a way to uh
to push that black king back and you
will reach a position where you can get
a winning King and pawn ending you leave
that pawn on G2 so that you you ensure
that you have the winning King and pawn
ending King in front of that pawn for
when that ending uh transpires and uh
yeah it's gonna be an uphill struggle
for sargassian here just got to be
careful don't blunder that pawn he goes
for G4 which is also okay you just don't
want to push it to G5 too quickly that's
what I feel is the key here Knight F5
check is now a big threat uh they're
playing a break now now G6 will come
Knight of six check King G5
yeah slow and steady uh just step by
step as you mentioned there Lawrence
keep one point in reserve for later keep
it protected but eventually black is
just being pushed back and I think we're
seeing the final stages of this game uh
Fabiano very quick very accurate uh as
was mentioned there in the future chat
he is just an end game uh virtuoso when
he wants to be especially when he can
just calculate his way to Victory Fabi
maybe you just got to avoid stale Matrix
with Black's King in the corner but that
white Pawn on G6 will cost black is
night sooner rather than later White
Knight now is coming around to E7 you
just need one check
yeah black king away and uh the G Pawn
rolls through but uh can he get there so
I guess he and trying desperately to
check that white King backwards for the
white King's founder safe square away
from uh any potential checks and what's
happened here is this the lifeboard
black's night just planning itself on H3
so I guess yoland is his Knight away it
was hopeless anyway and Fabi takes the
win
yep was never really in doubt the Hikaru
Nakamura also won his game should be
pointed out so all the top guys starting
off well and I have to say breaking news
breaking news in the women's section
Katarina lachno has lost her first game
with the white pieces big rating
favorite in my opinion against Walker
Genova massive massive massive upset
another massive upset actually two more
massive upsets humpy canuro losing
against the local uh player gulixan
nakabayeva and Alexandra castenia who I
touted I've really put the curse on them
this round losing against kovanova
I mean this is shocking stuff three of
the big favorites in my opinion and look
at this jansaya Abdu Malik we haven't
spoken much about the English place
because we don't have many we had Amit
Garcia in the open but we've got
lanyard has beaten jansaya Abdul Malik
with the black pieces rated only
2174 beating zhansaya Abdul Malik
absolutely exceptional upsets in the
women's section
and yeah we just uh come back to a board
as I think we see a draw on one of the
higher boards here
um yeah so many
surprises as you mentioned there
Lawrence in the women's section uh we'll
check in on the results in both the open
and the women's uh momentarily but yeah
we're seeing the final few games of the
round uh end now I'm not sure how many
games are still going often we see these
long end games uh kind of endure for 100
moves like broken Bishop versus Rook
these long grinds but it does look like
the first round of Blitz
does end there and there's a lot to
unpack Magnus Carlson arriving two and a
half minutes late giving his opponent
time odds and uh Nakamura distracted
watching that but in the end it did look
like those few favorites uh in the open
section did pull through so Lawrence yep
started in well unexpected crazy fashion
yeah very unexpected Magnus Carlson
doesn't need the full three minutes wins
anyway uh massive upsets in the women's
section we're going to be back for round
two in just a few minutes of course it's
fast and furious it's Blitz chess we
don't have too much time don't go
anywhere we'll be right back with round
two here on chess.com
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
everything
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
everybody and welcome back to
chess.com's coverage of the world Blitz
championships taking place in Almaty
Kazakhstan we've just seen uh a well a
dramatic round one we'll go through what
happened there in a moment of course
alongside me is Grandmaster David Hill
David
uh we just saw a a very unusual incident
actually in the open section Magnus
Carlsen arriving nearly the full three
minutes late he nearly lost on time but
it didn't matter in the end
yeah he really kept us on the edge of
our seats and uh I think he really got
under his opponent's skin by arriving
late Magnus arriving two and a half
minutes late as you mentioned there
Lawrence you start with three minutes on
the clock the Arbiters insisted they
didn't want to wait anymore uh they
insisted on the game starting and yeah I
think four of vladislav kovalev missed
opportunity he just waited too long he
played very slowly in the early stages
and Magnus fought back grinding him down
in a typical carson-esque endgame so
Magnus took the win in the end and uh
here we do see the standings after round
one most of the favorites did take the
full point uh at least the rating
favorites Nakamura won his game Carolina
as we saw that a moment ago grinding
down a long night end game Magnus took
the win Yu Yang Yi Anish Gary
napoleonishi vashi legrath most of those
top seeds uh took the win and that does
leave us with some very juicy pairing
some juicy matchups in round two we do
see
uh the rest of the top table here
meanwhile uh the top 20 some huge names
Mama Dr of nihal sarin vidit Jordan van
Forrest and uh the list goes on so uh
not as many uh upsets in the open
section as we would expect and here we
see round two which is upcoming in just
a few minutes it's gonna be fast uh not
too many breaks not too long breaks in
between the rounds Magnus takes on
cedipov a Russian Blitz specialist uh
Nakamura on board two takes in Sergey
Udin Vincent kymer against Fabiano
caruana the silver medalist from the
world rapid against the bronze medalist
from the world rapid and those two did
extremely well just over the last few
days and they're already facing each
other
um some other names uh Stand Out Anish
giri playing against one of the surprise
packages of the rapid tournament uh Giga
cuparazzi and uh followed on Merton
takes on the reigning world Blitz
Champion Maxine fashion the grave
Lawrence which matchups catcher either
well I would say that uh certainly uh
Kmart against Carolina is is the
standout game right for this round uh
with Vincent's fantastic run in the
rapid tournament uh his Ascent in
general has been uh just wonderful to
see much needed for German chess as well
Germany have produced a number of really
strong Grand Masters over the past few
years but they haven't had uh what I
would term as a breakthrough Grandmaster
sort of elite uh breakthrough
Grandmaster uh and Vincent very much is
that so uh this you know he's he's still
is so young uh he's over 2700 classical
but he can play Blitz he can play rapid
as he's shown
um and this is going to be no easy game
for Fabiano uh I should point out I made
a slight error in the introduction
um of course Ali reservous is really the
big name missing at this this tournament
Ali Reza is Blitz World number one at
the moment with Hikaru wad number two
Fabiano world number three and Magnus
world number four
should just make that clear Vincent
though 18 years old uh you know all the
energy all the beans this is going to be
a tough tough game for
uh for Fabiano and as we go down the
back also I'm very curious to see on
board eight volodynam spoke about him a
lot yesterday the young Russian says I
am I have no idea why he's still an IM
he's clearly Grandmaster strengthens
being Grandma's strength for a long time
now playing White against reigning world
Blitz Champion MBL I think that's going
to be fun another very fun matches the
game right next to him Alexander
grischuk uh playing against El Nino
Anton Alexander he hasn't really
featured has he in our discussions yet
David he it seems as though in the rapid
he he simply didn't get to the top
boards but he's uh he's a phenomenal
Blitz player
uh yeah phenomenal is the right word
there Lawrence Alexander gristrook
didn't make too much of a dent on the
rapid tournament but I think he's a
three-time world Blitz Champion uh at
least a two-time Blitz World Champion uh
at least this is definitely the format
in which he specializes uh Grisha he is
married to lagner could they do the
double the husband and wife for her
double uh in the medals there uh I do
think he's one of the maybe favorites
for this event if he can get on a roll
but it all depends on the start for
Alexander grishrock uh we do see
meanwhile the players Gathering starting
to take their seats having a nice chat
there I'll have Mike Zulu chatting with
vashilograph uh chatting with Tabata by
as well and uh yeah some of the
match-ups are huge already as you
mentioned Lawrence plenty of 2700
players uh facing each other meanwhile
here we see board one sidipov as black
he's ready to go I think uh the big
question of this round is when will
Magnus Carlson turn up hopefully he
won't leave it too late so this time
I don't think he's going to leave it as
late this time that's sure uh
uh but uh yeah I think just to also I
just had a quick look Alexandra has won
the world Rich championships three times
three times Blitz World Champion I
believe Magnus is one eight five times
but I could be wrong it is five times
yes it is five times
see all the other Grandmasters there of
course we've got Napo there wearing a
nepo shirt that's quite uh quite funny
they're chatting away uh you can see all
kite we've got Lin me uh Min Lee in the
in the uh background there Hans Neiman
walking around guys slowly getting to
their chairs finding out where they're
playing
uh must be nice to play this tournament
David I I have to say I am jealous I
wish I was there being able to
you know because every round you get
such a tough player uh and it's you know
really drives you
yeah uh you're right Lawrence I've
played in the world record of this
championships I think three times and uh
if you're doing well it's a great
challenge you're loving it you play
these uh Giants of the game every single
round but if you're struggling you still
play the tough opponents and it's like a
Non-Stop barrage uh and it's uh yeah it
can be brutal so those players who don't
get off to a good start it's all about
trying to bounce back it's staying
strong it is a marathon 21 rounds in the
open section 17 in the women's section
and uh yeah it's just about keeping
Focus who has the better stamina who has
the endurance to go the distance and we
will see the top players start to drop
points eventually whether it's in round
two whether it's in round five six uh a
bit later on but it is all about putting
a winning streak together if they say
that having one good day is often enough
we've seen World Blitz championships
before with uh with players going 100 on
one of the days I think we saw Duda a
few years back get 9 a half out of 10 on
one of the days a huge streak there and
you often have to rack up a massive
number of points in order to get a medal
often out of those 21 games you need
roughly 16 17 points if you want to be
contending uh at the top uh meanwhile
the players are getting ready taking
their seats I still believe there's a
few minutes before
um we'll hear that gong sound and the
games get going here we see young
volodar merzin against facilograph as
you mentioned World Blitz Champion
Ashley Graf did okay in the rapid
Lawrence he had a crucial role in the
fate of that title holding Vincent
climber in the last round yesterday and
um yeah I think he he'll believe in
himself he's full of confidence the
Frenchman that he can defend his title
such a
such a tough plan to play against
inblitz MBL so resourceful uh uh but
merzin
I think this will be a tough little game
for MBL and there we see as you said the
big bash for me of the round came up
against Favi and I have to say
go in with the upset in this one Vincent
came up for the win white pieces
uh stylistically think he's unpleasant
for for Fabi
um
Fabi is a very ambitious uh Blitz player
and I'm actually going for a
yeah for uh for uh
for a white win in this one
hate to say it sorry Fabi but that's
that's what I'm going for in this
particular game
yeah until we see nakamura's opponent
Sega you didn't I think he will turn up
in the next few minutes Nakamura he's
known for always being on time always
being early for his games you mentioned
Vincent climate against
caruana Lawrence and caruana is one of
the highest rated Blitz players in the
world but he's another one lacking one
of these speed chess World titles uh
he's never done fantastically in uh
Blitz tournaments Fabby he's not
necessarily known for his Blitz prowess
but recent years he's really improved uh
really seemed to have uh sped up got
quicker got more confident and he will
want to avoid that upset that you
mentioned meanwhile it does look in the
background of this picture like the
Arbiters are getting ready to make an
announcement the chief Arbiter is there
on the far left of the picture in the
foreground we see tanzan Yi after her
success after her gold medal yesterday
and uh yeah where is Magnus Carlsen
where is Hikaru Nakamura uh here we see
Jordan vanfurist looking around maybe
also wondering the same question
when will the game start uh often these
first few rounds uh they are
significantly delayed but I've been very
impressed with this tournament in the
rapid section uh at least Lawrence very
prompt the games they started on time
um not too long to wait in between uh
seems like a very well organized
tournament
on the whole and as I've heard have been
loving it out there in Kazakhstan
and yeah the games
I can't wait to get uh going yet again
hopefully this time less of a heart
attack in the early stages uh Nakamura
does indeed arrive on time we see the
handshake
the customary handshake to start the
game
yeah predictions for this one do you
think Nakamura Can Go the whole way
can he finally get that uh World title
in Blitz that he's been dreaming of for
sale
well of course he can uh and really if
if any any year he's going to get it it
should be this year because he's been in
a rich vein of form both over the board
he's done fantastically well and I think
of candidates tournaments and other top
tournaments when I think of his online
success he's done extremely well he
looks relaxed you know he this really
should be on paper his his time his year
to shine and winning this would mean the
world to him
so
absolutely has every chance but the
problem he's got is as long as Magnus
Carlson is hanging around as long as
Magnus is there
and not just Magnus of course you've got
MBL you've got Fabi and you've got
janaponishi and Duda and all of the
gristook and all these other great Blitz
players
as long as they are there you're never
going to have an easy time but I think
if Hikaru is gonna win it
uh this is really the year to win it
it's just all the stars are aligning for
him in that sense so I know a lot of
people watching this broadcast would
love to see Hikaru in it and to a
certain extent I would like to see
Hikaru win it as well I think he
deserves a world title his contribution
to chess has been phenomenal
yeah and we are we are anxiously waiting
for Magnus to arrive but uh Lawrence
which game do you want to follow in this
second round let's pick the game that we
will uh
that we'll focus on in the early stages
I I think we have to do the Kmart
Carolina game just because I've hyped it
up as game of the round but of course we
will keep an eye out for the Nakamura
yudin and Carlson sudapov games we can
see that Alexander Grisha taking a seat
nice little sideways shot there of some
of the top female players there we can
see Anna ushinina in the back playing a
former women's world champion
uh as well so yeah you know it does look
it does look like Magnus Carlsen has
arrived and it's a change of outfit for
the world champion uh no more hoodie
that's gone maybe the uh feeder
officials had a word with him about the
dress code he looks suited and booted
and ready to go so uh less drama now
that we know that Magnus is in the venue
and he is on time to start this second
round but I agree Vincent climber
against Fabiana caruana I think that is
the uh the glamor matchup of the round
has been since the Young Gun aims to
stake his claim in the blitz format
great rapid players we've seen already
so we will be focusing here but uh yeah
Magnus Hikaru they've got an eye on each
other I feel they know that Clash will
come later in the tournament they will
face each other eventually
it's uh it's a comment that gets Corona
the big one and here we see Gary
refocusing earlier we saw him having a
joke uh in typical Geary style having a
joke with some colleagues uh with some
of his mates uh he is also in one of the
higher boards another great Blitz player
of course Gary but another one who's yet
to uh get one of those big titles uh
another one who's yet to really make
that breakthrough in the blitz format up
against uh Georgia Grandmaster gigako
parrots Billy uh sorry and
um
yeah I think the games will start within
the next minute or so so we'll we'll
await that handshake as the players make
their last minute adjustments often we
see this right the nerves come in you
adjust your pieces you fiddle uh the
cameras are in their faces
it's not easy for the top players to
focus it's significantly different from
online chess
no pre-moves of course
um just the time it takes to make the
moves is physically difficult
and yeah I I think Vincent is in with a
decent shout in this game as you
mentioned Lawrence but Fabiano
I've seen him do extremely well in Blitz
over the past 12 months and with black
like you said he's extremely aggressive
extremely ambitious Carolina never
really allows for a boring position to
arise on the board and
I think he he will be backing himself
here as well what's the hold up let's
get this game going no idea it's it's
taking a bit longer than usual isn't it
yeah no idea what the hold up is
Magnus not spotting his opponent two and
a half minutes this time and we do see
the handshake round two has begun uh it
looked like Magnus played 1v3 in that
game what will Vincent play here and uh
some quick early moves it looks like it
started as a ready opening like bringing
the night out on move one but it's
transposed into a kind of a mix between
the reti and the English with some weird
porn moves white sting very flexible
Vincent as you mentioned yesterday
Lawrence he's learned a lot from Peter
lekko his mentor his coach and uh yeah
this is a very classical type of setup
why it's going to get castled white has
an extra Central Pawn we saw Fabi on the
black side of this Pawn structure uh
yesterday a couple of times with uh
pretty much colors reversed
often white throws a port forward in the
center tries to gain space accepts a set
of hanging pawns on D4 and C4
and uh has a very active chances
but uh yeah I tend to love these
positions I've seen so many games by
Vladimir kramnik where he somehow
manages to manipulate the pawn structure
in favorable ways as white uh black
meanwhile has to play with pieces more
than pawns but
okay solid start for both uh what do you
think who will this yeah
I think this is right up camera's Street
to be honest uh you put the queen on E2
you bring the Rooks into the center I
fully expect them with Queen E2 here for
example by Kmart
um
you can play D3
uh you can also put the Knight on E1 uh
sometimes I know it looks very odd to do
that but momentarily you you uh pin this
Knight you might even be able to advance
with the pawn to F4 but Vincent plays
the more classic way meaning too Fabi
will play Queen C7 here I think or uh
perhaps yeah he does play Queen C7 with
A6 and A3 used to stop any night before
is very standard Rook B1 like this move
by Vincent just looking at that week B6
Pawn putting the 21 is excellent
um not that this is a major concern for
Fabi this position far from it Rook B8
is good Fabi is probably going to do the
same but the bishop on A8 just to over
protect the B6 Pawn D3 keeping
flexibility and it's at some point one
of these players is gonna have to make a
kind of committal move so far they're
just
jostling but yeah played by Fabi or
fairly standard staff Rook D1
yeah Lawrence I I've got to say I've had
almost this exact position a few times
as white and uh yeah it's always that
plan as you mentioned retreating the
White Knight to E1 pushing the pawns
forward to F4 G4 white often launches a
pawn storm on the king side but I love
fabi's plan meanwhile this is the plan I
always struggle with when I have this
position with white what to do against
black advancing Pawn to B5 if white for
example pushes with A4 then there is a
whole huge hole created on B4 Black
Knight will happily jump back to C6 and
round to the B4 Outpost the newly
created Outpost so Tempi are not so
important here it's not necessarily
about the speed of your moves about the
threats you create it's uh quite a
closed position a very slow position
still so you do have that luxury of
taking time for your plans and B5 is
very very annoying for Kyler if it does
land on the board look at the clock
times as well Fabi playing instantly
almost up to this point Vincent's
significantly down so it does feel like
in terms of who's more familiar with
this position this Pawn structure
haruana the light Square Bishops
meanwhile leave the board this is still
very standard stuff and I think we will
see either white tonight on G5 kicked
back or Bobby's gonna go for his plan
he's gonna start pushing his B Pawn
forward and there we go the Knight
forced backwards first of all no
attacking ideas now left for Vincent he
just simply has to retreat and after B5
I think Fabi is at least equal he's
solved all of his problems and on the
clock doing very very well I think yeah
this is still balanced objectively but
Fabiano will feel momentum on his side
it's looking a bit uncomfortable as he
ticks under the one minute mark
yeah Vincent taking way too much time
here actually I mean Vincent isn't yet
known as a blitz
specialist
um
but uh I he's taking
really a lot of time in this position
um
but his position is still theoretically
Okay computer didn't like that last move
Rook C1 looks completely normal to me
I don't like the transition in general
Black's Pawn structure is now much
healthier than whites white is left with
an isolated a pawn which could become a
factor later in the end game also
vulnerable on the light squares
potentially as uh Fabiano tries to prove
Black's Queen sliding over onto the same
diagonal as the white king queen F3
blocks that but okay Fabby he's happy to
allow Queens to come off the board he
pushes forward with B4 now okay
interesting white can take on F6 check
with his Knight and get the Queens off
the board
heading towards an end game does Vincent
try and seek some solace in this end
game it does feel like white should be
able to hold uh let's catch up yeah it
looks like he's going for this
I think he was just feeling the pressure
of instant and he wanted to get pieces
off the board maybe Fabi should have
kept the Queens on it would have uh
especially with the clock ticking down
it would have caused Vincent more
practical problems
sometimes you have to play the opponent
and the opponent's Style just as much as
the board and I think this suits Vincent
style more than a position with the
Queen's on yeah I actually think Focus
made a serious mistake playing B4 and
allowing this transition now what has
got no problems at all the C5 Pawn is
weak if you take on A3 it's no big deal
um yeah he takes on A1 Rook takes A1 and
now actually
I'm not going to say that
Vincent is much better here but
I mean
maybe he just actually is the bar
shooting up now for Vincent Kamer uh can
you just attack this C Pawn
uh 16 seconds with Vincent is he gonna
take on B4 and perhaps play D4 and plant
an eye on C5 and he does that a
classical wait still prefer this ever so
slightly for white is B Pawn on B4 very
very weak you can't play Knight A3
because it gets taken off the board as
well nice little tactic here Knight A3
Rook takes A3 exploits the pin so this
is already getting serious for Fabi if
he loses this be Pawn he's gonna have a
situation where he's gonna be suffering
five versus four on the same side with
all these pieces on critical moment now
for Fabiano feels like he's in a bit of
danger
I completely agree Lawrence here white
has one beautiful porn Island all the
pawns are connected defending each other
Black's passport normally a trump card
in these types of end games it's just
weak I'll be honest decision to go into
the end game to swap the Queens off
I think it was just a bit impatient and
now he's having to suffer the
consequences white tonight also on a
much better circuit than the Black
Knight and look at this this is a
typical top player type of move he's
just trying to swap off pawns now he's
trying to release the tension he's happy
to give away his power what is this in
order to make his task uh more simple
but Lawrence is he not just simplifying
down into a drawn end game the Rooks are
coming off
uh Black's night now can Retreat I think
Fabi is going to hold the draw
yeah and he found a way to bail out we
do see a handshake after the Rooks come
off it would just be symmetrical pawns
and pure nighting game Dead draw and oh
lucky Escape for Fabi maybe lucky I
don't understand if we just very quickly
go back here why didn't he after E5 why
didn't he take the pool
I don't understand and hear take on B4
looks like Vincent could have just been
a put up yeah it's just
a lot of this action everywhere let's go
to another game let's check out this
game hikaradakamura just takes the win
uh just before we got a chance to join
it this final position white is going to
crash through on the light squares
White's Queen and Bishop set up this
battery eventually Checkmate was coming
Hikaru also three pawns up which uh
doesn't hurt and let's go to Magnus
Magnus also a couple of Pawns up it
looks like two extra pawns we get the
handshake there as well look at the C4
and B5 pawns connected yeah Black's
Pieces Just paralyzed on the back rank a
nice smooth victory for those two giants
Nakamura and Carlson uh we see Nakamura
now watching the game between you Yang
Yi and riazancev let's check out Maxim
vashilagrav yeah let's do that
followed our Muslim and look at this
what an incredible ending we've got
three
the the the the the the triple pawns
here on the G4 and why does got the past
B Pawn now I have absolutely no idea
what's going on here this looks like
it's probably going to end up a draw to
be honest because yeah this is going to
be a draw because once the C Pawn is
traded for the B Pawn uh and this Pawn
is off the board
whoa yes well this position here the
double G pawns is an easy draw so merzin
really should make a draw here King G3
King F6 now you have to go Rook C8 try
and win this C Pawn Yeah and this is
gonna be a draw no question about it
that MERS in way too strong uh Mel might
play on a little bit out of inertia but
this is a classic
uh ending where you could have double G
pawns you could have Triple G pawns you
could have quadruple cheap ones in this
position and it's still a draw
and yeah mvl
yeah not gonna try and play on here
against Mercy who knows this inside out
still got one game going on Yu Yang Yi
uh playing
and this is a
probably yeah
looks like a win for black opposite
color Bishops do have a George tendency
but black has too many past pawns the
black F Pawn marching forward there will
paralyze the white king Black's King
goes over to guide the white uh the
black a pawn forward and we do see a
resignation uh you yangi as black the
higher seed does take the win but let's
go to the top board or one of the top
Boards of the women's section tanzong Yi
the world rapid Champion she's trying to
battle it out here against multevskaya
and uh what is happening on the board we
see an end game looks like uh black is
just blundered just as we join uh the
game it looks like Paul is dropped just
judging by the body language
it looks like Tanzania a big favorite
her opponent's really not happy with how
things have gone oh good but Lawrence we
could be here a long long time rook and
Bishop versus Rook is imminent Black's
Pawn eventually will drop and we'll see
the long grind begin it is a drawn in
game we should say but only tanzongi
with white can win this one let's get a
full screen of it because I'm always
curious to see how the top players do is
she even gonna get it because this a
pawn might just run so tanjong he would
love to have a chance at rook and Bishop
versus Rook versus uh matsuskaya who is
not a player I'm particularly familiar
with I know she had a great oh well it's
not even going to get there because
she's managed to
uh exchange Rooks so it's uh
it we're not even going to get a chance
to see a great draw there by Massive sky
yep a great draw and uh saving us from
that torture of Rick versus uh Rick and
Bishop versus Rook or saving herself
from torture there Mel Sav I think
tanzongi if she got that Blackboard
would have had great winning chances but
with that draw with that handshake it
looks like uh the top boards at least
have finished in both sections uh we see
the playing haul uh that a moment ago
and uh yeah the play is taking a break
in a well-deserved break after all that
action as we get ready for round three
few surprises Lawrence uh we saw that a
couple of drawers dropped by the top
players but other than that some of the
other top seeds cruising through
yeah I know what I would call serious
upsets especially in the open section
this round Magnus wins Hikaru wins as I
said I thought this was a tricky
encounter for Fabiano he got a bit lucky
just to get uh the draw as he did
against Vincent Kamer you Yang Yi wins
anishkiri wins Jana pomachi Duda all win
murazin also I mentioned I think the
difficult pairing for MPL but look I
think a draw was correct also David
Hanson not a slouch when it comes to
Blitz holding Alexandre gristook nor is
to sahakyan holding and draken mamajarov
wins uh and yeah we haven't really had a
standout underdog win in the in the open
section there and in the women's section
also uh looks as though we had a fairly
usual round hoyatzkina winning stefanova
winning Nana tag needs a winning
hurricane winning
um so so far
uh pretty standard stuff we do have on
the board who is this queen versus Rook
bishop and Horn
should be a draw
and we've got
who have we got here
two players are not too familiar with I
must say
yeah I think at least one local player
uh maybe even both of them from
Kazakhstan this is level material Queen
normally does balance out against uh
Rook bishop and pawn however it's
unclear who's playing for the win to be
honest it looks like white is trying to
repeat the moves trying to give a bunch
of checks what white here can't really
go too wrong if uh if the queen keeps
attacking the black king I don't think
the black king is ever going to find a
safe hiding spot but uh black also has
to be careful not to overpress there
will be situations where you get your
Rook a bit trapped or you might walk
into a double attack
okay what is that square for the bishop
uh okay uh six square for the bishop
looks good bishop and pawn defend each
other right now but look at this the
white king trying to come back and
yeah you have to be very very very
careful for both sides look how quickly
they're playing seconds left on the
clock only a two second increment it's
impossible if it's to gain too much time
on the clock uh there we go white stuck
low five seconds pretty much every
single move and uh yeah I like this
tenacious uh kind of perseverance from
both players just even if this game does
end in a draw they are now getting in
the blitz flow they are getting in the
Rhythm and okay some indecision from
White the checks continue
I can't see any other result than the
draw to be honest barring a huge blunder
but suddenly Black's pieces look a bit
closer that black Rook
oh the white king can start coming back
and we're going to help the White Queen
check mating ideas on the board if
you're not careful
Queen B5 is a threatening mate
okay oh yeah
big big threat there a moment ago I
think it is time for black to try and
bail out with a draw blacks clock
dropping down as well
three seconds
King B5 Queen C8
still a draw
just
just about but black is living life on
the edge the white king can come back
yet again
still dead drawn but uh it does feel
like white is the one asking the
questions now asking the difficult
questions black look at the peace
twiddling between each move visibly
nervous and uh the black king forced to
the edge of the board yet again
white actually has built up a little bit
of a Time Edge on the clock
once this game does finish I think that
will be the end of the round we will
start to see the uh standings Etc but
the players stubbornly continuing this
game black finally finds a way to keep
this game nice and safe no more checks
maybe the black pawn is going to be
pushed down some progress to be made can
he push the pool
oh if they want to push maybe white
would have taken that pawn off and
swapped off uh White can just uh
eliminate the black Rook black porn uh
make the draw because a bishop balloon
cannot give checkmates I think you can
do that now if White's Queen had given a
check on H5 but
keep pinning keep checking why not
we must be reaching the 50 move rule
here soon Lawrence don't have a score
sheet the players don't have a score
sheet so they can't tell but uh I think
the Arbiters can step in after 75 moves
um unless the rule has changed recently
the Arbiters count they only step in
after 75 if the players don't claim the
rule themselves
White Queen is just going to take that
pawn we will finally see a handshake not
enough checkmating material and a
marathon draw between these two
youngsters
foreign
that will bring us to the end of the
round I believe
uh I don't think there are many more
games going on so we're going to go for
a very quick break uh of course tons of
Chess this was just round two of 12 in
the open section today plenty more
rounds to go you can see the playing
Hall there
alive bustling
players waiting around for the next game
which will kick off in just a few
minutes we'll be right back for round
three of today's action don't go
anywhere
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench Chief
chess officer back again with more chess
terms here for you today we're going to
talk about the past Pawn the past Pawn
must be pushed you hear it said often
and that's because just about every end
game you see that isn't a blowout often
comes down to maybe someone's up one
Pawn or maybe even just the first person
to create a past Pawn is the person who
goes on to win that game we're going to
talk about what the past Pawn is and to
find it for you in today's video let's
do it what is a past Pawn a past Pawn is
a pawn that has no enemy pawns stopping
it from moving forward that means pawns
either on the file in which it resigns
or on the adjacent files that would
therefore capture the pawn should it
advance so if a pawn has none of those
things stopping its way then it's time
to push them baby as our boy Yasser
would say and as you hear mentioned on
many broadcasts that you would watch on
chess TV and on that note as we look at
our game examples we like to do this is
taken from Thomas chefsky versus rajaba
here white plays the move B4 5x Glam
which highlights again it's not how many
pawns you have but who's going to be
threatening to get a queen first after
black takes it white pushes forward with
gusto and because the Rook can't
blockade the pawn due to the light
Square Bishop this game is already over
black is going to have to sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn on B6 and white
would simply be up a minor piece note
that after the first move B5 should a
takes B5 have been played white would
have pushed this pawn and then trap The
Rook on A7 showing the power of the pass
Pawn as with it protecting the bishop
this Rook is completely out of the game
and white would easily go on to win
picking up pawns and just flexing the
rook's muscles over the bishop for the
rest of the game so here we see a
passport being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
rooms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello everybody and welcome back to
chess.com's coverage of the world glitch
championships we can see the playing
Hall there uh in US almati I should say
excuse me Kazakhstan uh the uh the
fantastically spacious playing Hall
everybody so far that I've spoken to
there has been very complimentary
towards playing conditions it is round
three of this year's Blitz championships
tons of Chess yet to be played in the
open section we have had the real
favorites well not really make any major
slip UPS yet Magnus Carlson Hikaru
Nakamura yanchish of Duda and the like
all on a hundred percent we did have a I
wouldn't even really call it a minor
upset Vincent came a drawing with the
white pieces against Fabiana caruana uh
in the previous round not a huge deal we
can see there some some of the standings
some of the players on a hundred percent
so far
um and of course alongside me David
Howard David nothing really yet to
report on the players just getting into
stride
exactly it's all about who starts the
fastest remember every single Half Point
matters every single point matters in
these early stages it is a 21 round
Marathon the uh the world Blitz at least
the open section but as we saw yesterday
in the rapid it often gets decided by
those little details by who can take the
lead who can get the more favorable
pairings and we see the top uh 20 here
in the open section all of these players
are on 100 we see Magnus uh Hikaru as
you mentioned plenty of those favorites
doing very well in these early stages
and of course some small upsets here and
there but most of these players are
Grand Masters very experienced Grand
Masters so uh nothing uh kind of too
surprising when uh one beats the other
but we do have the matchups for round
three uh coming in some huge clashes yet
again we're saying that every round now
Ivan chaparinov one of uh Bulgaria's
strongest Grand Masters he faces Magnus
Carlsen he's definitely capable of an
upset Ivan chaparinov uh very
experienced Grandmaster a former second
of players such as vesely tapalov uh on
board two David andreasian against
Hikaru Nakamura andreasian is a former
World Junior Champion so he's capable
he's very dangerous he's very very quick
Blitz specialist Yu Yang Yi faces vlamir
ivich also a very strong young player
from Serbia and a huge Clash Lawrence on
board for Sam shankland the American who
had a tough time in the rapid he faces
Anish giri
um yeah I mean there's so much action
ahead of us
which parents meteorite at which ones
catch your eye
um yeah I would say chippery enough
against Carlson is very interesting I
think ciparino is actually a very very
decent Blitz play as is by the way
andreasian he's a bit more of a blitz
specialist I don't think that's a walk
in the park at all for Hikaru Nakamura
ivich fantastic young player also will
give you Yankee problems Sunshine
against Gary also Sam is no slouch when
it comes to to Blitz chess I would say
of those pairings I think yeah
napomnushi will be the happiest I think
uh shimanov is stylistically really
poorly matched for janapomnishi so we'll
see what happens and in the women's
section uh big match on Boardwalk
against uh danielian Elena had a
fantastic rapid tournament uh she's
clearly in some form we actually know of
course big favorite on paper uh as is
stefanova on board two uh and Nana
zagnitzi on board three guia hariko is a
bit more of a a tough battle I would say
on board four two very solid very
principled players
so we will see what happens there in the
camera David we can see Hikaru Nakamura
getting ready uh to play
he is playing
um well a player who I've seen over the
years looking sharp actually Andreas
normally has quite long hair gone for
the trim uh he's yeah he's a very
talented player this is without doubt
Hikaru a much better player on paper
however he's a tricky tricky customer
when it comes to this and then we can
see Sam Shanklin playing against
anishkiri Sam is uh he didn't really
feature much in the rapid uh it seems as
though he didn't quite get the points to
be on the top boards but as a chance
here can never be ruled out lovely
little lightweight shot there yeah yeah
Lawrence uh check out fabby's twin
brother his identical twin just on the
board next to him in shot
I'm uh just kidding of course that is
very strong Grandmaster from Turkey but
yeah nice view of playing who there as
where's the twingo where did he
disappear he's there hiding as we
mentioned them if you had bad eyes you
could mix them up that is that is an
uncanny resemblance those two looks as
though we're gonna have the games kick
off
yeah and the handshake starts the round
which one are we going to follow
Lawrence which game should we focus on
in round three
um I think we should go for andreasian
against uh Hikaru Nakamura to to start
things off
yeah so Nakamura is one of the 20 I mean
both of these players they're part of
the 28 uh strong leading pack on 100
right now it starts as the Italian game
uh very very topical very trendy opening
Choice I've been playing this for years
myself and just over the last five six
years everyone's been at it and uh every
time I see Hikaru play he seems to put a
new spin on black setup uh he's maybe
the world leading expert on the black
side of this opening and here we go he'd
pushed forward in the center we see a
quick Trader porn star very theoretical
position this is all still well known
stuff black looks like he solved all of
his problems like has a nice spawn
structure very active pieces however the
white Knights are dancing forward
towards that black king a knight on the
F5 square is extremely strong once it
lands there and like a mirror look at
this still in his opening preparation he
preempts a night jump into F5 by
recruiting his Queen the queen would
have been attacked anyway so now the
White Knight jumping into F5 or one of
the knights that will at least cause
less trouble and andreasian you saw his
body language there just for a second he
kind of closed his eyes he's trying to
remember he's in recall load because
again this is a well-known position and
uh does he know it does he is he as
familiar with the ideas as Nakamura
that's the question I like how Nakamura
is showing a lot of respect to his
opponent playing pretty much his best
openings uh however this is supposed to
lead to equality if uh if both sides
know what they're doing Nakamura bogged
down by all of those draws in the rapid
section he will want something a bit
special he won't want to for example
just swap off this white knight in the
center because that will lead to a very
balanced position
how does he keep the tension well we see
a night retrieve from Nakamura will this
Black Knight and F6 just be defended
lots of choice but a balanced start to
the game you would say Lawrence
yeah it's kind of standard position I
don't think Hikaru will be too unhappy
here I don't love how uh andreasian has
played the past few moves I I don't know
why he didn't plant a knight on F5 a
little earlier but the position is is
relatively balanced okay this uh
transformation I think andreasen is
going to be quite happy with you can put
the queen on F3 now uh simply improving
the queen put the Knight on F5
um
the bishop can sometimes come out to E3
to neutralize this bishop so I I he goes
for nine to five immediately in F6 this
is all a bit strange and the computer
not loving this at all I wonder why that
is
seems as though there might be some
tactics
exactly uh it works right out of my
mouth Lawrence it feels like there
should be some tactics just visually
Once a Night arrives on F5 in any
position or
there will be tactics against the black
king and look at this andreasian which
movies he played okay he brings his
Queen out I'm being told there was a
very strong blow uh which would have won
a pawn for white in that past position
white could have played Rook D1 maybe we
can show this Lawrence just a couple of
moves ago andreasian instead of Queen G4
Rook D1 and uh after Queen to F7 for
example Bishop takes H6 winning a pawn
the whole idea is that after Bishop
takes F5 he takes F5 uh getting rid of
this white knight uh then Bishop B3 at
the end would be a monster threat so
there's no time to take White's Bishop
on H6 so a missed opportunity for white
for andreasian there can he keep the
momentum can he keep these tactical
ideas up his sleeve Nakamura looks very
uncomfortable you've got to say uh low
on the clock as well Hikaru has white
lines up these sacrifices in front of
the black king Bishop takes H6 for
example the idea we just showed is still
on top it's still a threat in the air if
black ever eliminates the White Knight
captures the White Knight with his
Bishop then I guess the bishop long-term
advantage and Hikaru playing with fire
he's uh is he bluffing now is he just
saying to andreasian you can calculate
all of these sacrifices I don't believe
in it the black queen at least a good
Defender now
Lawrence I've got to say I'm standing
for Black dead for Hikaru I'm I'm scared
but at the same time I really like his
last move because you really want to
take on H6 but actually after just G
takes H6 queen 6h6 king G8 there's no
immediate follow-up you would love to do
a little Rook lift of course the bishop
controls E3
so it doesn't quite work out and that's
why he's gone Bishop B3 first in order
to set things up rook 63 and now Bishop
B3 but with all of these trades the
power of White's attack diminishes and
after Bishop takes P3 8xb3 I actually
feel like Hikaru is in full control now
because there really isn't a
a knockout sacrifice after Bishop takes
b3a takes P3 you've just got to be
careful of this move as black Rook G3
Rooks hg7 but I think here we're gonna
see uh Hikaru trade some more pieces off
the board hxb3 and now I think he's
going to go 97 quite simply just get rid
of that problem Knight there we go
played and now you've got all these
weaknesses as white your attack suddenly
doesn't really exist and I think uh you
know Kara is in great shape now now you
can take on F5 double on the the file
thing you've got to be very very happy
here as Hikaru we can see Anish gear in
the background
uh has crushed Sam's shankland so um Sam
not able to keep Pace Geary on a hundred
percent
yeah I completely agree with everything
you said about the uh the game in front
of us Lawrence Hikaru it feels like the
the quality uh that he has is now
shining through he survived the attack
which was scary he simply eliminated uh
all of White's attacking pieces
especially the departure of that White
Knight on F5 that signals the end of
White's initiative andreasian went all
in pretty much he gambled on an attack
against the black king but as soon as it
uh kind of fizzled out he's just left
with ruins look at that white porn
structure look at the Double B Pawns
they are going to drop off long term
look at the white doubled F pawns not
impressive either what is the White
Queen doing now on G3 you've got to ask
her the question she's completely stuck
she can't make a single move
white trucks can't make a single move
either they're both tied down defending
pawns it's pretty much zuk Swang any
move that white makes is gonna worsen
his own position
um it's rare to see this in the middle
game with Queen still on the board
andreasian desperately tries to
sacrifice the pawn he pushes to B4 he's
trying to open up his Rook on a one he's
trying to get one open file at least to
break through to get to Black's position
but I think it's just not gonna work
look how classy this is from Nakamura he
grabs a pawn he says yes you can get
active with one piece I'm gonna shut you
down yet again swap the Queen's off it's
just a very consistent strategy swapping
off your opponent's best pieces it's
removing any danger any risk from the
position here car is so good at doing
this and
surely he's going to win this end game
the evaluation bar sets the advantage is
less than it previously was but it's
safer than it previously was and I think
that is exactly what Hikaru was looking
for look at this again H5 locking down
the king side black is a pawn up on the
other flank so why take any risk at all
sooner rather than later White's pawns
are just all going to drop off
textbook
yep uh you know as soon as uh Bishop E3
and Bishop E3 happened I I felt the the
energy slip away for Andreas
Hikaru is just not going to make a
mistake here there's just no way he
doesn't convert this he's this is a a
mop-up job that he's going to take on on
F2 take on F5 he's going to take
eventually on B3 he's gonna be yeah he's
gonna do it this way as well how many
pawns up is he going to be here he's
already sort of three pawns potentially
yet
okay Rook A8 trying to set up some
mating
um attacks but yeah he's gonna take on
F5 it comes back now there's no issue
for The King The King comes to G6 and
andreasian has had enough rightly so
let's go to I was going to say let's go
to Magnus Carlsen but games already
ended Magnus has beaten chaparinov uh
already
so
those guys keeping Pace Andrew scary
shimanov I am putting the curse on
everyone has beaten yeah napomnishi
that's a massive massive result
congratulations to Shimano I thought
this was a bad pairing for him but just
a piece up
looks like a nice uh nice strategic win
there by Shimano just completely
outplaying his high rated opponent
Magnus we've got to say we didn't manage
to follow that game much but it was a
typical Magnus effort just a long grind
opposite color Bishops but with Rooks on
the board you won a pawn and uh yeah
managed to break through eventually
let's check out some of the games that
are still going Lawrence oh we come in a
moment too late there but and maybe a
surprise results it looks like Danny
eliane has one just judging by the final
position on the board look at this white
king caught in the crossfire checkmates
about to occur no way to defend against
the combined might of Black's Queen
Black's bishop and rook and a surprise
taking down one of the highest rated
players
okay and second handshake we see there
from Hikaru and uh andreasian I think
that was after an analysis they were
just nicely discussing that game uh so a
handshake to say good luck to each other
for the rest of the rounds but again
most of the favorites
cruising through maybe a few surprises
though for the first time in the
tournament such as naponiashi dropping
uh dropping to defeat that
definitely napomniashi in the uh in the
open section that's quite a big uh quite
a big shock Duda did meet Radley muradli
is a very very strong Blitz player by
the way it's been crushing online
recently uh sarin is up there
um Abdul saturov looks like he's gonna
win to be on a hundred percent Hans
Neiman though lost to pranav now you
might be saying hold on who is pranaf
pranav is a blitz God uh has been
crushing online recently that doesn't
surprise me at all by the way pranav uh
this was on board 14 has beaten
bluebound in ditch and Neiman okay and
is rated 24 40. that's all Laura
incredible start
Lords on our camera I was about to say
it's a dead drawn end game between give
a tad say I believe and uh good Nina
Valentina gunina very strong Russian
player but heartbreaking stuff we've
seen the first loss on time uh of
tournament one of the first losses on
time white simply forgot about the clock
was a bit too slow and a dead drawn
position
she flagged and that's the type of thing
that can happen in this fast time
control especially over the board three
plus two two seconds is not a big
increment so heartbreaking stuff there
yeah sorry to interrupt just a little
bit of drama in the women's section not
at all the the big game going on still
in the open section is this
game uh playing against uh tin and I
wonder if we can get uh some uh well we
don't have video of it just yet but
apparently this
uh we can go to the dubov game let's go
see Daniel duboff
uh
we he's playing against naranian let's
go straight there
and uh it looks as though wow what a
what a tricky position the pawn is on
the seventh white is an exchange down
Black's King is weak
Daniel is probably going to try and play
for a win here I would expect with white
yeah and uh look at this tactics on the
board Bishop takes F6 boom winning a
pawn because now Black's pieces are
overstretched and okay a nice tactic
there by nariana if the White Queen had
been taken white would have made a new
Queen if the white Bishop had been taken
the Black Brook would have fallen so he
finds a way now riyadan to uh exchange
off and wow we're going to a king of
Pauline game what is the evaluation here
black has to be extremely careful black
is a pawn down however it is a doubled
Pawn for white and I think nariana has
found a really nice way of keeping the
balance you don't want to rush towards
the white pawns because then you will
get kicked back but look at this the
white king is going to come round the
long way
is black able to hold Lawrence it's it's
really hard to evaluate in two seconds
from Ariana oh he went down to one
second there
he's racing against the clock and racing
against this white king that's coming in
and it does look like white has the win
here he gets the opposition and look at
this now F fighting technique yes I do
buff F5 if this Pawn is captured white
sits with the King on F4 Black's King
will have to give way but now it's a
race who's gonna get there faster it
looks like the white Pawn is one move
too quick it's gonna promote Black's
Queen was a Black's new Queen would have
dropped off in that variation and dubov
wins the wrist he wins the game
lovely bit of technique they're finding
that F3 move by uh in that ending uh to
beat uh
naranian uh from India Daniel dubov
therefore keeping pace
with the leaders and uh after all that
action looks as though
things are pretty much settled we will
go for another very quick breather as we
go into round four
uh no super duper major upsets I would
say just yet
the van favorites
still keeping up the pace Hikaru
Nakamura Magnus Carlson especially
Anish Geary now very much in the mix
perhaps the big upset actually there was
one wasn't there shimanov beating the
pondichi that's quite a blow for
janapomnushy but plenty more rounds to
go we'll be back in just a few minutes
with continued coverage of this year's
World Blitz championships don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
ERS championships taking place in
almatic Kazakhstan we're already on
round four uh the games will be kicking
off soon we'll go through the pairings
as well as soon as we have them before
we go there though I'm alongside uh the
one and only David Hal David it's been a
pretty standard start so far but there
was a little bit of a strange incident
in round one
that's right for those viewers just
joining us in round one we almost got
off to a very dramatic start when uh the
new world rapid Champion the reigning
world classical Champion Magnus Carlson
turned up two and a half minutes late to
a Blitz game where he only had three
minutes on the clock so he basically
gave his opponent an extra two and a
half minutes on the clock gave him a
handicap there and yet he still managed
to pull through and win Madness so very
dramatic I'm not sure the reasons behind
uh the delay that he experienced maybe
he was celebrating after yesterday's uh
Victory yesterday's gold medal uh maybe
it was just a delayed trip to the
tournament Hall I know the players are
staying quite a distance from the venue
but uh either way Magnus managed to
avoid an upset there and ever since he's
been cruising uh we mentioned Magnus is
on three out of three Hikaru Nakamura on
three out of three now
um after that very very surprising start
to the day
since then it's been smooth sailing and
we do see a crowd of players Gathering
they're just waiting hanging out trying
to stay in good spirits uh before round
four this is uh still not even the uh
the one-third Mark of today it's 12
rounds in the open section so still
plenty of action plenty of rounds left
uh maybe we can check out the standings
Lawrence uh here we see the standings of
the women's section where there are only
six players still on 100 on three out of
three small group now yes small group
but uh very popular names antonette's
stefanova uh
harika uh all super experienced Grand
Masters Paulina shuvalova now this is a
name that we haven't spoken much about
Paulina one of the top promising young
players coming through uh she reached
over 2500 In classical chess extremely
talented I believe she won the World
Junior Championships as well well if my
memory serves me correctly uh clearly
you know a massive Talent not really a
surprise that she's on 100 Elena
daniellen with with a massive Victory
beating goyatzkina in the last round
that's a that is an upset yes Alina is
extremely experienced and accomplished
but to win with the black pieces against
gray Arch connect is an upset she's had
a fantastic rapid tournament though so
she's clearly in form well done to her
and Natalia books are also strong
International master from Ukraine no
huge surprise there in the match-ups the
pairings round four
shuvalova against Stefan over on board
one zagnitzi against Elena danielian on
board two and uh harrigger playing
Natalia books on board three
um not so easy to call them by the way
there is a crowd of players uh lingering
over a board we'll have a look at those
pairings again I don't exactly know
what's going on here David
is a game still in progress in the open
section let's see if we can get a
clearer view of what's going on
yeah ah it looks like they're just
chilling maybe a couple of players for
playing Blitz or I mean some Applause
now I did see a couple of Arbiters in
that group uh one of the chief Arbiters
uh Anna strabenich there with the red
hair she was uh lingering so yeah it
initially looked like there was a game
still going but the crowd is dispersing
maybe it was just players relaxing
between the rounds by playing even more
Blitz maybe they just can't get enough
but uh there we go once that uh that
crowd has dispersed I do think we will
start to see the pairings come out and
uh yeah Lawrence maybe we can go back to
those match-ups you mentioned on the top
three boards it's all the leaders
against each other but uh tanzong Yi on
board four as well will be aiming uh to
catch up with that leading pack the uh
Chinese player there on a hot streak
after yesterday's gold medal in the
world rapid tournament meanwhile the
open section uh I think we do have some
uh standards okay not yet we don't have
any standings there we are still waiting
on those but
okay commentators curse yeah Paris uh
how and standings have just been updated
let's go in and check out uh the results
that we've seen so far so a bit of a
bigger pack here uh in terms of the
leaders we do see some of the familiar
names that we mentioned I think there
are
12 players on 100 still after three
rounds that does include of course
Magnus Carlson hey Karnak mirror Anish
Gary nihaf sarin mama jarov pranav
though Loris you talked about a little
bit maybe the least familiar names to
some of our viewers
possibly unless you are a regular viewer
of things like title Tuesday on
chess.com and some of the speed
championships on chess.com you will know
the name pranav he is always up there
he's a tremendously talented Indian
Blitz specialist uh it doesn't surprise
me at all that he's on three out of
three uh and beating some of the players
he has he's just beaten Hans Neiman
hands in his own right is a very very
good display but pranav is just very
good so doesn't surprise me uh tons of
players on on 100
uh we've got manager of Abdul saturov is
up there uh we've got yanches of Duda
Shimano with that great win against
naponda she means he's up there but of
course everybody else won two and a half
is hardly in massive danger there are 21
rounds of Blitz we're gonna have 12 of
them today round four coming up so uh
just tons and tons to go and really
David as I mentioned a few times
yesterday and it probably applies even
more so to the blitz it really is all
about momentum uh these are momentum
tournaments uh if you start to lose one
two in a row then that can be three in a
row and suddenly four in a row and your
tournament is kind of destroyed and the
reverse also happens you get to put a
few wins together all of a sudden you're
back in it
um so you want to make sure you you
really take that momentum through in
each of the rounds
uh and uh yes we can see the lovely
shots of the playing Hall uh we've got
uh obviously
you know we've got the women's section
some some friendly faces there having a
chat some players already sat down men's
section open section I should say we can
see Ralph mahmedov there the experienced
azeri Grandmaster Parham matsudlu
amongst others
also they're having a good chat
um nice nice to see some smiles
Yeah you mentioned it uh Lawrence it is
all about momentum last year I did play
in the world Blitz and rapper
championships I think I had a three-game
winning streak followed by a three-game
losing streak uh and it kept going on
like that throughout the tournament and
these players they know that things will
be whittled down eventually we will see
a few leaders break out from the pack
but it's all about staying
psychologically stable and that's what
the top players are so good at doing and
talking of the top players we do have
the matchups for round four Magnus
Carlson against tomashevsky on board one
that is a rematch they did play each
other in the rapid section where Magnus
took an important Victory using the
hippopotamus defense uh on board two
Nakamura against nihal sarin what a
match that's going to be to speed
Specialists the young sarin teenager
from India very dangerous as he's shown
in what's pretty much been his breakout
year uh this year at the top level Abdul
sotorov former World rapid Champion up
against you Yankee Anish giri taking on
shimanov the destroyer of yandere
ponieshi and Duda playing the youngster
that we mentioned pranav another name
that might not be too familiar to some
of our viewers Dennis lazovic another
specialist online he takes on the final
leader of this pack of 12 Shakira
mamajiarov some huge clashes of course
further down the table but uh those top
12 right now
who will stay on 100 who will keep the
Run going that's the question and
Lawrence maybe some thoughts predictions
on the top boards
well I think uh Magnus Carlsen is just a
huge favor favorite against tommyvsky
yes tomaszewsky's on three out of three
but Magnus got white got the momentum
bad pairing for tomashevsky in my
opinion Nakamura sarin is a different
kettle of fish though in my opinion uh
yes Hikaru is favorite but nihal sarin
as you mentioned David had a breakout
year this year fantastically talented in
all formats classical rapid and Blitz
and is capable of upsets so I even
though I think Hikaru
should win this game it wouldn't
surprise me if we saw a bit of an upset
here and on board three Abdul saturov
against you I think this is actually a
bad pairing for you Yang Yi I'm just a
tour of
um is a tricky quantity he's uh his
style I don't think is that easy to
absorb
um you yangi a very theoretical player
Abdu satorov although knows lots of
interesting ideas in the opening a lot
of them are not mainstream he has an
unorthodox opening style in many regards
and I think that's going to be a tough
pairing for you Yang Yi Anish Gary also
uh playing against shimanov I think this
is a tricky pairing for Anish David uh
shimanov is a really really dangerous
little Blitz player I thought he had an
apomishi who for me is one of really his
top five Blitz players in the world I
thought he would do it Shimano winning
that with black
uh mate sorry maybe shimanov was white
in that game apologies uh nevertheless I
think that's an awesome uh opportunity
actually for Shimano and he's giving no
sloucher Blitz but sort of maybe
potentially awkward and we see some
players there I'm at Hamilton somebody I
know quite well got in the ring with
hilly with Eric Hansen uh taking a break
and we've got the local heroine
uh there we've got jeansai abdumalik she
just passed the camera with the glasses
jensaya from Kazakhstan
doing phenomenal things both in politics
chess she's got an academy now she's a
real role model
uh when it comes to uh chess in
Kazakhstan if we go down the list David
a bit more I'm going to ask you your
opinion how about this one do the pranav
is there any danger there for the rating
favorite
there's always a danger when you take on
a younger player especially a young
confident attacking player like pranav
and uh yeah Duda will not be resting on
his laurels in that game and uh here we
see the typical scene at NHS tournament
the players Gathering as soon as the
pairings are out they flock to those uh
those pairing sheets uh just to check
who they're playing check what board
they're on it's often a scramble in the
initial stages and uh they play as as we
see are taking their seats the games I
think will start in three or four
minutes
and uh yeah there's different approaches
a lot of players like to get in the zone
sit down at the board whereas others
they just want to have a good time put
their arms around each other have a
laugh and stay relaxed nice scenes there
between the two uh young Iranian players
Mike Zulu and Tabata by meanwhile Yugi
takes a seat
I'm just a tour of you mentioned that
one of the favorites maybe one of the uh
well one of the breakout stars of the
year at least and uh yeah Lawrence as
you said nobody can rest easy anybody
now at the top of the table on 100 is
there for a reason they have clearly
performed well in their first few games
they're clearly seeing the board well
seeing the clock well uh banging form so
uh yeah that leading group of 12 I
wouldn't be surprised if we do see one
or two slip UPS by the high rated
players here we see this champion vashir
legrath who has dropped half a point so
far but has been impressive uh
regardless facing Ahmed adley another
former World Junior Champion I mean
everyone here at the tournament seems to
have a great CV uh everyone that's so
established in the world of Chess and
yeah fun Forest duboff two of the most
creative players in the world sitting
side by side sharing a smile two members
of the Magnus Carlson team
sitting there
I mean what you would give to be over
there in Kazakhstan right now in that
atmosphere
at the moment the players do look pretty
relaxed but uh I'm pretty sure as we get
towards the end of the day tiredness
will kick in the nerves will kick in
everyone's gonna be looking a lot more
tense
uh meanwhile will we see Magnus Carlson
arrive late to the board what do you
think Lawrence will he be on time the
thing is always late to the board but
it's just a question of whether it's 10
seconds or two minutes I don't think
he's going to be too late this time uh
as you get to uh critical stages you
don't want to just be giving away uh
advantages unnecessarily
we can see that anushkiri and shimanov
sitting down see the Best Dressed player
of the tournament Anish giri he seems to
look sharp every single day yeah
yeah he does he does look sharp maybe
Jordan there we can see also potentially
uh has a a claim to best stress player
uh you know
apparently Jana publishi has changed his
shirt
perhaps because he was wearing he I
think he was wearing a t-shirt earlier
and it may very well be against the
regulations to where a normal low-cut
t-shirt and I think you have to address
in business attire or at least some kind
of formal wear
in a different shirt
yeah very strict on that no t-shirts no
jeans uh it has to uh has to look good I
think for the sponsors so the cameras uh
there have been uh some controversial
incidents in the past players wearing
shorts during the World Cup getting uh
kicked out of the tournament but no not
in this tournament it looks like
everyone is adhering to those rules
and uh yeah hikara looking in good
spirits he must be so relieved after uh
the kind of trauma of all of those
drawers in a rapid tournament suddenly
he's back on forming his favorite time
control and uh he's racking up the wins
it's back to what he's used to Nakamura
back to his stomping ground
yeah and I think this is the game
actually that we should focus on Hikaru
Nakamura against sarin listen feels like
the most juicy of the top board matchups
will of course keep an eye on all of the
games but
excuse me
um I was gonna say we should first see
if Magnus Carlson turns up and he has
turned up so
um relief there for all the fans
indeed Magnus Carlsen on time
and
we will go to the Nakamura match up
playing against siren you can see
Nakamura not
I you know his his mind isn't wandering
he's focused on the board because he
understands
he has got a very very tough match up in
front of him
right now in the form of nihal sarin one
of the
great talents from India they've
produced so many over the past few years
the the names just roll off the tongue
but this young man especially
is he going to be
the next Prince of India
big shoes to feel to feel
in uh
with vishianan dominating at the top for
so many years
but the moves are coming through and we
can see
we have an Italian
and we're going to get a fairly standard
position
by the looks of things
so far
yeah it is uh a spin on the Italian but
not the Italian game itself it's uh kind
of a hybrid they often call this The
Bishop's opening or a kind of a mix with
a Vienna where white hesitates to
develop the Knight out to F3 often this
does at least float the idea of White's
F Pawn pushing forward uh White f porn
can push forward very quickly now that
it's not blocked in the style of the
king's Gambit so this is like a hybrid
of all sorts of Kingsport openings it
feels like Nakamura is trying to confuse
his young opponent here just with the
move order we'll wait for the board to
catch up to refresh with some of the
moves we see uh on the cameras there
have been a few moves uh since but uh
looking very relaxed Nakamura maybe the
one spending a bit more time on the
clock at this early stage
that snackable strategy uh that's what
works for him so well uh in the blitz
format especially surprising his
opponent taking them out of
well-known Waters just uh forcing them
to think trying to confuse them here we
see Nakamura as you mentioned Focus mode
this is Nakamura in the flow uh let's
let's if
yeah let's get a full screen view yeah
let's get a full screen view of the
board while we get this transmission of
the moves correct let's see if we can do
that and there we go
um
we're gonna we're gonna have to look at
this one from the side for the moment
uh well we've got the moves uh ready so
nakamura's won the bishop pair very
early on but uh nihal has a very solid
position
D5 very nice move breaking out black
does have a very harmonious position as
you mentioned there Lawrence and the
bishop power won't live for too much
longer the light Square Bishops will get
traded eventually unless Nakamura can
find an ingenious way of uh keeping them
on the board and the more exchanges that
happen the safer Black's position
becomes uh White of course is never
really in any danger unless something
crazy happens uh White also has a very
nice Pawn structure but
it's very balanced and look at what
Nakamura has done opposite color Bishop
suddenly he's given up the bishop hair
but he's breaking out now with F4 and
this does look a bit odd to me I've got
to say uh White's King has only two
points in front of it now as shelter
Black's King looking much much safer
Nakamura is arguing that long term his
Bishop is potentially stronger than
Black's Bishop the C7 Pawn for black it
maybe we can highlight that is actually
under Fire right now uh White is in some
variations trying to take that pawn uh
using the fact that the black queen is
overworked defending her Bishop in the
center
and uh yeah it's I've got to say I'm
surprised traditionally this type of
Pawn structure is very very fine for
black uh to say the least but maybe in
this exact position your car is banking
on the fact that he's gained a bit of
time he's got a bit of energy in his
position his Rook is going to slide
across to E1 uh from A1 he's got ideas
already in mind of sacrificing on H6
with this bishop just to explode up in
the black king
I'm not saying it works right now but
it's something that Nihao sarin has to
calculate has to burn time uh worrying
about and there we go Hikaru he's so
good at this he plays the natural easy
moves quickly he's not worried about
being accurate or kind of uh super
precise every single move it's only when
things get really critical that's where
he spends his time
and uh it's those types of 80 90 type of
moves that he excels in and already we
can see nihau sarin Below on the clock
playing a move like C6 that feels a bit
cagey and can Nakamura now start to look
for those sacrifices to open up the
black king
Lawrence the more I look at it the more
like I like game three I have to say all
of these last moves are the moves I have
pinned you go A3 Rook A1 these moves
just can be played quickly you slowly
improve and as you said David it's more
about playing useful moves and playing
the absolute most precise move that
isn't actually required in a position
like this because black doesn't have any
kind of resource or eyes or clear idea
to punish you for for playing uh for
playing a bit more standard so for
example a move like King H7 and queen of
two another improving move now the queen
comes over to the to the king side
and all of a sudden as black
I would be very very concerned playing
this position here as Black Knight F5
now the Knight can come
three four but maybe Queen D4 maybe this
is his grand plan Neil Hall would love
to exchange Queens so it wouldn't
surprise me actually if we see a move
like King H1 or King H2
uh
and he does play King H2 there you go
anticipating Queen D4 now
Queen F3 exactly he wants to keep the
Queens on the board I really love this
by Hikaru I think this is the right
strategy because now the queen on D4 is
slightly misplaced so the queen comes
back to t7 also makes a bunch of sense
now a four by Hikaru okay he wants to
put this Pawn on B3 I believe and just
have a super solid Queen side structure
rookie eight I think he'll play B3 here
and he might even remove this bishop and
put it over on B2 and claim that the
bishop is actually doing a much better
job on the long diagonal wouldn't
surprise me at all to see Bishop C1 uh a
move like Knight E4 also makes a bunch
of sense because then suddenly you know
night night coming to F6 at the right
moment becomes an idea uh Queen F2 here
also was Queen up to announce Queen D4
so I'm not sure you can do that I think
he'll play rookie four I was also
thinking about this move as well but it
looked a bit weird to me
but there you go meanwhile meanwhile
Lawrence we have to say it's dramatic on
the clock for nihal sarin Nakamura is so
good at putting pressure on board and
clock he's created some small threats
and that has caused anyhow uh to burn
time answering those threats under 10
seconds for nihal surely it's going to
be difficult to keep Pace with Nakamura
as the moves come thick and fast uh the
Black Knight contorting itself
re-routing itself he wants those
exchanges he wants to simplify the
position but nihal down to is it three
seconds did he make that move with one
second left looks wow look at this
Lawrence there are ideas of sacrificing
the white Bishop can possibly take on G7
you have to really calculate this one
well if Nakamura wants to keep attention
he'll just Retreat his Bishop is he
going all in he does I think sacrifice
his bishop and uh look at this a huge
attack Brewing against the black king
and queen D6 Queen f8 great defensive
resource there by nihal using the queen
and now 94 95 is coming but it looks as
though hold on a second was it a bit
premature can you play F5 here as black
queen G6 is not gonna do it Knight F6
check
King G7 you can just take and then bring
the other rook in and it's surely all
over
I mean yeah the other rook's coming Rook
F3 Rook G3 lift that Rook up the board
win that black queen nihal sarin had
seconds left on the clock Nakamura
gambled with the sacrifice but it's a
gamble that's gonna pay off and uh look
at this the positions change slightly
white has one and Rook
change up but it's not so easy that
white knight is dropping Nakamura maybe
a bit over hasty in the way he converted
the advantage there suddenly he's
shaking his head he's miscalculated
something and all of a sudden we have a
completely random ending two pieces
Against The Rook with some pawns this
could go any way whatsoever I this has
been a major miscalculation by Hikaru
who surely had a winning position
showing he is so tough Knight D4
Yeah slip-ups by both players in times
in that time scramble remember nihal is
one of the best bullet players out there
in the world one of the highest rated
bullet players on chess.com same goes
for Hikaru but this is not going to be
one-way traffic Hikaru has won another
Pawn though on the queen side it's now
rooking three pawns for Bishop at night
that is a significant material advantage
that white a pawn watch out for it
moving further forward undermining the
black Bishop uh Hikaru meanwhile he
needs to trade off those Rooks he's
desperately begging for a set of Rooks
to leave the board because uh whites
Rook will be stronger than Black's two
minor pieces if uh those uh those other
set of Rooks disappear here nihal sarin
giving a check he's one one of the white
Pawns
this is crazy stuff and look at this a
Sacrifice by Nakamura giving up his Rook
for Bishop is the white apron gonna
decide the game blacks Rook cannot come
across to stop White's a pawn it's going
to become a new Queen
surely winning for white now
instructive stuff Nakamura giving up
material but running through with his
past Pawns
and Desperation for me how siren he wins
the white Rook but white makes a new
Queen this is game over too many points
for white no chance of a fortress but
Nihao
and you can see it on the body language
nihal knows he's losing
yeah well done by Hikaru great fight
there by nihal but it was just
too much
uh to to deal with with so little time
and Hikaru does come through a winner
Magnus Carlson meanwhile blew out
evgenie tomaszewsky uh tomashevsky but
didn't even know what hit him in that
game that was a complete murder but nor
did
has lost to you Yang Yi uh and Anish
giri has beaten Alexander shimanov Duda
did beat pranav in the end but what did
we say about Dennis lazovic as well as
an outside uh Underdog has beaten
Shakira mamajarov uh so lazovic the
blitz specialist online blood
Specialists are still doing phenomenally
well in the women's section chuvalova
does beat stefanova and Danielle and is
just having an amazing tournament
beating Nana zagnid said tanjong ji
though keeping Pace with the leaders
having beaten italic with the black
pieces so two leaders in the women's
section on a hundred percent and in the
open we've got all your big names still
on four out of four Hikaru Nakamura
Magnus Carlson and ishkiri yeah
has had a great tournament and
we've got the Young
well for many people unknown quantity
Dennis lazovic a real real tough player
I wonder who he's going to play in round
five we really enjoying Lawrence the
there is uh still action on the board
Neiman is fighting for victory I think
this is against Manuel Petrosian and uh
Hans Neiman here he's got an extra
pawners White
black is struggling here the black king
is so far away white has a two versus
one Pawn Advantage very strong
protective past Pawn that F Pawn he's
gonna start pushing it Forward he's
gonna bring his King in but uh if the
black king gets back towards the king
side in time towards those pawns maybe
drawing chances hasn't even missed the
moment he's
indecisively retreated
he's going the whole way back surely now
the black king is in the vicinity of his
pawns he should be able to hold this now
I think Hans has gone in the wrong
direction with his King with his Knight
and uh should be safety the position
repeating itself you've got to be
careful not to walk into a three-fold
repetition here hands he needs to find
something else I think he's blown it he
was winning when we joined this and wow
giving up his night gambling on his past
pawns here Hans Neiman got to push
forward but the Black Knight is stopping
those pawns from advancing and suddenly
who's winning what is the result Hans
Retreats Knight F7 surely Knight F7
Knight F7 was hard panicking down to one
second when he made that move black king
is coming round I think we've seen a
complete turnaround Hans is losing
losing suddenly the black king is
winning is the race he's gonna take that
white pawn and Hans resigns blowing a
completely winning end game
wow what a turnaround Adams Neiman and a
big surprise uh smile there by Petrosian
hasn't even discussed it with himself he
gambled because he had to win
he felt like he had to push in that
position but it all went horribly wrong
Hans Neiman still plenty of Chess left
but
you start losing a couple and you can
get in that death spiral David we've all
been there you lose two bad games and
it's three four and five and before you
know it you're wondering what are you
doing playing the tournament still got
some more action here on board 21 of the
women's section we've got
uh the match the kitchen against gaboyan
and all Armenian clash and what's going
on here Rook vs Knight
should be a draw
theoretical draw but of course very
difficult to defend if you just have the
Knight and only a few seconds on the
clock so huge Focus here in this
Armenian battle looks like Black's doing
a good job so far the drawing method is
to keep checking the white king as often
as you can force the white king away
from yours and uh there should be no way
a way to make progress I think we'll
have repeated the position three times
if black brings a knight back but
okay there we go a handshake uh well
defended there by the player with the
black pieces
time scrambles Galore law Lawrence this
is stressful stuff Blitz over the board
yeah absolutely uh we see it time and
time again
in these championships but uh fair play
the draw was the correct result there
still a lot of players hanging out
enjoying
the social element of this tournament as
well yes it's a serious tournament yes
it's a world championship but it always
has a slightly different feel when you
play a rapid uplits tournament in a in a
classical tournament you would never get
this camaraderie of players just hanging
out in the lobby or hanging out in the
playing Hall and talking but it's a bit
more light-hearted the blitz uh still a
very very serious Tournament of course A
world championship
but uh nonetheless nice to catch up with
some people and also it's a chance to to
catch up with people that you don't see
all the time such a big tournament
people from all over the world uh you do
of course Forge friendships in this
world as well and it's it's nice to
catch up with people that you might have
uh not seen for a long long time
yeah and uh meanwhile round four has
concluded and uh on that note we will
take a short break we will look at the
standings we'll look at the pairings for
the next uh round in a moment but in the
meantime go grab yourself a drink and be
back with us in a few moments
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
World Blitz championships here on
chess.com the tournament itself taking
place in almatic Kazakhstan but we are
bringing you all the action live and
direct I'm joined once again of course
by the main man himself grandma said
David hell David we've had a few rounds
tons of Chess left to play
who has caught your eyes so far uh in
this tournament
well actually uh plenty of players have
impressed so far it's still early of
course uh plenty of rounds to go but
I've got to say those favorites
especially Magnus Carson and Hikaru
Nakamura not once have they looked in
trouble on the board they've just
cruised to 100 to Four Points out of
four here we see the standings of the
open section and all of those at the top
those six players now on 100 they've
looked great uh Dennis lazovic special
shout out to him as you mentioned
Lawrence a star on chess.com a start of
title Tuesday events especially but he's
showing he can do it over the board too
and uh he has crushed some very strong
Grand Masters on his path to 100 in the
chasing pack there's only three players
on three and a half out of four and Eric
Hansen is one of them the chess bra Eric
Hanson he did tweet a couple of days ago
that he was feeling unwell he had
experienced flu-like symptoms but he's
clearly recovered and it's great to see
him back to his best after a slow start
a draw in the first round against
someone rated 5 600 points lower than
himself he's on a streak he's won his
last three games and he will be feeling
confident so uh those names stand out to
me but uh it is a long tournament as you
mentioned Lawrence and uh some
Superstars as well in the chasing pack
absolutely would love to see Eric make a
good run in the tournament very very
accomplished Blitz player of course
really made his bones playing Blitz his
channel the chess bar Channel go and
check it out that's where he plays and
it has been predominantly blitz so no
super surprise to see Eric actually
having a good tournament and as you said
in that big pack of players on three
points a lot of big big names they are
nowhere near out of it yet just one
point behind dewbot Vamp Forest
mamajarov near sarin the list goes on
pranav who we also spoke about as a a
sort of uh surprising Underdog although
if you've been watching all the chess on
chess.com over the past year or two you
will know that pranav is a very very
accomplished Blitz player a lot of
players clearly really looking forward
to seeing the big match up though Hikaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlson they haven't
been paired yet as far as I understand
but I think it's very very likely that
we see that pairing today I personally
would love to see Dennis lazovic uh play
either Hikaru or Magnus in the next
round I think there's a really good
chance that that does happen we'll wait
for the pairings in a minute but in the
women's section we've only got two
leaders David Paulina shuvalova and
Elena danielian both showing fantastic
forms so far
yep shrivel over looking impressive she
didn't do too uh well she wouldn't have
met her high expectations in the rapid
but literally started on fire well
deserved 100 of there and Elena Danielle
doing it the hard way beating some of
the top seeds like you said earlier
uh was one of her victims in the earlier
rounds she's looking good it's clear
that these two leaders will play each
other but yet again a huge chasing pack
and some big names there uh we do see
Danielle have the white pieces against
chival over can she keep up uh that
winning streak Mama Zada from Azerbaijan
against tanzongi badelka against harika
Arabic against gunina and the final uh
player on three and a half Natalia buxar
takes on Katarina Langlois who has
recovered after a shock first round
defeat the top seed of course in the
blitz section very uh many big names
here I'm also looking slightly further
down Alexandra castenuk Lawrence takes
on our good friend Tanya Sachse death in
a battle of two very famous uh streamers
two great ambassadors for chess
yeah
um and uh Tanya actually you know she
was showing some decent form in the
rapid yesterday
gotta say not a fey not uh massively
bullish on Tanya in this particular
matchup I've played both of them
extensively at Blitz and I can tell you
um Alexandra is a really tough tough
player especially with the white pieces
Tanya is going to have to be in
fantastic shape to hang out with
Alexander christenick in this game
really curious to see how bored one goes
though because I have to say I you know
I've also played Polina I've never
played Elena at Blitz and she's in such
good form and she's so difficult to play
uh with black as well I mean she's got
this very Orthodox style so I'm very
curious what happens then I want to say
another name good night Mama Zaza in the
mix gunai is a very very dangerous Blitz
player also had the opportunity to play
against her uh she could definitely make
a big run in this tournament as well she
didn't really managed to find her feet
in the rapid but it wouldn't surprise me
at all if in the blitz she starts to
shine
and we can see there all the players
gathering in the playing Hall walking
around loosening up Alexander Grace
shook
you know not really getting too involved
with the
uh with the uh with the other players
fraternizing less than the other players
we can see that that's battle javava
and uh
what a player he is uh one of the
biggest characters chess has ever
created really uh top bloke and uh
really I think I I Echo the sentiments
of a lot of people when I say we all
want to see him back to
his top level back to his prime he
really had a fall from grace he was
rated 2700 Plus in classical chess went
under 2600 which is just absurd he's his
talent is unquestionable I think we
would all love to see Bardo back to
playing the kind of Chess we know he can
play
that's what all his uh fans are of his
stream are used to
yes not such a big fan of his dancing or
his tasting music may I say but um
certainly when it comes to Pure chest
Talent very few have got what he has
some other players there are in the
playing Hall you notice how you don't
see Hikaru and you don't see Magnus uh
they do tend to tuck themselves away
between rounds you won't see Magnus
fraternizing with even somebody like uh
you know either the chess bras or uh
uh you know maybe some of his countrymen
who are there Magnus does like to have a
bit of a alone time between rounds
um he and he's fully focused
herrings are out David let's let's see
what we've got for round five
yeah we have some huge matches for the
first time in the tournaments some of
the top seeds are facing off against
each other and wow Lawrence look aboard
one Jan Christoph Duda against Magnus
Carson
huge game they face each other so many
times both over the board and online
over the past 12 months with mixed
results trading blows Duda certainly
capable of upsetting Magnus there or to
as well equally big Anish Geary 100
against Nakamura can Anish keep up his
great form in the blitz so far it's
going to be a challenge though up
against Nakamura and uh you yangi up
against the youngster Dennis lazovic
Eric Hansen has made his way up to board
four as we mentioned he faces off
against vasive durability he will fancy
his chances there uh very balanced on
paper Anything could happen and uh the
chasing pack below that bash headed by
vashilagrav the current world of Blitz
Champion but it's all about those two
top two boards Lawrence
I mean where are we going to focus on
it's uh you could take your pick just
huge matchups
it's been a few rounds since we've
actually been on Magnus I think we
should look at Duda Carlson because you
answered off more than capable of eating
Magnus if he gets a sort of position uh
he likes giri Nakamura as she said tough
bearing for Anish I always feel like
hikaru's got a little just one over
Anish uh in recent times I will be
keeping a very keen eye on you young
jigan's lazovic though I think this is
actually a tough pairing for lazovic
young years is a really dangerous player
with white and
I would like to see lazovic stay in
contention because I want to see how he
fares against both Magnus and Hikaru but
we'll see and as you said Eric Hansen
will fanciest chances against Duro
Bailey absolutely this is a dream
pairing for Eric Hansen three and a half
out of four and you get vasive
durability no offense ambassadora Valley
of course class player great Grandmaster
but if you were Eric Hanson and you uh
could have bumped into whoever else MBL
or uh you know somebody like a Fabiano
caruana he'll be fancying this one for
sure
mm-hmm
and uh yeah we will be following all the
games all the results as they uh tick in
meanwhile uh yeah I think the games will
start in a few minutes we're still
waiting for the arrival of some of these
players
um so yeah dude Carlson I've got to ask
for predictions you mentioned maybe
Anish uh struggling in recent times
against nakamurbo predictions on these
top two boards Lawrence
really tough to do a prediction uh
Buddha Carlson
I'm gonna go draw
I think uh I think the answer stuff will
will not want to lose I think he's going
to employ a little bit of a slightly
risk less risky strategy and on board
too Anish Geary playing against Hikaru
Nakamura we're actually going to stay
with this game as it's a real Fan's
favorite
I'm actually gonna go zero one I'm gonna
go with Hikaru on this one uh
I think that uh
Anish has really struggled against
Hikaru in recent times I like the fact
that Anish is very poised and he's
already thinking about which opening he
wants to employ they've played so much
chess together
in recent times
but Hikaru looks like he's getting a bit
of flow a little bit of momentum and
he's probably the most dangerous player
when it comes to Blitz if he does build
that momentum he can become a runaway
train
and so I'm gonna go with Hikaru Nakamura
David do you echo my feelings or do you
think it's going to be slightly
different
I mean these two top pairings they could
go either way of course but uh I will
say we will see the first uh surprises
as you mentioned uh Duda could employ a
maybe more solid strategy against Magnus
I actually think Duda has great chances
of causing an upset there dude are
looking good in the blitz so far and I'm
gonna backanish I do think Anish is
notoriously difficult to beat of course
uh I think he might try him for a
straight Nakamura and uh yeah we'll see
where that game takes us I do think
Anish with white especially is forced to
be reckoned with so uh we will see what
happens once those two players arrive
we're waiting for uh Magnus Carlson as
usual the storyline of today so far of
course and uh mcmura arriving with a
smile a little drug with a niche
looks like we are also waiting is this
board four between Eric Hansen and
durability neither player at the board
so far and I know durability these days
lives in the US uh Eric Hansen I believe
uh knows him very very well there we go
players have arrived we'll see a
handshake in a moment some confusing
stuff happening behind them perhaps
looks like uh they were just maybe
struggling to find that board and
handshake
yeah this game I do predict uh to be
very very wild both players with very
aggressive Styles but Duda meanwhile
Magnus is keeping him waiting he's
keeping us waiting but the handshake
comes the world champion arrives and I
think with that we will shortly see the
first moves
land on that board
yeah it's uh this one is uh it's really
heating up it shows that the blitz now
has fully commenced this is only round
five for a member of 21 but already some
of the top dogs facing each other and uh
it's in these types of clashes that the
title will be decided eventually uh here
we go the clocks have been pressed a
niche opening with 1d4 we see a queen's
gun but a client from ikara Nakamura
very quick moves uh at the start of this
game very theoretical stuff and Lawrence
you expected
well we were discussing maybe a solid
approach a slower approach from any
scary this is certainly
not the most aggressive line but it will
ask Hikaru maybe some long-term
strategic questions
uh C5 here for a thematic Pawn break and
we'll see a bunch of exchanges in the
center of the board there we go a set of
Pawns a set of knights have left
I do slightly fear that we might see a
well-known draw variation
but how ambitious is Anish giri feeling
this is well known to end up in a draw
if uh oh if dark Square bishops come off
the board
I've seen plenty of draws between Timo
retrovov and Hikaru Nakamura in this
variation they've debated discussed this
variation several times in the past
Anish giri now has a choice between
trading off dusk where Bishops or just
castling the white king
yeah not the most uh exciting of
openings that's for sure white with that
long term positional Advantage playing
against this isolated Pawn but Black's
minor pieces and development fully
compensating for that deficiency uh with
the Rooks being able to come into the
center and not really being able to
attack that pawn of course also a lot of
pressure here and after 94 96
we could get one of those positions
David a move like Queen D2 and then
there could be a big trade on D4 and all
of a sudden
we've got a very dull
a symmetrical position
and that is a real possibility yeah
I could tell by the tone of your voice
Lawrence you're not so enthused by this
game anymore it does look like a niche
has taken the uh kind of risk adverse
approach to the pragmatic approach he
knows Hikaru is dangerous Hikaru is on
form and here we go a set of knights
have left the board instead of Queens
have just been traded off as well and
yeah this one is fizzling out towards a
draw very very shortly unfortunately
Hikaru does know everything there is to
know about this type of opening he's an
expert in the Queen's government decline
so it would have been difficult to get
an opening Advantage anyway but a niche
didn't leave any tension in the game the
Rooks will all eventually trade each
other off on the open files and White's
slightly Superior Bishop long term
cannot really make any Headway against
Black's solid structure
and uh yeah as was said in the feature
chat there uh yeah it looks like the
draw Gambit accepted not the Queen's
Gambit in this game Hikaru couldn't
really have pressed harder unfortunately
with black it's tough to do so a niche
uh yeah playing very solid stuff and
looked like a draw the players have
shaken hands they are discussing the
game let's go over to the other big
matchup of the round Magnus Carson black
against young Kristoff do that this one
much more tense Lawrence much more life
left in this position
oh yeah far more ambitious play by both
uh Duda and Carlson we have a kind of
um interesting position which has come
from a modern defense Magnus has really
been playing this modern uh or perk uh
consistently over the past few months is
that fantastic results in the Melt water
chest tour
playing now against Duda Queen C5 and I
think Magnus will be relatively happy
with his position actually it looks just
balanced to me but I don't see any
reason why Magnus would be unhappy he's
gonna double on the D file and then he's
going to make a decision about exactly
how best to improve the answer of also
not with an easy task here is what the
moves don't come that naturally as white
in my opinion here so let's see what Jan
shustoff goes with he goes with Knight
B3 Queen C6
okay that's three
yeah it does feel a bit loose for white
now somehow the white king not entirely
safe on certain diagonals some dark
Square weaknesses around that white king
long term watch out for that to become a
factor later and white tonight on B3 a
terrible Square for it I guess the idea
was to kick back kick away the black
queen but white tonight really
urgently needs to relocate re-route
itself also I'm looking at the clock
times Lawrence Magnus has had around 30
seconds extra 45 seconds extra on the
clock for most of the game and uh I
think the longer that situation
continues the more trouble we'll see if
we do that but Magnus offering a trade
of light Square Bishops is that a signal
that he's happy to just swap off pieces
happy to simplify the task and maybe
head towards equality or is this uh an
ambitious Try by Magnus white piece is
still a bit clumsy
yeah White's piece is still a bit clumsy
rugby too I like though this is a lovely
little move by Young just off the point
is that
if Rune tasty to Knight takes D2 now all
of a sudden the queen protects the A4
pawn and now structurally speaking we
have to say
all the pawns pretty much on white
squares but all of black spawns on dark
squares and that means that they are
targets for this bishop uh in a
long-term perspective and also this
bishop itself might suffer a little bit
now I don't think it's anything major
but hold on a second 93 comes suddenly
the D5 Square becomes an optimal post
potentially for that white knight
so if I play Knight E3 what are you
supposed to reply with there is black
because if you go fish Buffet I might go
Knight D5
yeah it feels like dude is turning the
tide slightly you're right Lawrence that
black Bishop is definitely the problem
piece in not just this position but any
future end games Black's Bishop is
terrible that's why Magnus is retreating
re-routing it but as you mentioned as
well tactics in the air now utilizing
maybe the pin uh on blacks Knight where
it's Bishop along that diagonal has some
tricky ideas and Duda jumps in Knight D5
direct threat has Magnus slipped up how
does he defend against this if Knight
takes Knight if Knight 65 White's Bishop
takes the black Rook I don't see any
compensation there for black or not
sufficient at least will Magnus have to
worsen his own Pawn structure blocking
with an ugly move such as G5 pushing
opponent just to swap off Knights white
tonight is just too strong surely
yeah I think he probably has to go G5
okay give us a check first the king will
go to H1 or H2 probably H2 I would guess
um and then G5 will happen
uh he goes to H1
G5 on the board takes takes but maybe
this isn't so bad because after Queen's
xf6 actually this bishop on H4 doesn't
have a camera to go to so he has to go
to E1 which
we should also mention the clock times
seriously favor Magnus here now this is
the type of position where the Magnus
effect could come into play we are
headed towards a slower position the
Queens have now come off it's an end
game and dude only has a few seconds
left two seconds for Duda as he makes
this move oh he's making moves with one
two seconds left look at the white king
as well caught in the corner in a box
could never really Escape due to
desperately trying to open up a path for
his King but look at this Lawrence
White's Bishop is attacking the A5 Pawn
but more urgently
Black's Bishop has found a fantastic
place a fantastic Outpost in the center
we will see a trade of a few more sets
of Pawns I think both of the a pawns
will leave the board and then it's a
question of whether Duda can neutralize
the activity of Black's pieces
suddenly the risks Magnus has been taken
taking maybe they're paying off what do
you think Lawrence easy draw yeah
you've got to hold not not at all feels
like a bit of a grind here for Duda
suddenly you know black has got the
active pieces got the Outpost on D4
Bishop G3 actually wins a pawn so hold
on dudo's already made a slight mistake
here because there was back rank
Checkmate threatened and now you can
take on H4 Bishop F4 and now you're
actually able to keep the C5 Pawn on top
so after Bishop E3 check King H2 The
Rook now goes to B4 it's very close but
it feels as though
look at that white king it's almost
getting checkmated it's having to match
up the board Magnus now also low on the
clock seconds left dude that's fighting
for his life he's scrambling he's
running with his King but okay the
positions change Magnus has won a second
Pawn in his quest for victory Judah I
think had to give up a second Pawn in
order to just break his King out of that
mating net and surely this is winning
for Magnus the h g Pawn's too strong
okay one point has dropped the C5 Pawn
but Magnus is simply going to start
hoovering up White's remaining pawns
white C Pawn is dropping White's King is
stuck on the edge of the board Lawrence
Magnus is going to win surely
yeah no question about it this is this
is going to be a win just one check is
not going to be enough for yancha Stuff
Duda it all went horribly wrong at some
point Duda did have everything under
control but it felt as though with that
Bishop Bonnie one he was gonna have
trouble coordinating his pieces and
Magnus just did what Magnus does which
is slowly impose himself and indeed
looks as though Magnus has in fact
already won the game uh we're gonna wait
for confirmation of that the video feed
is uh is a bit lagging uh but I can see
here on the board that the game has been
won Magnus Carlson
uh pulling away from the rest of the
field or is he we've still got you Yang
Yi against Dennis lazovic what's going
on there
Yang Yi wow pressing
it
seems
wild position but dude uh here Dennis
lazovic is the exchange down Yu Yang Yi
has The Rook for Knight Advantage
however the pawn structure does favor
Black slightly there are some threats
against the uh white king I was going to
say but suddenly there's a pin Black's
Knight has pin on itself pinned
desperation now simply no way to keep
that night intact Dennis Las Vegas is
having to throw away all of his pawns
simply to trade off pieces to get
himself out of this pin and now it's a
simple simple process of trading off
pieces for you Dennis lazovic one of the
uh dramatic one of the underdog stories
of the tournament I think he's crushing
to defeat here you Yang Yi looking very
impressive and has Dennis lazovic
resigned I think he has due to the pin
on his night on the third rank
yeah still so few drawers very few
drawers apart from that Geary against
akamura Clash as everyone's taking risks
everyone's going all out for victory
here's the stat about draws looking at
the women's section
firstly top six boards all black
victories that is something you almost
never get uh that was in the top six
boards but here's another stat actually
I should probably correct that it might
even be
yes top six boards top 20 Boards of the
women's section no draws
absolutely no draws in the top 20 all
decisive results uh they fight tooth and
nail hardest Fighters out there
um and tons of decisive results I should
point out that in the open sections well
we did have a draw Gary Nakamura Eric
Hansen is playing Dora Bailey that game
is still going on Eric
well it is a draw objectively speaking
but is he gonna magic something here
doubtful very very doubtful I mean King
C6 Knight A3
yeah you find it difficult to believe
that Eric is going to make something
work here
yeah looks like an elementary draw
there's no way to force the exchange of
knights in a favorable in any favorable
circumstances at some point Black's
Knight will find a way to sacrifice
itself for the white porn and durability
has found that uh found that path so
dead draw now no way to keep the white
Pawn intact
therefore a draw so decent results for
both sides they were still they'll still
sit on a very very healthy score but uh
maybe a missed opportunity small missed
opportunity for Eric Hansen with the
white pieces
possibly yes but a draw is hardly the
end of days he stays in touch with the
leaders as is Fabiano caruana beating
Alexander predker with the white pieces
and shimanov with another big win
beating dubov with the white pieces this
time he's beaten upanishi now he's
beaten dubov he is on four out of five
he's in the mix mamijarov staying close
to the pack as well so uh
you know a lot of the top guys are
hanging in there but Magnus Carlson
creating a little bit of Separation I
beg your pardon not quite you Yang Yi so
Yu Yang Yi and Magnus Carlsen will face
off in the next round that is the
pairing we do know
yup Yankee deserves his chance against
the champion and uh yeah he's looked
very impressive so far so don't write
off You Yankee but Magnus
inching away he will at least make
Nakamura wonder whether going for that
early draw against giri was the right
thing to do as you mentioned Lawrence
plenty of rounds still ahead we are
starting to see those huge clashes on
every uh board now at the top and uh
maybe some game's still going but uh
either way I think uh yeah the drama of
that round was resolved in a very
satisfactory way for the Norwegian
player
all right there's still some games going
here there are but we are going to go
for a quick breather as they come to a
conclusion
so far Magnus Carlson
showing no signs of
uh well stepping off the pace really he
won the rapid World Championships now
he's on 100 in the blitz uh World
Championships who is going to stop this
man will it be you Yang Yi will it be
Hikaru Nakamura or will it be somebody
else there'll be plenty more drama to
come don't go anywhere we'll be back for
round six of the wildlife championships
in just a jiffy
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
right
[Music]
right
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
chess.com's coverage of the world Blitz
championships
we are moving on to arrest stage for
today round six in the open a few less
rounds played in the women's section
nonetheless things are starting to
nicely heat up uh the big favorites
leading the way especially Magnus
Carlsen hot off his win of the uh rapid
championships yesterday
uh his form uh well and his desire to
keep winning has clearly not relented
whatsoever Magnus on a hundred percent
after round five dismantling with the
black pieces in the last round
Hikaru Nakamura not able to beat
anishkiri who decided on playing a very
solid setup with white but in two yangy
the Chinese Grandmaster who beats the
online sensation Dennis lazovic to join
Magnus
on a hundred percent in the open section
and in the women's section it's really
all been about
um the the black pieces in the previous
round the top six boards all black
victories quite astonishing but there is
only one player on 100 and that is uh
World Junior champion and one of the
hottest talents out of Russia Elena
shuvalova five out of five closely
tailed however by harika tan tanjong ji
of course won the world record
Championship yesterday and Valentina
gunina who can beat anybody on her day
David
um looking at those standings there for
the open uh how do you see things at
present
well it is starting to Bunch up uh at
the top a lot of players in the chasing
pack as you mentioned you Yang Yi will
have a his shot against Magnus Carlson
Magnus looking just at the top of his
game now I think full of confidence
after his victory in the rapid
tournament and it is up to Nakamura it
is up to Geary to try and show that they
can get that momentum back often the way
chess works is when you take a time out
when you take a quick draw the chest
Gods punish you so can Nakamura and Gary
get back to winning ways they are the
only two players half a point behind the
leaders so I think they'll both get down
floats they will both play players on
the lower on a slightly lower score
group of course in the chasing pack we
have the likes of Ganguly Duda duboff
sarin carwana I think is slightly
further down if we um if we keep looking
if we keep scrolling and yeah of course
no easy matchups it is just about
momentum as you said a bit earlier you
don't want to to let up at all we will
be reaching the halfway stage of the day
after this next round so the players
know they'll get a bit of a break they
will they will still have plenty more
chests to go I don't think however we'll
see the likes of Nakamura giri take any
more uh kind of Safety First approaches
I think that was their one game of the
day and uh they'll get back to going all
out maximum maximalist for the win they
know they need to chase Carson they
can't expect Carlson to drop any points
to the rate he's going uh so every move
matters at this point meanwhile we see
the tournament Hall players looking very
calm very relaxed I think this is the
chief Arbiter nearest the camera talking
to uh his comrade his uh compatriot
there
uh I think that's guy mcgamy from Iran
very strong Grandmaster and uh yeah
again that is always the most tense
moments as we wait for the pairings as
we wait for the standings to come out
everyone has that different approaches
Magnus and Hikaru they both have their
own special rest areas their green rooms
where they chill between games they're
very lucky in that regard I've always
wondered why fide do allow certain
players those special privileges but uh
by the way it looks like Duda there in
the foreground the others are waiting
itching to get going uh maybe we can
check out as you mentioned uh those uh
okay we'll wait for the standings for
those uh pairings in the women's section
I don't think they're quite out just yet
but Lawrence uh what have you been most
excited about today what have you been
most impressed bye
um for me it's it's always I enjoy
seeing the up and coming players the
dark horses I I love seeing an underdog
perform
um so for example in the rapid we saw
the lives of Vincent Kamer of Vladimir
save we want paper our underdogs causing
some of the big guys a problem and today
I'm just keeping my eye out for
one of those players to potentially
break through Dennis lazovic took a big
hit losing to you Yang Yi so it's going
to take him a few rounds to get back
into the sort of mix but for example
Alexander shimanov
has done fantastically well beating
dubov and napomnishi so far you've got
the likes of hike Marta rosian who could
do something fair to save himself
is up there nihal sarin although maybe
not considered a pure Underdog anymore
is up there and the list goes on
um so
you know clearly uh you know when we see
these top young players it's it's always
great to see because they don't get a
chance to play the absolute Elite a lot
of the time so this is their their big
chance their big moment I will say going
through the list of players David that
some Monumental uh results are coming in
janaponashi losing Iranian
I don't even think is on 50 or maybe 50
percent he's having a torrid time
and already with you know losing so much
uh so much traction in this tournament
you fear for his chances uh moving
forward here it looks like he's just
going to be out of the running
straight away
so yeah
these tournaments are brutal Lawrence I
remember once I played I think it was in
the world Blitz a few years ago I lost
round one I drew round two and my reward
for that was playing Levon aronian in
round three so you often see uh even the
top seeds struggle in the initial phases
often they might be uh kind of lingering
around 50 plus one around the middle of
the pack but as we also discussed
earlier it only takes a little burst of
wins a burst of energy uh to catch up a
bit later on there we see pamagara and
very good spirits uh in the playing call
Lawrence I want to ask you the question
we see these little cliques these little
friendship groups uh in the tournament
Hall between the rounds what would you
be doing who would you be chatting to uh
between the games
you I would be chatting to you uh no I
mean it would be uh well Magnus isn't
there Fabi I think hides himself away
pretty much maybe you know somebody like
uh I don't know the chess bras uh
somebody like uh iron tari if he's
always a good guy to chat to
um
who else uh
who maybe MBL wouldn't mind he's he's
nice to talk to although I think he's
quite focused I don't think he's being
too uh sort of uh chatty between rounds
Jordan Jordan Brown Forest I'll be with
Jordan there we go there's your answer
it'd be me and Vic Gordon uh hanging out
good care answer
yeah I agree and uh now we did see uh
more of the players but we do have the
standings for the women's uh section
they have later five rounds now shovel
over you mentioned separating herself
from the pack taking the outright lead
she is chased down by three players
harika who uh I was very impressed by
played The Olympian earlier this year
while eight and a half months pregnant
that was incredibly impressive she did
so well there uh won a medal in the end
for a team tanzong Yi one of the players
of the year so far and Valentina
on a hot streak she was leading the
rapid section as well remember after
what was it four or five rounds uh
before falling back slightly and uh yeah
I want to say Lawrence as well shout out
to Tanya sachdev who did actually take
down kostenic with the black pieces in
that huge clash between two of the most
uh famous women players in the world so
um yeah lots of tracing to be done by
those uh players behind shrivel over
there but meanwhile it does look like
the players are taking their seats that
must mean the pairings are out can we
perhaps take a look at some of the
match-ups for round six
and uh we have them tanzogi uploaded she
gets the leader Paulina shrivolova uh
harika plays gunina lagno plays a little
Elizabeth Pates the most recently
confirmed Grand Master or one of the
most recently confirmed Grandmasters in
the world congratulations to Elizabeth
pets Tanya from Riding High after that
win against kostenic even bigger
challenge now Alexandra goyatzkina and
Elena Deli Danielle playing antoinetta
stephanova a former women's world
champion I mean everywhere you look
there's just huge games I wish we could
follow them all of course but uh how
about the open section let's go there
Lawrence what are the Paris for round
six in the open oh okay okay
but what I will say is I was far too
dismissive of my good friend and our
colleague Tanya sachdev uh David I said
she was gonna have a tough time against
Alexandra castenia with the black pieces
apparently not beats Alexandra castenia
with black putting her to four out of
five now she's got a really tough game
in the form of Alexandra goyatzkina uh
but Tanya maybe she's been doing some
work on our Blitz you know when she's
camped out in San Francisco commentating
on these tournaments and flying all over
the world maybe she's had a bit of time
to to work on her Blitz game
uh who knows uh nice to see her up there
on the top boards though
yeah multi-talented of course she won I
think two bronze medals at the Olympiad
individual and uh as part of the India
team so yeah shout out to Tanya doing
great so far in this tournament and uh
yeah
okay we see some matchups I don't think
these are the correct matchups these are
from the previous round so we'll get
that we'll get that refreshed in a
moment and there just to recap some of
the results we did see Magnus Carlson
takedown Duda and a draw between Gary
and Nakamura meanwhile uh Duda having
suffered defeat in the previous round we
see him on camera now he's looks like
he's got black against Ivan chaparinov
we see Eric Hansen revitalized uh
feeling better now having recovered from
the flu a few days ago where he had to
sadly withdraw from the rapid
so the trespass join the atmosphere
there and the players are taking their
seats
caruana wow Carolina black against
Nakamura Lawrence it looks like that is
gonna be
American battle
yeah I can see how the corner of my eyes
some of the matchups will bring the
graphic up in a minute the All-American
All-Star Clash Nakamura karawana on
board two we already knew board one
though Carlson against uyangi because
that those are the only two on 100 so
far it's Marta rosian on board three
against Anish giri 44 Daniel dubov
playing Petrosian and five chaparinov
Duda six Dura Bailey mvl
well
Nakamura karawana such a fierce rivalry
has been
around for some time now these guys uh
ever really since uh Fabi decided to
return to the U.S remember he was
playing for Italy for many many years
he is an American born in New York uh
lived there for for most of his
childhood then came to Europe to get his
Grandmaster title and all the
opportunities that Europe offers in
chess when uh chess in America wasn't as
big as it is now then of course when
rexing field and the Renaissance of
American chess started uh Fabi made the
wise decision to go back and has been
with the American team ever since
in the early days this matchup
especially in Blitz it felt as though
Hikaru had a massive uh sort of upper
hand against Fabi but Fabi has very much
switched that around Fabi competes with
Hikaru uh and More in Blitz uh games are
very very uh level now the results very
very even as you would expect it's not
one-sided whatsoever really looking
forward to seeing that one
and we can see there world champion
Magnus Carlson World classical Champion
World rapid Champion is he going to be
World Blitz champion
got a lot of Chess yet to play needs to
be fully focused playing now against the
Chinese
uh top Grandmaster you Yang Yi uh
predictions for this round David
yeah predictions uh it's tough I'm gonna
back Magnus and Hikaru to win their
games but which one do you want to
follow that is the big question we're
spoiled for Choice here with two huge
clashes and uh maybe we can follow
Nakamura against Carolina just because I
think Nakamura has played a bit of a
strange opening has he played his Pawn
to A3 on move two uh wow looks to me
like uh Nakamura is really kind of
beating Carolina here he's really saying
to him come at me uh with some strange
opening moves at this early stage it
looks like white landed with the pawn on
A3 it was the English opening or it
started that way at least and now we see
a bit of a weird porn structure early on
Lawrence is this Nakamura trying to take
Carolina out of his comfort zone trying
to evade any potential opening
preparation
to a certain extent I think it is yes
it's just trying to get a position
uh which uh which Hikaru is going to
enjoy as well uh both Fabi and Hikaru I
think we'll be actually both of them
will be relatively happy with the
outcome of this opening we do have just
a very novel position I'm pretty sure
this isn't that theoretical and
uh you know I think Fabi will also be
happy he's going to put the bishop on E6
he's got to be careful because there's
some Knight D4 ideas
maybe hey for maybe it's a little bit
loose for black what does your instinct
tell you about this position David
yeah my instinct tells me black should
be fine with correct play but it's not
easy to find the right move orders you
mentioned there Lawrence white certainly
has direct threats evaluation bar seems
to prefer White's chances as well as
early stage despite white lagging behind
the development white hasn't castled yet
but hasn't got the light squared Bishop
going and wow Nakamura not resting on
his Laurels not taking time out to
develop he's pushed his Pawn to C5 he's
opened up a diagonal towards the black
king Abby doesn't get greedy doesn't
grab a pawn shuts down the center
Nakamura now has a beautiful night
entrenched on the default Outpost and by
pushing his b-born forward looks like
he's uh clamped down it's
it's committal I've got to say by
Nakamura black has more Central pawns
black will play on the other flank on
the king side later but I've got to say
I like it in terms of Blitz it looks
easier to play for white and that's all
you can ask for white has a simple plan
pushing pause on the queen side at some
point white would take your time out to
move his lightsaber Bishop to get
castled and in the meantime I don't
immediately see what Fabiano should be
playing
cam Fabi take on B4
take on A1 and then play Knight H5 and
try and push H try and push F4
does this
plan makes sense it looks reasonable to
me just trying to take advantage of the
fact that white is lagging behind in
development of his King side
Lawrence I love that variation it shows
a real sensitivity to the Dynamics I
think black needs to do something urgent
before white is fully organized and Fabi
tries to kick away the white Bishop but
he does it in a different way maybe a
bit of a slower way he relocated his
night round to E6 took three Tempi which
yeah isn't ideal necessarily and now
Nakamura is only one move away from
castling I don't think peace exchangers
will really help bail black out of any
uh potential trouble he's in on the
queen side we do see white glorious
Knight traded off but it has been
Retreat uh replaced by White's Bishop on
D4 it's looking good for Nakamura I've
got to say White's gonna Castle just
judging by his hand movements there I
think he did castle and white is just
going to push forward Pawn to B5 create
a past Pawn Fabby desperately needs to
counter attack
I think he's going for a similar plan to
the one you mentioned Lawrence at some
point he wanted to push pawns on the
king side push F4 which Nakamura has
prevented
okay the pawn structure is changing
evolving do you still prefer White
prefer preferred lessons the moment
where there was a trade on B4 I didn't
understand why Hikari didn't take with
the queen he took with the bishop
um and now I I am not actually that
impressed by this transition this Pawn
on E3 is going to be a weakness forever
and it can be targeted
so I think Fabi is going to be quite
happy here
um and yeah he puts a knight on E5
Knight on F4 still probably is better
for white but how much I'm not entirely
sure
unless you can go B5 here and just try
and win by Brute Force trying to isolate
this Pawn
and it's late yeah it's played yeah the
timing of this breakthrough you have to
be very very careful you don't want to
prematurely push this Pawn because
suddenly the position might open and if
your pieces aren't ready uh it might
backfire but I think he's timed it
correctly as you say Lawrence black is
simply not ready the D Pawn
the D5 button is doomed if you ever try
to exchange off why it's a majority
there White's advancing pawns on the
queen side
and suddenly look at the clock times as
well huge difference there this is maybe
why Nakamura has had the ascendancy
against Carolina especially in the early
days of their uh Blitz matches it's
almost two minutes for Nakamura it's
less than 30 seconds for karawana 20
seconds now and he's had to play an
artificial looking move superficial here
Rook A5 I mean awful yes it's targeting
White's pawns but tactically that black
Rook is a target it's loose now
undefended white is surely gonna gain
time against that Rook later this looks
terrible look at that white Pawn on B6
now protected past Pawn any end game is
just going to be winning for white uh if
it gets that far okay Fabi activates his
Knight the knight in C4 looks nice one
good piece but shouldn't be enough
Nakamura is so good at just uh kind of
clamping down at consolidating and Fabby
F4 desperation but also very very clever
he was trying to open up a diagonal for
his light Square Bishop Black's Bishop
wants to come to G6 later
um but first an attack on the White
Queen by the rook and an exchange of
pieces fabby's fighting back Lawrence
yeah I mean I I'm in shock really to see
Hikaru lose control of this position he
had so many ways just to consolidate and
now
is this just random and unclear and has
Fabi got some incredible ideas in this
position okay he's only got a few
seconds nine takes D5 Knight takes D5 no
no no no no no no no Fabi he had a half
Elementary right 65. oh good Elementary
tactic there it's a simple one-two punch
double attack
temporary peace sacrifice like you said
Lawrence yeah this has gone all wrong he
had five seconds it's impossible to
fight Nakamura when you're so far behind
on the clock but now white is simply two
very strong pass points ahead that he
Pawn has dropped off this is a
straightforward win look at the C and B
pawns new Queen
poor Fabi he was just too slow in the
opening and that came back to bite him
later Nakamura takes the win
massive win there for Hikaru Nakamura
let's go to Magnus Carlson against you
young ye and hold on a second here wait
ah Magnus Carlsen a pawn down
Lawrence oh my goodness he's two pawns
down
but he's got to pass deep on what's
going on here
yeah he temporarily gave up a peace
Magnus in order to promote his pawn it
costs black as Rook so material count
now is a knight and three pawns for
White's Rook so Black's still doing well
in terms of material but Lawrence we've
seen Magnus convert similar things
before he loves having The Rook against
the minor piece any winning chances for
white or is this just balanced now
I wouldn't have thought so
um I think you still have to be careful
here is white now three bones is really
a lot okay you young you're getting his
pieces active as well uh no he's not oh
he's walked into a skewer there the
bishop skewering the Black Knights it is
a scramble on the clock you Angie barely
any time left and uh okay looks like
Magnus is just trying to force a draw by
eliminating as many black points as
possible black tonight is also going to
start grabbing some pawns you can tell
our magnets of body language jack it off
ready focused but he doesn't look happy
it looks like a draw and we saw the
verbal offer of a draw there by Magnus
it looks like simply too many pawns
dropping off the board and just to show
the final moves of this game the
handshake there because whites were
collecting all the pawns it would have
come down to a dead drawn end game
wow yeah
yeah once this happens here even though
black has got three pawns white collects
this Pawn here and black has got no hope
uh with just two pawns and a knight
against the uh against the king uh no
point in playing this one on another
another big result Lawrence Anish giri
has one with the black pieces against
hike matarosian uh big result for Gary
who joins the lead now he catches Magnus
he catches uh you Yang Yi and Nakamura
very impressive stuff
okay and uh this is which board now
it looks like job section women's
section wow huge game here between the
leader Paulina shuvalova and
um
was her opponent and tanjong Yi wow hey
white porns are running up the board
like it's a piece up though black has
extra Knight and all their checkmating
ideas against the black king you've got
to be super careful here like it's just
in time to block
who's playing for the win it's not clear
black has this bee Pawn which is going
to disappear or is it oh 95. suddenly
Rook takes F5 exists after Rook B5 and
she can take on F5 oh oh she's getting
nervous she's knocked pieces over the
night
away
it is a dead draw now oh yeah should be
a draw
should be a draw yeah come back
dramatic stuff
yeah White's giving up the pawn but the
B Pawn won't survive either draw in this
huge match and there we go an agreement
to the draw
while Laura's so much drama a lot of
drama there by the way we had a bloody
round the last round in the women's this
round much more uh contended draw
tanjong view Shuffle over draw
haricagunina draw Lano heads then you're
such they're unable to keep her winning
streak alive losing to koyage meaning
like gets back in the mix danielia
continuing to play phenomenal chess
beating stefanova zagnitza wins as well
and uh Lawrence here we see nihal sarin
defending a difficult end game a losing
end game against his uh Countryman Surya
Ganguly uh nihal sarin going down to one
two seconds after every move struggling
to physically make the moves in time
there are some stalemate ideas so you
have to be very careful well I can give
it why can give a check there Rook F1
check but uh okay Dan Gully still has
this under control and
there we go Nihao sarin loses on time at
the same moment he resigns black was
about to trade off the Rooks and win the
end game disappointment for Nihao sarin
great technique from Ganguly
absolutely yeah well played the
experienced Ganguly most games finishing
up now still a bit of hustle and bustle
in the playing Hall
any other games I wonder if we can see
chaparinov Duda on board
five is that still going on
I don't have
uh that's already done
all right so we're not
we have got a result that that is a draw
whichever we don't do this looks as
though all the results are pretty much
in David
uh
thoughts on Fabiano's performance in
that game
yeah uh disappointing for Fabiano
caruana and all his fans of course but
Hikaru was just too quick in the early
stages Fabiano got a playable position
not an easy position to play uh but
unfortunately that's all the Hikaru
needs to really put the pressure on to
really punish you and he fought back
caruana but the clock was the main
decider in that game I Want To Praise as
well Anish Geary winning as black no
easy feat at the top level
um he's keeping Pace now with the
leaders and uh yeah of course that key
game would Magnus costume against you
Yang Yi it did show the first bit of
weakness Magnus for the first time in
the blitz looked uncomfortable looked
uncertain and uh here we see the
Norwegian team plenty of Norwegian
players and Norwegian press the main
Norwegian News Channel they're covering
this event
um yeah there's as we said huge bunch of
players now in the lead Lawrence
who do you think is going to emerge as
the front runner by the end of the day
we are officially at the halfway stage
of the day
well I'll tell you this I think there's
a really good chance we get Carlson
Nakamura in the next round uh they're
both on the same points uh I think
well theoretically you Yang Yi the
colors might work so that yuyangi might
get Hikaru actually and Carlson might
get Geary so we could get Carlson Geary
that's my prediction for the next round
um
as for the front runner well
the onus is on everybody else uh you
know then this will remain the constant
for uh the rest of uh the rest of time
basically either Magnus Carlsen is
stopped by somebody else or he just
cruises to to Victory
um who is that person going to be or who
is most likely to do that clearly Hikaru
is finding his feet lovely little
Victory there against Fabi Hikaru hasn't
had any issues so far
Anish uh certainly could also pose some
problems can be extremely difficult to
beat when he wants Daniel dubov has
beaten tigrant Petrosian as well I
should point out so
there are a few players it's really up
to one of those guys to
to uh to to do something to create that
that Dynamic we saw it yesterday when uh
when Magnus did eventually uh lose a
game
um and for this tournament to remain
competitive I would like to see somebody
put Magnus on the back foot somebody put
a Hikaru on the back foot otherwise
these two could start to create some
separation and uh I would like it to be
a bit more competitive
yeah it suddenly looks competitive so
far not just in the open section as we
mentioned uh in the women's section two
that dramatic draw that we saw right at
the end there the closing stages of
tanzin Zhong Yi against shrivolova has
ensured that players have been able to
close the gap have been able to catch up
and uh yeah we'll see even more tense
pairings there Lawrence
um the results are starting to trickle
in we will examine the standings and the
match-ups a bit later
in the meantime
uh what do you think now should we go to
break should we discuss some of those
games
yeah I I think I think a break is a is a
perfectly good idea we'll be back for
round seven
of today's action in just a few minutes
are we gonna get Carlson Nakamura
probably not but we will keep you guys
updated don't go anywhere round seven
coming up in just a few moments
puzzle week is back what a comeback as
Jeffrey came from behind the entire week
of January 9th through 13th all puzzle
features will be free for all chess.com
members and puzzle week will be packed
with puzzle competitions Community
contests and more
the action kicks off with chess play
quick a puzzle themed Bounty battle open
to streamers as they compete for cash
prizes and puzzle Rush
Puzzle Battle that was crazy oh my
goodness custom puzzles daily puzzles
and more
[Music]
then it's on to the puzzles World
Championship
s
in time we get another 53. wanna compete
submit your best five-minute puzzle rush
to earn a spot in the puzzle Rush Royale
where the top finishers advance to a
puzzle battle knockout bracket and
compete for 25 000 surprises what on
Earth are they doing don't miss these
and other exciting puzzle themed
contests and shows in chess.com's annual
puzzle week that is unreal
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
everybody and welcome back this is
chess.com's live coverage of the free
day world Blitz championships 2022
we are now up to round seven past the
halfway stage for today in the open way
past halfway stage in the women's
section we do not have clear separation
at the top in either of the tournaments
but we do have a great group of players
on five and a half out of six in the
open Magnus Carlsen just winning the
rapid Championship yesterday looking to
add more titles to the roster
Hikaru Nakamura also looking in Sublime
form
uh just crushing Fabiano caruana in the
previous round Yu Yang Yi holding Magnus
in the previous round and Anish giri
Anish don't sleep on Anish can play as
good as anyone on his day also up there
with those four on five and a half and
out of six they will be paired up I
predict it will be a Carlson Theory a
new yangi Nakamura match but we'll wait
for official confirmation of those
pairings and in the women's section
we have
shuvalova actually shovel over I should
say
shuvalova is the sole leader in the
women's section on five and a half out
of six with all those straws behind her
meaning that she is leading there are a
bunch of players on five Danielle
and gunina only half Point Hinds so
clearly plenty of Chess to play there
I'm here of course with the one and only
David Howe there you can see our
colleague good friend Tanya such Dev
deep in thought getting ready for her
next round Tanya taking this tournament
pretty seriously must be said she had a
couple of great results as beaten uh
Alexander christening with the black
pieces didn't manage to keep up uh the
uh the role with uh a loss in the last
round but still plenty of uh chances for
her to make a good run and somebody
there twiddling a porn can't see who it
is
David you are certainly not one to sit
down at the board early are you
Lawrence I've never been early to a game
in my life but uh yeah I do respect the
players who are and uh meanwhile and we
see your good friend I'm on Hamilton
with uh Fabiana caruana Karana needs to
recover from that loss he knows he has a
lot of time the top players will be
dropping points to each other uh the
further we go into this tournament so
it's never too late to put put together
a streak I think Oman Hamilton has had
an up and down tournament so far and um
yeah we are curiously awaiting those
pairings for round seven we mentioned we
have reached the halfway mark uh today
in the open section the women though I
think they play nine rounds today if I'm
not mistaken and uh therefore they do
have that final Sprint of three more
games today so who will keep their
energy levels up it is about endurance
as we mentioned I think we do meanwhile
have those matchups for round seven
maybe we can bring them up I think they
have been confirmed and you are correct
Lawrence with those predictions Anish
giri does get his chance to play Magnus
Carlson on board one you Yankee the
other leader faces Nakamura thoughts on
this Lawrence
foreign
yeah it's not an unexpected pairing an
issue clearly a class player playing
against Magnus has typically had a
pretty rough time against Magnus in
Blitz uh if I think all the blitz
matches they've had over the years but
Anish is white and um it really depends
how optimistic Magnus wants to be we saw
renish play very modestly with white
against Hikaru Nakamura I think Anish
will be looking to play the same kind of
Chess not give Magnus too many chances
not make it too random so it's really
all about how classically Magnus wants
to play in this game as for You Yankee
Hikaru Nakamura this one's a tricky one
for me
um
this feels like a potential banana skin
game for Nakamura who looks at the
pairing thinks hmm I should really press
against you Yang Yi and then realizes
that actually you Angie can really
punish you that being said Hikaru does
understand that this is a marathon not a
Sprint this is only around 7 of 21.
there's zero need to go all in in this
game and so perhaps we're gonna see
Hikaru just play a bit more of a
conservative game if you Yang you decide
not to go nuts but I think we will see
Nakamura Carlson in the next few rounds
I think that's going to be inevitable
interesting to see Mateus blue balm on
board three David
yeah you're right Lawrence we see some
interesting names in the chasing pack on
Five Points bluebound if I respect him
he's had a great year he is the European
Champion currently uh he played in the
official random World Championship he
qualified for that so he is having a
great 2022 he'll want to round off the
year on a high he faces Daniel dubov who
of course was one of the players of the
rapid section the world rapid
Championship checkmating several
opponents there so duboff might start as
the favorite but blue balm
very difficult to beat durability
keeping up his great form he's on five
out of six he faces fedes another name
in the mix that we keep seeing time and
time again a speed specialist but it is
the more experienced players Lawrence
Ganguly very experienced Indian player
part of the older generation who now
helped coach the youngsters he's doing
great he's showing the experience is a
factor uh in Blitz and he faces mama
jorov and uh I hesitate to say manager
of his uh one of the older guys but yeah
he's been around for a long time one of
the world's Elite for a long time and he
wants to uh he wants to make his mark on
this tournament too so plenty of action
here guaranteed I think we will be
focusing on the gear against Carlson
matchup just because it is such a big
one
such uh two big names uh two of the most
popular players out there in the world
with huge fan bases but uh yeah even
further down we see some huge pairings
as well I want to highlight board eight
sadwani against lazovic two teenagers
and uh they are both I think going to
cause even more surprises this
tournament
uh yeah Lawrence Yeah you mentioned the
predictions Anish Gary I want to see him
go for Magnus Carlson I think that's
where he's had success against Magnus
when he doesn't show any fear and goes
for the win Magnus won't allow him most
likely any uh easy way outs early on so
uh yeah it depends on the strategy for
Gary I feel
yeah I agree I I think
players have got to wise up to the fact
that playing tame passive uninspiring
chess against Magnus with the view of
reducing risk is really just not the way
to go
um you get the chances against Magnus
when you are aggressive when you are
optimistic because he will want to beat
you regardless so you're going to get
chances and
um
I I think Anish by now understands that
uh
you know Anish
he's more than capable I I want to see
him be more aggressive against Magnus I
think that's you know anish's career
almost can be defined a bit a bit more
um
let's say positively
if he starts to really have a go against
Magnus because he's doing it against
pretty much everybody else it's just
against Magnus where he seems to be a
bit more tame I I want to see him go for
the jugular he's got white it's a blitz
tournament
why not what what is the worst that can
happen so I'd love to see a more
aggressive approach today by Anish Gary
fully agreed and we saw Gary there
sitting down getting ready for the game
now we do see the standings of the
women's section you mentioned that
Lawrence shivolova does maintain her
lead after that draw against tanzongi
the very very tense end game but she is
now being chased by a huge pack of
players six players have five points uh
some of the biggest names let's check in
and on those matchups to see who shovel
over will have to defend her lead
against and it is Nana zagnitzi from
Georgia also one of the top women's
players in the world in the world
throughout the last decade
phenomenal uh player on her day really
scary opponent if you get into a
tactical melee with her so that's not
going to be easy on board one for the
leader good Nina on board two it's her
time to play tanzan Yi that one could go
either way like you said Lawrence you
Nina could be anyone on it on her day
but tanzongi notoriously difficult to
beat very resourceful and goyachukana
against harika uh going actually gonna
start it as one of the highest seeds and
uh she yet to maybe conquer the world in
Blitz in this format but she's uh on a
streak after an early defeat she's been
winning many games recently and harika a
tough opponent a very slippery opponent
very rarely loses what result will we
see that we also should mention on board
for the reigning Women's World Blitz
Champion uh bibisara Asura bayeva is
creeping up the table after a slow start
as she tries to retain her crown here we
see board one of the women's section
yep indeed uh you can't rule out
bibisara whatsoever
she uh
she she if she again she's a momentum
player in my opinion she's got white
against Daniella now Danielle has been
in in good form but I feel like this is
actually quite a good spot for us who
are they ever uh wouldn't surprise me at
all to see a win here really curious
about board two good enough against
tanjongji nobody has really been able to
stop tan Joshi either in the Rapid or
the blitz so far but gunina is actually
the sort of player who is capable of
doing that she uh I remember years and
years ago at the London chess classic
actually I think it was the blitz
tournament the London chess classic she
scored something phenomenal something
like nine out of ten or something
ridiculous including you know all the
top players with their Luke McShane was
playing I think even you were playing
um
yeah yeah and you know
um so the capability is there she's it's
the consistency in her play that has
been lacking the past few years but I
really hope that we start to see
um a bit more of the let's say the older
Valencia gunina come back because
talent-wise she's just she's just
tremendous white here against San Juan
Ji this is actually a pretty interesting
spot I'm very curious to see what
happens but I'm gonna go with a good in
a win let's give Valentina some good
vibes uh because
feels like a while since she's had a
really good tournament score as well
yeah meanwhile we were just watching
giri there share a joke with duboff I
wonder what they were talking about was
it uh maybe talking about dubov
checkmating Gary yesterday it's nice to
see Gary laugh uh against uh someone who
did Vanquish him meanwhile we do see
also hikaranakamura arrive in that very
uh well statement like shirt I'll say uh
against you young
very focused difficult powering Nakamura
with black tends to take a solid
approach against the top guys what will
we see there but uh the key matchup
Magnus Carlsen facing Anish giri that's
where all eyes will be in this round as
the players get ready for confirmation
from the Arbiters that they can start
their games Magnus arriving not two and
a half minutes late you can't spot
anishikiri any time on the clock uh I do
feel the clock is actually where Magnus
will try and hustle if he gets a
playable position out of the opening but
the first few moves will be key and he
needs to get off to a good start in this
game
he does and I as I said I really want to
see a bit more of an aggressive approach
let's see he goes to E4 Magnus plays E6
of Annie is now going to be forced to
play something uh a bit unbalanced we
have three Knight C3
and Magnus goes for the winner Bishop
b40 continues to play this sideline with
Knight C6
Queen G4
and now I saw this she saw this from
Magnus in the world rapid section uh in
the world records uh championship and he
got a really really dodgy position there
I've got to say strategically uh it does
look like Anish giri has come prepared
but no quick draw no early uh
liquidation uh of the pieces which you
gotta love Lawrence you've got to be
happy to see that we're getting a
full-blooded fight in this one
definitely and looks as though we are
having a slight leg with the
moves coming through
um I can tell you that I think it went
G6 H4 H6 and now Gary just went for it
H5 G5 and
F4 just immediately
going for it and actually I was kind of
curious about this exact line
an F5 by Magnus Carlson Queen G3 and G4
locking everything up
Lawrence D takes C5 was played in this
position by Anish giri instantly after
G4 locking up the position and queen A5
by Magnus and this has caused Anish Gary
to pause for the first time in the game
uh it does feel like Magnus has walked
into some opening preparation Geary
clearly has studied this before uh
before the round before the day perhaps
because he knew at some point he would
play Magnus and uh Magnus remember has
already played this line but now white
has those tripled pawns those drunken
pawns on the C file and one of them is
guaranteed to drop off so Gary
developing his Knight Magnus does the
same who do you favor here Lawrence as
things hot up so 92 was played Knight G
E7 and white played A4 very sneaky move
to try and activate white dark Square
Bishop maybe we can put those on the
board yeah I'm gonna try and get the
update here
uh so that it went 92
yeah and 92 97 A4 yeah I love this move
by Fury this looks bad for Magnus I I I
don't like this at all
uh maybe I'm misinterpreting the
position I don't know
the idea is that White's Bishop will
activate via A3 but Magnus gives up a
point he doesn't even want to recapture
one of those triple points he played B6
admitting that it is a pawn sacrifice
just to speed up his development he
wants to get black light Square Bishop
Into The Fray and uh after this it looks
like Gary played King F2 wow really
playing with fire remember Geary brought
his King out to F2 yesterday against
duboff and got checkmated will we see
lightning strike twice uh Magnus is down
upon the evaluation bar roughly in the
middle uh still thinking black has
decent practical compensation for the
sacrifice Pawn
Lawrence I've got to say I don't like
Black's position but I don't hate it
either I think there's plenty of
potential if the knights get to decent
outposts white still needs to untangle
uh White still looks a bit clumsy with
his peaceful mission
yeah he still has got to develop those
pieces and I think the initiative is
firmly
shifted to magnus's position
I'm a bit concerned for Anish actually
he's got to be a little bit mindful of
the fact that you know Magnus he just
plays King F7 he's going to bring a rook
to C8 and he he can get a lot of
pressure very quickly I do like B6
conceptually and I do like what Magnus
has done
in the past few moves and it's going to
be up to I used to really try and come
up with some kind of uh short-term plan
because
I don't know how you should be playing
this really
Queen he's replayed
okay yeah maybe Anish wants to hide his
King on the G3 square is that the
potential safe haven for that white king
very unclear what white is trying to do
here I think he just wants to protect
everything and consolidate his extra
Pawn but it's not going to be easy long
term Magnus has the blockade which tends
to favor the knights over the Bishops
um looks like we're not getting any
extra moves here we might let's let's go
on screen yeah let's go full screen to
see if we can get a better view of this
game
yeah we need those updates we want to
see the clock we want to see the board
we maybe the clock is accurate here it
does look like Magnus is under one
minute against anisha's two minutes so
Magnus giving up time on the clock yet
again
and uh okay let's stick with the players
cameras we need to zoom in we need to
get a closer picture of that board
um simply not updating it does look like
Magnus is getting very active and uh the
Queens have been exchanged as far as I
can tell I can see the Queen's on the
side off the board
and it looks like an end game here we go
this is the current position it's
Knights against Bishops but white still
a pawn up Lawrence
this is something went wrong for Magnus
something went wrong C4 now c4 for one
surely protecting that Bishop
Anish retreated he went Bishop back to
E2 and after a trade of Rooks played C4
so white Bishop suddenly not so
impressive and he just locked his own
Bishops behind his own Pawn chain
uh Knights against Bishops you've got to
favor the Bishops usually but this could
be an exception Magnus can he work his
magic the Magnus effect
I've got to love white dark Square
Bishop but the light Square Bishop white
slight Square Bishop can never ever get
in the game look at how it's trapped by
this Christmas Tree Pawn structure for
black
uh yes I I think I think Magnus has
dodged a huge bullet in this game
actually because this bishop can just
never get into the game now it's locked
there are no Pawn breaks and so there's
nothing really you can't really improve
here now as why the pawn is firmly
stopped he had to play C4 Bishop B2 or
move 24 was a terrible mistake C4 would
have given him an awesome Advantage a
massive massive miss that being said
Lawrence Niche has he tricked Magnus
what is happening here Magnus has just
taken the white a pawn but white is
going with his Bishop after the H6 Pawn
oh my goodness
Anish has reestablished the extra Pawn
that is a scary past point to allow but
black is marching with his King towards
the king side we'll catch up with this
in a moment there's a bit of like with
the board and uh there we see Magnus
body language does not look happy at all
Gary looks focused ready to pounce ready
to deliver the killing blow but White's
light's going Bishop he's playing
without a peace Lords yeah
but he can't and and I'm actually
thinking I think Magnus is is getting
excited here because Magnus uh you know
he can put the Knight on C6 he can bring
this Knight to here and whenever the
King goes to D4 he always has a pawn
break available in the form of D4
and I actually think that this position
is not not better for white Lawrence
look at the clock and Niche down or to a
few seconds has he made a move in time
uh the clock ticked down to zero there I
don't think he lost on time he still has
a few seconds left but as you say white
is completely boxed in boys King and
white light Square Bishop can never
really break out wow and look at this
Magnus is just piling up the pressure on
this C3 pawn and all of a sudden we'll
see this come on the board in a minute
we have Bishop races he's going Knight
A7 Knight B5 and it's just nothing oh
wow what happened there we see a
handshake
wow
from being completely winning completely
winning to losing that game that is
extremely extremely disappointing let's
go to the next match uh two brothers
beating blueband but what about you Yang
Yi against Hikaru Nakamura what is going
on here this looks awfully tough for you
Yang Yi to defend
but has he got some kind of Fortress
yeah it looks beautiful
those three pieces stacked up tripled up
against White's backward Pawn on F3 that
black H Pawn on H3 uh as well that is a
thorn in white side creating all sorts
of checkmating patterns later on
Nakamura all he needs to do is improves
the position of the black queen he's
going around now when that black queen
finally enters the position
I mean it's already one-way traffic but
it feels like that could be the killer
blow uh where's that black queen going
it's coming round
Lawrence this is uh really ugly for you
Yankee do you think he can cling on
the time he's lost on time he has
another game on Time another game
decided by the clock in both the two uh
battles between the leaders yuyangi and
Anish giri both lose on time with white
both in difficult positions but Lawrence
we talked about it earlier the clock is
such a big factor in Blitz
absolutely let's go to the women's top
board shovel over playing against Nana
zagnitza this looks like a
terribly difficult position
can we get the camera on those two we
could see their chevalova with the pink
hair
Nana said needs in all kinds of churches
getting made in and that's that
yeah we were about to see Checkmate next
move and uh Paulina extends her lead wow
what a win she gave up her Queen to make
a new Queen and uh that white d-pawn
decided the game
so many decisive results on the top
boards now let's go to I think board
three board four and this is dura Bailey
with white against Vladimir fedes and
durability from Azerbaijan very strong
Grandmaster can he take down his Russian
opponent uh it's looking difficult it
looks like black should be in charge
here uh we're seeing a Time scramble
both players having to play instantly
but look at the white king the white
King's not going to survive and a
handshake mate
it's just made that's all it is great
win for Vladimir to say if he's having a
fantastic time over in Almighty we saw
the smile from him
yeah we still have we've got massive
news Valentina goonina is she gonna be
able to convert this playing White
against tanjong ji is he going to be the
first person to really put a dent in
tanjongji's tournament thus far in fact
a whole event let's go there if we can
Valentina gunina and
we have gods
a result and it looks as though
technology has resigned Valentina unina
yes with the massive win speaking about
it before the round we need she needed
that win
um David in order to kick-start her
campaign
what a massive massive victory that is
and that will set up a chivalova gunina
game in the next round
amazing myself
that we see the final position black
could not hold the Fortress tanzani
could not hold the defense queen versus
Rook uh eventually white won a pawn and
winning the blackfrog next and yeah many
many people picked out tanzongi is the
favorite for the blitz but it's not
looking easy for her so far here we see
a clash between Dimitri and draken and
Vincent kymer uh Dimitri well-known
Russian player former candidate Blitz
specialist is he just repeating the
position white has an extra Bishop for
two black pawns but it looks very close
to a fortress
it's looking very difficult for Andrea
can to break through Vincent desperately
trying to hold the draw here as black
uh you just got to shuffle with the
black queen Dimitri pushing his Pawn
forward I'm looking at that white H Pawn
and it promotes on a dark Square which
long term does not really help because
white has a light Square Bishop this one
Lawrence feels like it should be a draw
but will the clock have a part to play
do you think Dimitri can win this one
even by marching his King around maybe
somehow
I wouldn't have thought so no it looks
like this is just way too solid for
Vincent he only has to protect the F7
point
oh and he does go for the queen trade
which was declined by the queen Traders
and okay a queen trade's immediate draw
but it's a draw anyway black had a
fortress and a handshake confirms the
Half Point
indeed
probably still do have some games going
on you can see it just behind interest
in the game just finally I didn't catch
who they were let's see if we can get
our roaming uh video man over there wow
okay massive massive random we've got
here is that Andrew Tang looks like
Andrew
is Andrew Tang against hike materosian
and Andrew Tang is trying to convert he
has an extra Queen black has two pawns
but there are all sorts of stale Matrix
in the position if White's Queen takes
that advanced uh black Pawn on C2 it's
stalemate Andrew Tang looks frustrated
how does he win
it looks like it should be winning
because black has a pawn in the center
of the board but simply no way to
prevent black queening and prevent
stalemate at the same time this is a
study-like position
God you never see that online one of the
quickest hands in the world on the mouse
Andrew Tang but loses on time this is
how difficult over the board chess can
be you just forgot about the clock we've
seen three of those uh Lawrence three
people losing on time with white in this
round
unbelievable by the way Eric Hanson beat
nihal sarin in that round as well superb
result
for Eric who's showing some real form
and what have we got here this is board
13 of the women's section this is
Theodora injouch against umida or monova
and we've got Rook versus
Brooke nearly came off the board
and
a win
she's gonna pick up the pawn on scene
five and she's
she's beside herself with joy
the the the player there black playing
uh playing Black that was a massive
result for her
on monova rated only
2052 beating in judge a very well-known
Grandmaster who's rated over 300 points
higher that's a massive individual
result
well done to umida umonova in that game
wow what a what a round David
yeah what around it's been with so many
uh decisive Games first of all so many
dramatic moments especially on the clock
three people there including the top two
boards losing on time and Lawrence I
think we need to catch our breath the
players clearly wanting a break as well
so I think it's time to take a couple of
minutes out and we'll be back with all
the action all the updates very shortly
see you in a few minutes everyone
see you soon your subscription makes
shows like this possible which is why
our twitch subscribers will never see
ads on chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] chess championships we are moving
on to the business end of today and my
goodness finally it is upon us the match
everybody has been waiting for it Karina
Nakamura will face Magnus Carlsen these
two Titans of the Chess World especially
when it comes to Blitz will be facing
off and it will be Hikaru Nakamura with
the white pieces so a bit of an
advantage there we'll talk a bit more
about that and of course the other key
matchup of the day spanner against
svarna on board 53 Battle of the
brothers
now I thought I'd shout them out anyway
I gotta put in a little bit of humor
into this ah no shout out to to
Frederick and to Rasmus very I I I bet
you guys couldn't tell me the last time
two brothers faced each other in a world
Blitz championships a little one for
this statistician statisticians out
there we do have some other big pairings
though David we got fedisev duboff on
ball too that has a lot of Promise as
well
yeah very spicy pairing there with two
very aggressive players uh two friends
from Russia so uh it'll be interesting
to see how fiercely they go at each
other they know that someone on the top
board Nakamura or Carlson are going to
drop points so uh these players in the
chasing pack do have the opportunity to
make up some ground they do have the
opportunity to catch up uh mamajarov as
well just half a point behind uh
Nakamura and Carson after winning his
last game and manujarov is downloaded to
you Yang Yi who remember did lose on
time to Nakamura in the previous round
Dennis lazovic up against Anish giri as
giri aims to recover as well from
heartbreak in the previous game uh like
you said Lawrence will be focusing
mostly on uh Nakamura against Carlson
Nakamura gets the white Pieces by virtue
of having the slightly higher rating in
terms of Blitz they were both do white
in this round but Nakamura due to his
high rating gets the color and yeah as
you said that could potentially be
decisive that could be a huge factor in
the grand scheme of things
absolutely could we've got some great
matchups further down the list as well
how about lasovic against Gary lazovic
staying relevant in this tournament I'm
going to point off uh the blitz
specialist the youngster playing Anish
who's come off a really tough losser
against Magnuson this was a real
travesty actually uh for Anish let's
have a look at this game uh before the
next round starts because Anish
um he had a massive opportunity I
believe around the move
24. we had this position here Rook hb8
if we do a little count white is a porn
up and here Anish makes a huge blunder
because he plays the move Bishop C E2
which allows black to completely lock
things up sorry not with C4 straight
away but rather with exchanging a pair
of Rooks first and then C4 and all of a
sudden this bishop is now completely
locked out of the game there are no Pawn
breaks no ways to get it in had instead
played the move on to C4 here
on move 24 he would have been odds on
favorite to win because now the bishop
can't really be taken because then white
just has two uh past pawns and you just
guide them home
and if you take for example on C4
now the visual can always just take back
and it really is simply an extra Pawn
this Pawn is also weak very very uh
dangerous for black position just looks
toast to me David this just looks
resignable almost
yeah I completely agree and he's missing
a huge opportunity there he still had
time on the clock at this stage but uh
by retreating his Bishop he made sure
that he was playing without a piece for
the rest of the game really instructive
actually quite slight Square Bishop can
never ever uh find an active Square
again and uh Lawrence maybe we can fast
forward to the final position we
mentioned that uh giri lost on time but
things had turned against him by that
point and it was here that I think he
was just too slow didn't press the clock
in time and uh it is difficult however
Magnus had mobilized the Black Knights
white is a pawn up in the final position
but surprisingly nothing to be done
Black's Knights are simply coming uh one
of the Black Knights is coming to five
to take the C3 pawn and uh Lawrence
sorry go on but I was going to say yes
even though that is true maybe with the
Knights slightly offside white did miss
a little trick here Darth the move
Bishop takes G4 exists as a last gas
attempt the point is that after F takes
G4 I now want to go f five again these
nights are far away and I want to create
two past forms now almost certainly
doesn't work but it's close
it's close for example what are you
supposed to do here as black uh
yeah it's not easy to get those nights
back you could consider maybe taking
that pawn on F5
and then using yeah using one of the
Black Knights Knight C6 Knight C8 maybe
uh Knight C8 maybe the better Square
just to come to D6 block on E8 but like
you say Lawrence it was a better
practical try you have to try something
when you have such a bad piece you might
as well give it up just to give your
pieces more activity and yeah the
evaluation Bar says White's not doing so
badly here so Anish still had chances
later in the game but the clock is such
a key factor in Blitz and it decided
this one a huge result for Magnus
Carlson and maybe we can also just show
the final position of Yu Yang Yi where
he also lost on time against Nakamura
Nakamura was well in charge uh in that
game but couldn't take it
excuse me
I'm botching the games here apologies
for that I don't actually have the uh
that that game
okay either way Nakamura one on time
against Yankee in a very strong position
anyway and uh he was gonna be riding
High
there we go it's looking very good for
Nakamura here blacks Rooks blacks Queens
are doing the business I think all black
needs to do is play the move King d8
defend against any threats against any
checks from the White Queen and he's
crashing through he's winning this game
so Nakamura would have won anyway
but he was helped by the clock situation
Lawrence maybe it's time to check out
the standings in the women's section I
think the games will start in around two
or three minutes
absolutely let's do that
and it's shuvalova who's out in front
alone at the moment closely followed by
Valentina gunina those two will face
each other in the next round both have
been shown tremendous form in this 200
so far with a pack of players on five
and a half who are well within a
striking range
who's coming back into the picture
Elizabeth pets having a good tournament
and reigning uh Blitz Champion bibisara
Asura valleva can't rule her out after a
fantastic Victory last year so it's all
going to be about gurina shuvalova
shuval over wins she could put some
serious separation between her and the
rest of the pack
um
what do you think of of this particular
matchup shovel over agunino what's your
prediction
yeah it's two players who will know each
other very well from the Russian
national team they've been teammates
there for a few years now shiver lover I
think is maybe the more consistent
player as you mentioned there Lawrence
especially with white she's extremely
dangerous great opening repertoire very
predictable when she has the black
pieces always playing the karakan always
playing the playing uh variations of the
Queen's camper decline so it depends on
shrivolova's opening choice if she can
get the upper hand in the opening I fear
for ganina but yeah either way two
players who can uh beat anyone on their
day and also Lawrence I'm looking at
board two Katarina lagno as you said
caught up after losing round one the top
seed of the blitz tournament and she is
playing the reigning Champion so
yeah this one is going to be uh very
very uh kind of it's going to have an
impact on the standings come the end of
the tournament I saw by ever I picked
out as well as maybe being on course to
defend her title she's just so good in
Blitz every time I see her so quick so
tricky but she will need to get past the
top seed with black
and uh yeah I think this is
the games are about so I think this is a
very very tough spot though for latinum
uh to be brewed to be honest oh sorry I
beg your pardon for acid worry ever
black against lachno uh when Katarina is
on that Ascent when she's got that
momentum I think this is a this isn't
the ideal pairing at all but you have to
play them all eventually anyway so I
guess you could say it doesn't matter
too much players getting assembled
indeed you have to beat the best to be
the best as they say and that's true in
the women's section right now but also
in the clash between Nakamura and
Carlson and uh as they check their
parents and uh sit at their boards
Lawrence prediction Nakamura against
Carlson huge Clash
yeah
such a difficult game with hikaru's wide
I tend to feel like he's not going to
lose so I'm gonna go for
can I do that can I say Hikaru will not
lose that's my prediction
uh you're covering two results there
very sneaky but uh yeah hikara with
white very very good and remember in the
speed Chess Championship just a couple
of weeks ago Nakamura took down Magnus
uh he managed to win just by one point
but it was with the white pieces that he
did most of the damage Nakamura he
starts with D4 it's interesting that
both of these players arrive equally
late for this game the other games had
already started so Magnus not giving his
opponent any extra time here what
opening will we see it's a queen's Pawn
opening and it looks on the camera like
the Queen's Gambit declined
and uh it's what caused the main
position where white is giving black the
option uh lots of flexibility and Magnus
choosing the tarash variation of the
Queen's Gambit client so um yeah
Lawrence this is what Magnus has been
doing a lot lately it it tends to be
what he chooses when he's in a solid
mood when he's happy with a draw do you
think Nakamura will go for maybe an end
game that's available in this variation
just to keep things really safe always
good Nakamura Gonna Keep as many pieces
on the board as possible keep attention
I really have no idea we'll soon find
out in cd5 CD4 this classic uh line
where black can get a
uh slightly uh sort of passive position
but one which is
uh
you know has been defended at top level
for a while now I think this is a
position that Magnus analyzed deeply for
his world championship as well let's go
straight there
let's show that uh Lawrence because we
are in the end game it's uh it's what
they call the Berlin of 1d4 uh it's this
end game with blacks King on d8 Queens
are off the board white just temporarily
sacrificed upon but why can we gobble
that pawn back anytime he wants by
taking on e4 instead Nakamura takes the
bishop hair long-term uh Ace up his
sleeve there the bishop pair but black
has the pawn Advantage temporarily
um this one yeah it's pretty much been
worked out that black can hold the
balance but you need to know a lot of
stuff and of course Magnus will know
his theory in this variation
Nakamura is about to take the pawn back
he's pinned that Black Knight on F6
and he's just played Knight takes E4 in
this position meeting a check uh by
Bishop B4 looks dropping back his Knight
so material is balanced white has the
two Bishops white has the better Pawn
structure
like has this horrible isolated E Pawn
but black has the activity and I've got
to say I back Magnus to hold this I
would be shocked if Magnus
would lose a very very balanced end game
it's just not his style uh Nakamura I
think taking the safety first approach
which which makes sense in the terms of
the tournament standings Lawrence
yep uh not not the kind of explosive
match that uh perhaps we were all
gunning for but it is what it is uh I
think uh
Magnus will be extraordinarily happy
with the outcome of this opening he's in
absolutely no danger whatsoever
and uh
it's uh it's now just a question of does
Magnus want to start to get slightly
optimistic I I I don't really see any
reason why you shouldn't actually want
to play on here I see no particular
Danger
um
the Knight is on B3
The Rook comes to d8 isn't black just
slightly better in this position
um I tend to agree with uh I think it
was zedo there in the future chat that
these two greats of Chess just canceling
each other out I think it's just roughly
balanced You could argue black has more
Mobility with his Pawns in the center
but uh yeah I I do feel that white has
nothing to worry about worse comes to
the worst you trade off all the Rooks it
is opposite color Bishops after all you
shouldn't be in any trouble but I agree
with you Lawrence I think I would take
black if anyone Magnus has more time on
the clock
and uh okay with this last move I think
his intentions are clear look at the
body language as well by Magnus Carson
he wants to get out of here as quickly
as possible I think he's just traded off
the knights he's played Knight to 85 and
knights have disappeared the Rooks will
soon disappear
anti-climax but a good result for both
players it's about to be a draw any
moment now I think we see a handshake in
the next few seconds
it's just like the vacuum cleaners come
out everything's been hoovered off a
bunch of exchanges and
there we go the handshake nothing left
to play for in this opposite color Bush
pen game
yeah anticlimactic
Carlson just doing what he needed to do
with black uh Hikaru choosing a
very very uh well
unambitious approach in this particular
line
seems as though hiko didn't really know
in the critical ways with white
back to the chest
yeah let's go to the game Geary against
lazovic lazovic with white and uh yeah
you're right Hikaru couldn't make any
Headway there but can lazovic make
Headway against Anish Geary it's looking
very balanced if we do a quick counts
it's level material uh on the board I
think
uh Dennis lazovic the youngster less
experienced of course than Gary but
maybe just as dangerous just as quick
for sure
first thoughts on this position Lawrence
yeah as you said Dave it feels kind of
balanced uh black has got two decent
Bishops but white has got
um perfectly solid position
um
black has got one tiny little weakness
here on C6 which might be a source of
some counter play for white position has
changed ever so slightly
uh seems as though Geary is is actually
trying here
that's what it seems like to me Gary is
not happy with just making a draw
and he's saying well I've got the two
Bishops on an open board why can't I
Fair points
yeah but uh definitely doesn't feel like
it should be too dangerous for why
yeah Gary knows that he lost with white
in the previous round two Magnus if you
if he wants to win a medal if he wants
to win the title he's going to have to
strike back and win with black to
compensate for that defeat and black
does have the two Bishops as he said
Lawrence Black Sea porn looks
potentially quite strong so I'm not
surprised at all that Gary is trying to
play for the win here and uh he also has
a Time Advantage if these clocks will be
are to be trusted under 20 seconds now
for Dennis lazovic Erie with over a
minute the Queens are off the board
suits giri very much uh he loves the end
game also watch out for White Queen side
pawns there a rest of any defense
they're on dark squares easy pickings
for that black dark Square Bishop I'm
loving loving Gary's chances I think
he's
got to take this win if he wants to win
the tournament
Dennis lazovic clinging on for dear life
those white Knights less powerful than
the Bishops
yeah
very sensible move by Gary
yeah and I do think we will see
I do think we will see Geary try just a
little here or maybe more than a little
F4 very committal move there by white
trying to play the move F5 clearly
um and destroy the structure slightly
has lazovic got enough here I would say
black but it's marginal
I would take black every day of the week
I think black is the only one who can
hope to win Bishop D3 by Gary very
committal staff he had the bishop pair
that was one of his main advantages why
is he trying to trade off the Bishops
now is it to protect his C Pawn to free
up the Black Knight here we go the Black
Knight has activated it's hunting down
White's b-pawn uh that pawn on B2 maybe
Gary's winning a pawn here Lawrence how
does yeah prevent that it's inevitable
to be Pawn drops black has a extra Pawn
now an extra pass point on C4 theory on
the brink of Victory but still a lot of
hard work to be done lasovic down to
some mere seconds on the clock
I'm not sure he can hold this it's gonna
be difficult he's got to set up a
blockade with his Knights but that won't
last long term
and uh C3
yeah I love how Annie she's played this
game it's been masterful the bishop now
working it's magic displacing those
Knights
and the pawn is
is protected
it's ready to roll Black's past sea Pawn
Black's King first enters the action
lovely technique from Gary look at that
black king can't stop it you're entering
can't stop it penetrating on the light
squares it's going to come in Via E4 and
I don't think those Knights are that
well placed they look like they're nice
pieces on outposts but they're not going
to stay there for long on dark squares
we see a trade of black Bishop for night
is Gary easing his cause here is he
easing the pastor Victory or is he just
maybe erroneously swapping off material
when he could have kept more pieces on
the board
suddenly some nerves maybe from Gary
kicking in
this Black Sea Pawn he needs to get his
King active again and start advancing it
King's coming
yeah we can see the king moving in now
and I think that this is gonna be
impossible you can even win a pawn now
Knight b196 A3 wins upon
you've got to be careful you don't get
checkmated with the black king in the
center of the board there are some
translating ideas uh if the Knight comes
back to F6 but no we see Gary has broken
through with the black king
pawns are dropping for both sides I'm
very surprised Gary's allowed his eighth
one to drop
to play Lawrence
yeah too many people too many pawns are
coming off I'm getting slightly
concerned now that Anish is actually
blowing this
um it's three versus two only these are
notoriously very difficult to win
I I don't like what Anish has done it's
been too fast and too for us for us to
see every move but
doesn't look oh and Annie's probably
making a move there just before the
clock fell
he nearly lost on time a first second
round in a row again Anish Gary he
should have eliminated White's a pawn
earlier a pawns are so strong against
these Knights blacks Knight's struggling
to go back and stop white tape on
look at this and if she's playing
without a piece now Black's Knight is
stuck completely oh my goodness and
is this gonna be a draw can Anish win
his three Pawns
Lawrence
no idea
he's running through and we get a
handshake where are the Kings being
placed Anish giri takes the win
well it was fast it was Furious but I
think the black pawns were just too
strong for the White Knight and uh
anishikiri sneaking through with the
victory
fantastic stuff
and uh
wow massive massive win for Anish
keeping him
uh very very uh much in touch with the
leaders
think most of the results the big
results have come in now uh we can see
if we've got our roaming cameraman uh in
the in the vicinity if there's any other
big games
I think is Fabi still playing against
Dora Bailey looks as though they're all
looks as though that one's going to end
in a draw very very shortly that is
indeed a draw MBL beats Sam shankland
through the Beats my middle
Timmy have against Hansen
um also
looks like it's going on
it would be great to get there
Eric Hanson fighting to convert this
he's got extra material alerts
okay so tell me if he he has he's got
extra material he's an exchange upload
this is a massive massive opportunity
for Eric Hansen is he going to be able
to apply the pressure
we're waiting for the moves to come
through
now meanwhile Lawrence while we while we
wait for the moves there has been a huge
result in the women's section on board
one the leader has been taken down
Valentino gunina beats and overtakes
Polina shavalova so uh yeah it looks
like wow granita is going to be the sole
leader heading into the ninth and final
round of the day
yeah I mentioned it before she's so
dangerous when she gets a little run
going uh she is in top form what a what
a great thing to say and Lucknow unable
to beat us away ever with the white
pieces massive
very happy with how things are going
because she beats pets and she moves
also into that mix hurricane beats
arabidsu tanjongji beating fatali yeva
as well kostenyuk with a slim chance of
finding her way to the top
we are looking at this guy Merrick
Hansen no more moves coming through
let's focus on this game who have we got
here
so this is uh I recognize tear Dora
inject uh playing Black here uh maybe we
can check what board she is on right now
it looks like board 18 of the women's
section she's facing up against Anna
lotzer from the Czech Republic from
czechia and hey just checking out the
board it looks like black has delivered
a fatal check there blacks Rook landed
on C2 check forking the king and queen
winning material uh teodora as black
takes a win and uh she will leap up the
standings with that Victory how many
more games are ongoing in the tournament
Hall doesn't look like many looks like
players are leaving uh players are off
to take a break off to the restrooms
and uh Lawrence what another dramatic
round Magnus against Hikaru draw
slightly anti-climactic we said but
decent decision uh understandable
completely for both players
yeah
um
Hikaru just uh I think was slightly
surprised by magnus's opening and he
clearly didn't have anything
particularly uh prepared against this
line of the tarash so the way it
happened doesn't surprise me at all and
Hikaru realized he wasn't getting
anything so bailing out
um
ASAP was always going to be the correct
thing to do I think Magnus should be
satisfied he had black uh it was a he
didn't invest too much energy in that
game and so both of them with seven out
of eight still leading the pack
um and there is a whole bunch of players
now on six and a half Gary Duda duboff
manager of amphet
all on six and a half would be
interesting to see I would like to see a
duboff Carlson match uh very very
possible maybe chakra mamajarov Blair
he's he seems to be showing a little bit
of form so I would love to see
one of those match-ups and in the
women's section
Valentina the Destroyer gunina is on
seven out of eight great score
so far overtaking chivalova who is
joined Now by gojkina and harika on six
and a half with a whole bunch of players
on six
uh the women's section will be playing
their last game
uh in the next round for today
yeah and uh on that note Lawrence
there's a lot to unpack we will check in
on the standings on the results and for
the match-ups of that next crucial round
but in the meantime let's take a break
for a couple of minutes and we'll be
back with you shortly see you soon
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back this is the feed a
world literature chess championships
live on chess.com
we are getting towards the end of the
action for today not quite though still
actually a fair few rounds left
especially in the open section it will
be the last round of the women's section
for today we just saw the Clash of the
Titans Nakamura against Carlson it was a
relatively uneventful Affair though a
bit anti-climactic for some perhaps
where I think Magnus surprised Hikaru
slightly in the opening Hikaru decided
to take zero risks the game ended in a
draw
and what that means is that a few
players behind them were able to make up
a little bit of ground namely uh Anish
giri uh yankov
all just half a point behind Carlson and
naka mura
in the women's section massive massive
massive result
for Valentina gunina beating the
extremely strong and young shuvalova
meaning that Valentina gunina
is now the stand alone leader of the
women's section their final round to be
played shortly David
uh thoughts on on the last round and uh
thoughts on
on this round coming up
yeah
um in the women's section this is a
crucial round as you mentioned this is
the last game of the day so so they
could throw all of their energy at this
final game you always want to end the
day on a high of course especially with
uh more games tomorrow you want to sleep
well you want to feel confident you want
to feel sharp and for those at the top
of the table especially gunina now with
white against goyatzkina a defeat might
be disastrous it might put to the end
your streak and it might lead to
downhill spiral so gunina against Goya
vital for both of them another battle of
Russian stars uh gunina Riding High but
goyashikina certainly capable of taking
her down despite having the black pieces
of course on board two she plays shovel
over can travel over recover from that
defeat harika playing very solidly so
far this tournament very well as well
taking lots of chances uh when they've
come and kostenic against lagno
the parents simply do not uh do not get
boring here every single match up is
going to be tight is going to be
ferocious and uh yeah those two Russians
know each other so well uh from their
national team and Lena denier we should
mention against tan Zhong Yi and as
against Elizabeth Elizabeth pets a super
Bhai ever is certainly not out of it
it's very rare to see anyone defend
their titles especially in the world
Blitz championships but she's on course
if she can keep the winning uh can keep
up the wins and keep the pressure on the
leaders uh yeah it's going to be an
exciting round Lawrence will follow that
one as it comes as the results come
through but of course the open section
equally dramatic Magnus Carlson plays
Vladimir fedes they face each other in
the rapid
and that was a very balanced draw so uh
Federal definitely isn't going to lie
down he's uh gonna challenge Magnus he's
a very very uncompromising player do Bob
against Nakamura great match up again
Daniel dubov can he work his magic can
he Checkmate Nakamura can he unleash
these sudden attacks that have brought
him so much so much success over the
years Anish giri meanwhile off the back
of that win with black is up against
Shakira Mahmoud yarov I mean Clash of
the Titans you called it uh a previous
round to Lawrence but all of these guys
Titans in their own right and uh yeah
I'm expecting more decisive results I
don't think the players are going to
take their foot off the gas despite the
fact that draws are sneaky in here and
there it feels like Magnus Carson and
Hikaru Nakamura especially if it agree
to draw with each other fine but now
it's a Sprint to the Finishing Line you
can rack up a greater score against the
rest of the field
yeah uh totally agree with you David
we've got a bunch of insanely good
matchups
irrespective are this round uh Dube of
Nakamura for me is is a really exciting
uh matchup because I think well dubov
just
he's naturally a very ambitious player
and I think he finds it very difficult
just to lock up
and play Uber safe so we're going to get
excitement by by default in in that game
and also Carson fair to say if this is
the second time they've played each
other they played each other in the
rapid uh fair to save
uh is is a tricky customer for Magnus
so I think that uh yeah we're gonna get
some interesting uh matches
yeah and uh just as we wait for the
players to start maybe we can take a
brief look back at those match-ups uh if
we can check back in on those uh as we
see dubov and Nakamura ready to start
their game because there are some
surprising names on the top 10 boards
Lords especially if I'm looking at board
seven bardia danishva from Iran I
believe up against hike matarusian a
surprise name there a young player very
dangerous player but making his way up
the standings there's always a few
underdogs who come and upset the apple
cart in these Blitz events also I'm
looking at board nine an Englishman the
only English player in the open section
and meet Ghazi uh a contemporary of ours
he has risen up the ranks on a winning
streak he's on board nine against
Dimitri and Drake in Lawrence exciting
to see
I mean just let's talk about
um Amit because he's had an unbelievable
little run started off poorly lost in
the first round won the second round
lost the third round
excuse me I'm gonna have to get my voice
in order before we go to the main
matches but then he beat gadin Bailey
Christensen vidit Druid tomashevsky and
just beat the ornament for us I've laid
a lot of Blitz against the meat I know
you have as well he's a serious Blitz
player and now he's all the way up on
board night
yeah and uh it's nice to see how much
your players actually make a mark
against these professionals and meet
garci their onboard nine uh from England
he's got a full-time job he's been
working full-time away from chess for
many many years but Talent does shine
through and he's a blitz specialist he's
played a lot of speeches online over the
board and uh it's really nice to see
these players who are very strong in
their own right of course in their own
countries but come uh onto the world
stage and make their Mark so I think we
are we don't have the cameras right now
but we will follow those games in a
moment we will be focusing on the top
few boards Lawrence what do you think
Carson against fedesaf or Daniel dubov
against Hikaru Nakamura where will we be
focusing on in this I mean I would like
to see do both I would like to see two
of Nakamura uh but uh
let yeah let's go to Duke of Nakamura we
get a scotch
game wow okay that one is good yes and
this new bishop G4 which has been all
the rage in the past few years
um seen as a great attempt for black
just to four straws
I hope we don't get that here I hope
doomov has some little idea to keep the
pressure alive but black has done well
with this particular variation
in terms of trying to force a draw
yeah and I've uh I've seen Nakamura use
this variation already in the past and
guide the game safely towards equality
white is temporarily two pawns up uh
however there is a threat in the
position Bishop takes H7 check Black's
Queen is loose uh there's a discovered
attack there black can solve all of
those issues in one Fell Swoop that can
just take white snipe Bishop takes C3
and uh just there we go we've regained
one Pawn I think the key move after
white moves The Rook for example Rook B1
uh the key move in many of these
variations is to play a quick Bishop G6
I'm not sure whether it's exactly now or
in the near future but you want to
eliminate White's Bishop pair as quickly
as possible otherwise white has a long
time a long-term advantage and this is
certainly going to be opening
preparation for me carolakamura we see a
small pause after King H1 maybe just uh
refreshing the lines in his mind but uh
yeah Daniel duboff has been dabbling in
this opening a lot over the last few
months it's been maybe the main string
to his boat in terms of repertoire with
white so Nakamura clearly undeterred he
has done his homework he it's
interesting to see him take a safe
approach yet again when I when we were
kind of predicting that he would take
risks that he needs to keep up the pace
uh keep that winning streak going but
yeah he respects dubov a lot clearly
Lords he's just trying to equalize here
as black
absolutely he does to play tons online
as well uh so we'll see how this one
develops just a quick uh point to
everybody watching probably asking where
is the live camera feed cameras are
being
re-started in the venue maybe noticed
there was a little bit of lag so
hopefully we'll get the cameras nice and
ready and sharp for you guys for the
remaining rounds but they are currently
being restarted
um no more moves coming through here ah
it was actually agree to draw
it was a greater draw after King H1 yep
they just in this they just agreed to
draw I believe in this position as well
which is uh which is shocking but uh
that's the information I have and draw
alongside
both names means they did agree a draw
let's go to Carlson feather save then
let's see what is going on here Carlson
versus
typical Catalan structure
uh slightly better for white David
yeah traditionally you would uh you
would associate these types of positions
with a slightly more kind of
fluid Pawn structure for white you would
associate this with an advantage
especially because the center is
relatively blocked no Pawn breaks no
open files open diagonals really why
tonight is actually the best minor piece
Black's Bishop sits on a nice Outpost
but hits thin air and I'm slightly
surprised Magnus traded off one set of
nights you want to keep more pistons on
the board usually however maybe it's
just banking on the queen of night being
the superior Duo uh compared to the
queen and Bishop often that becomes a
factor later on this is magnus's bread
of butter he's been playing the Catalan
consistently now for a long long time
and it suits his style I was going to
say it's uncharacteristic of dubov and
that murder to agree a quick draw but
this position is very characteristic of
Magnus Carlson uh it's we talk about
their custom uh the Magnus effect quite
a lot but here Lawrence we already see
it in action the White Knight
maneuvering around don't be surprised to
see that white knight Park itself on the
D3 Square while the rest of whites
forces get ready and black is reduced to
waiting moose it's a very unpleasant
situation I've been there many times
myself on the black side of this porn
structure
if you're impatient if you lash out
pushing any pawns changing the wrong set
of pieces then you will get punished
white is too well centralized that white
D4 Pawn is like a rock it's like a
granite statue it's so hard to erode and
uh I just see magnets pressing this one
for a long long time uh yeah Lawrence
would you like to be in feather save
shoes here
um only if they were Gucci
uh
no I mean
I think he's got a perfectly fine
position so I I wouldn't mind playing
Black here and I I quite like his last
move C5 he's just trying to find a
concrete way
to uh you know to liquidate effectively
um exchange all the pieces
and after Knight D3 you can go for
example Queen back to E7 looks
completely reasonable to me
and yeah I met
Queen D7 is
fine I mentioned that White's D4 Pawn
was the stronghold but if white can't
keep that pawn intact on D4 then black
is completely fine maybe he just found
the right moment the opportune moment uh
to break out feather save and hold the
balance meanwhile uh we are hearing that
the internet is down in the playing Hall
hence the cameras uh the video footage
not being with us just yet so yeah bear
with us hopefully we'll get that fixed
at some point hopefully uh if you can
sort the internet sort the cameras but
uh in the meantime we'll stick with the
games it's nice that the moves are still
coming out we do see a very slow B3 move
by Magnus and a bunch of exchanges is
this one fizzling out Lawrence will we
see total equality or does Magnus still
have some chances in this end game yeah
not not entirely sure it feels as though
he's still got some chances I think
feder serve needs to find at least one
or two really accurate moves right about
now basically uh and
moving the B Pawn looks sensible but
whether you played B6 or B5 B5 looks
very committal to me allowing A5 I don't
I don't know but the years but but feder
save is one of those players where he's
just going to go for it Queen A7 that's
exactly the move and now the point is
you drop D4 so Rook A1 Rook takes D4
and Rook at Rook A2 and maybe this is
just genius by Magnus Carlson because
now he has passed a pawn The Rook behind
it
and everything else protected and maybe
this is just unpleasant to defend now
for fair to save yeah
it wouldn't be the first time we've used
those two words together those two
phrases together in the same sentence
Magnus Carlson and genius not everyone
would sacrifice a porn black is a pawn
up now having captured White's isolated
D4 Pawn uh and Magnus he sees that
there's bigger issues at play he gave up
opponent gets Anish Girish to dominate
Gary's Bishop now he's given up a pawn
to dominate Black's Rook look at The
Rook on A7 tied down if the Queen's come
off you have to ask the question is
white simply winning because White's
Rook is active supporting a pawn
blackstroke is passive uh simply
blockading blacks Double B pawns as well
don't make a great impression they are
ripe for picking later and their clear
targets and Black's poor majority
actually
does lie in those Double B pawns which
isn't necessarily impressive Magnus
though while a quick flurry of moves I
don't know how we achieved this but he
managed to get his Rook to the eighth
rank with a check he's just captured
opponent Lawrence there's a queen
exchange possible there's Queen trade
yeah this has actually gone wrong for
Magnus hasn't it because now uh Federal
saves are poured up in a rook ending and
in the worst case scenario it's going to
be a trade for f i mean Magnus is
probably going to play Rook C5 uh and
mop these up Freda save is going to win
this and we're going to reach a fairly
well-known theoretical drone Rook ending
and it is a draw
as far as I could see I saw the draw
Flash wouldn't surprise me if they've
actually agreed or Draw
in this position
yeah as you mentioned Rook C5 all the
pawns come off the board black will go
Pawn hunting white will go Pawn hunting
and it will be completely level so uh we
missed the fireworks there but it did
look like the queen exchange was very
timely by fedesev just before Magnus was
able to deliver a knockout blue to the
black king and uh yep a draw looks like
the results in this game Lawrence where
shall we go next
foreign
looks like another balanced Affair here
looks
yeah well life points against iPhones
level material
yeah the B Pawn the weakness being
offset by the seapoon weakness
um
very difficult to see how white all
black can make serious progress in a
position like this of course you've got
to be careful for tricks that you don't
run into some 93 forts but in general
um
feels like this one should fizzle out
it looks objectively balanced but Gary
thrives in these types of positions and
Mama jarov He's on record as saying that
he doesn't really enjoy long grindy end
games where maybe he has uh long-term
weaknesses and uh yeah he wants to
calculate his way out of trouble my
majority is so good at that that part of
the game Knight E3 check is coming I
expect white to just guard against that
maybe with a move such as Rook D1 or
King E2
horns might get exchanged it should be a
draw with best play but
Gary I do feel has a slightly more
harmonious Pawn structure why it's four
points on the king side could be a
decisive Factor later
we're waiting for the moves to trickle
in I think still some internet issues at
the venue but yeah you might be right uh
in the balance
in the balance in this game yeah and
it's maybe we can do a quick scan while
we wait for the moves wait for updates
was already a draw in the women's
section they did have a very fighting
draw though but I that that does mean
that billionaire is she's going to be at
least
top of the pile
but I say at least because Paulina
shuvalova did beat harika with the black
pieces and castenia has beaten lachno
with the white pieces so good enough and
shuvalova are sharing the lead going
into tomorrow and then a nice group of
players tanjong
and costeno all on seven points
um
yeah so
lots of uh competition there and in the
open section
as far as I can tell
uh
well the internet
is giving us real problems because we're
not getting any moves anywhere at the
moment
uh
we've got uh well uh
information that this game ended in a
draw Gary against mamajarov
cadrich has beaten you Yang Yi with the
black pieces it seems
uh which is a phenomenal result that is
cartridge I've only rated 25.84
is now right up there in the mix and
Matthias bluebound has beaten mvl
this is a massive blow
for the reigning Blitz World Champion to
lose against matteus of course Mateus a
very very strong player but a massive
massive blow and amigosi has beaten
Dmitry and drakin what an unbelievable
result
for Amit Ghazi beating one of the best
Blitz players in the world and all of a
sudden amigazi is going to be a top six
board uh participant what an
unbelievable result
for amigosi what a run he's having
yeah you couldn't write that right
Lawrence you couldn't script it and it's
a Hollywood uh story for Amit Ghazi so
far the only English player in the field
and uh he's only an IM remember so he's
mixing it with world-class Grand Masters
this uh I am and he's doing the business
very very proud uh I must say there's
lots of underdogs actually Rising making
their Mark uh taking down the more
experienced uh opponents but yeah
meanwhile all we have it is the results
no moves unfortunately are me to doing
his bit for England but uh we are still
awaiting some of the other results it
looks like draws on the top four boards
meaning the status quo will be
maintained uh it won't shake up the
standings too much but it does give the
chasing pack an opportunity to catch up
so we're gonna see things Bunch up even
more at the top it looks like Nakamura
and Carlson will be the soul leaders uh
joint leaders uh going into round 10 of
the date we still have three more games
we're hoping of course Lawrence right
that the internet will be back the
camera feed will be back and that we can
enjoy three more games of action
let's hope so we're going to take a
break we'll be right back with continued
coverage of today's action don't go
anywhere
[Music]
so I first learned about ill Cafe
through my buddy Aaron he was like Hey
me and a group of fellas meet at this
Cafe downtown on Sundays and we play
chess there it'd be really cool if you
could stop by and hang out with us and
you know just feel the vibe and so I
showed up
and it was a nice bike I was like yo ill
Cafe is pretty ill
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to the
free day world Blitz championships uh we
have now reached round 10 of the 12
planned for today the women's section
have completed their nine rounds they
will be back tomorrow but the good news
is we have got the internet connection
back over from the playing Hall
we've got uh camera feeds live again so
lovely to be able to see all the action
uh of course and uh that means that
we've got um
a really really nice insight into the
remaining three rounds for today
there are two leaders in the open
section not surprisingly Magnus Carlsen
hikaranakamura are leading the pack but
a big bunch of players just behind them
on seven out of nine I'm here with David
Hal David take us through what we just
saw and uh what are we looking forward
to in this round
yeah we're looking forward to plenty of
things I've got to say here Lawrence uh
we're looking forward to whether Magnus
Carlson Auntie coronakamura can pick the
pace back up they've slowed down
slightly with a couple of draws in the
last two games we also following that
clip that chasing pack there are eight
players just half a point behind Castle
Nakamura poised ready to pounce and uh I
guess they're gonna get their shot a
couple of those players on seven points
are gonna get a chance to try it their
hand against Carson Nakamura maybe we
can look slightly further down the
standings as well we've got to mention
Dennis cadrich in Ninth Place shout out
to him uh Rising through the ranks now
representing Montenegro uh he has been
putting together a winning streak one of
the lower rated players on that on that
score group and here we see 11th to 20th
Place slightly further behind but huge
names such as caruana you Yang Yi joined
Now by Dennis lazovic the youngster and
Amit Garcia from England only and I am
outrated by a couple of hundred points
compared to some of uh his rivals on the
same score group let's go check out
those match-ups let's examine what we
can look forward to in the next round
round which does start in a few minutes
it's Magnus Carlson against shakuria
Mahmoud yarov the Firebrand Shack Attack
as he's known sometimes Magnus this is
not going to be an easy pairing for him
he has a great score with whites against
mamajarov but as everyone knows
mamajorov cannot be taken lightly uh
Nakamura faces off against Duda Duda
with black there also doing pretty well
in the last few rounds but needs to beat
Nakamura if he wants to overtake him and
cadrics on board three against duboff
Dennis cartridge he beat me last year in
the world Blitz he's a very aggressive
player he never backs down never
Retreats a piece and he's up against
another uh famed attacker Daniel of that
is going to be Chaos on the board
guaranteed and uh Lawrence I guess we
have a bit of skin in the game now we
are definitely uh going to be following
Ami Garcia's progress against Fabiano
caruana when was the last time an
Englishman made it up to board six of
the world Blitz Championship it's been a
few years uh he is doing extremely well
at the moment
yeah absolutely uh what a what a
fantastic run he's having
uh as for as for the the top games uh
David
has traditionally been and I'm not going
to quote who said this but Magnus
Carlson's client
okay I'm not gonna quote who mentioned
that but in other words chakria has had
a disastrous time against Magnus there
are little periods where he seems to get
back into the mix against Magnus and be
able to kind of
stand his ground and then there are
periods where he just gets beaten by
Magnus relentlessly
um he seems to be playing pretty
decently this time we've not really seen
him at all on the top tables uh in the
rapid he just for whatever reason wasn't
there but
um he's very much a temperamental kind
of player he can be an absolute genius
beat anybody and then the next day or
the next round he can play very clumsily
so I'm very curious to see how he does
against uh against Magnus
um as for Nakamura Duda two guys just
that are very strong very much in form
and uh well
uh I I expect that to be a close Affair
but do both black against cartridge
cartridge a pretty unknown quantity
rated 2657 though very very decent Blitz
player but do wobble fans of his chances
there with black being so tricky himself
um
so we'll keep a keen eye on it and
obviously yes
I've got to say Lawrence uh it's a
relief uh it's nice to have the cameras
back I've missed the players yes I hope
we do see a view of the playing Hall
half of it has emptied the uh women are
done for the day as we mentioned but
yeah we will be keeping an Eagle Eye On
The Players while we can see them and uh
here we have a nice close-up of the
board it's the open Spanish like
grabbing this Pawn on e4 and this is a
variation that Magnus has played himself
recently he played this
I think a couple of months ago on the
Champions chess tour with white it looks
relatively unambitious White's opening
you give up the bishop pair however
Magnus gains space in the center now and
this is mamajara's pet line he nearly
always plays the open Spanish against
top players in the world uh he lives and
dies by The Sword and he lives and dies
by this opening but uh Magnus clearly
has come prepared Knight to C3 allowing
a capture
with the blacks Bishop off the white
knight in the center what is Magnus
doing this looks bizarre frankly to me
it looks like Mama jar of with this last
move very clever move undermining
White's night in the middle of the board
looks fantastic for black at this early
stage
um Lawrence C5 by black manager of
not hesitating there allowing white
tonight into the center Magnus barely
hesitating either
we're seeing a bunch of exchanges it's
getting very very sharp symmetrical Pawn
structure now but white Knights are
extremely active can black wind material
though there are some awkward pins in
the position it doesn't look like uh
Magnus is too worried it's two nights
against two Bishops
how to evaluate this I don't even know
where to begin I must admit one of the
two players if not both of them seem to
be in their preparation
even in this round line
yeah I'm not I'm not sure this feels
like a bit of a freestyle For Me From
magnus's perspective but how can Shaq be
at all unhappy I mean he's got
everything he wanted out of the opening
he's solid he can play C6 he can play
Bishop E6 he can play for a p8
um Bishop B6 has just been played Magnus
has got completely
you know nothing basically in this
position he's going to take on F6 Queen
takes F6 and then he's going to play a
move like I don't know B3 securing his
structure uh and then you know simply
put he just
Rook 81 Rook fd8 will come we'll Rook 88
the queen will drop back to E3
it comes into C5 instead or C5
and he can trade he can play Rook d8 and
he's played it Shack with yeah
I mean Shaq is Shaq is maybe even better
here after Rook d8
you know because the white background is
slightly weak
the Knight on E5 doesn't actually do
anything
would you take black here I think I
would
I would happily take black here I'm not
saying black has an advantage but it
looks like you've solved all your
problems it's very easy to play look at
the clocks as well Shakira has 40
seconds extra on the clock any end game
like you say Lawrence might favor Black
the bishop will be superior to White's
Knight and the black Bishop has a nice
safe Square to sit on nicely defended
White's night a bit unstable a bit loose
and White's Queen side pawns on C4 and
A2 especially on light squares easy
targets
I think Magnus needs to pull the brakes
here needs to just neutralize uh Black's
initiative like you say the back rank
vulnerable he's just chosen a poor
opening it feels like uh the world
champion and my major of playing
instantly up to this point he was either
very well prepared or just uh feeling
sharp it's uh yeah I mean I think the
more I look at it the easier Black's
position is to play Magnus clearly
struggling for moves grimacing here as
we can see on the cameras not happy at
all this could be a third game in the
row that Magnus fails to win all of that
early initiative winning his first four
five rounds and that has dissipated now
and you just got to swap the Rooks
you've gotta
give that white king some lift some
breathing space
maybe you can sidestep a rook exchange
he does keep the Rooks on the board
but uh yeah I'm a giraffe
in his element this is also a very
typical manager position yes it's
heading towards the end game but it's
about peace activity it's no longer
about those small finesses like Pawn
structure uh kind of long-term factors I
think he's got to be loving life look at
magnus's Rook Lawrence on F1
it's on the light Square vulnerable to
Black Bishop long term
manager protects the C porm by playing
C6 I think Queen B6 now our name plays
B3 well now you play H6 as a manager of
course to give the kingdom some Luft uh
which he does
and as soon as black speaking has some
breathing space Black's Rook is coming
into D2 like his Queen is coming into F4
maybe we can get a camera on the board
again as we try to catch up with the
moves a lot of moves being played there
we go look at this both Queens are in
White's Queen attacking blacks Queen
type pawns Black's Queen trying to do
the same
okay Magnus one whole minute down on the
clock he's been here before remember he
was two and a half minutes down on the
clock in round one yet he still managed
to win and manager of going for a rook
Exchange
hey Rook takes Rook as possible but
there's a huge threat black is
threatening Rook takes F1 followed by
Queen D1 Checkmate Magnus has to be
extremely careful here
okay he takes White's King is forced
onto H2 and now a pin on the White
Knight
wait there's F6 wait wait wait wait wait
wait this is just over you have to go F4
I beg your pardon but f67 is Magnus in
trouble
I think he's in huge trouble he's going
to have to drop a pawn why tonight is
going to have to move out the way
and black is just going to sweep in
Queen takes F4 check winning a pawn
it's not the end of the road it's not
the end of the game but why are we just
too far away
Lawrence wow this has gone wrong for
Magnus
this has been the catastrophic game so
far now the question is does he take on
nature yeah
take on Atria or go Queen B8 he's gone
for taking on H3 you can't blame him two
pawns up five seconds Magnus Carlson on
the verge gotta move for catastrophic
loss
one second left queen now he takes the
Knight
yeah he's pulling down with a naked King
now uh Magnus Carson only a few seconds
left on the clock he's two pawns down
yet again
amateur is going to wrap this on up
surely unless there's a miracle
Perpetual change
has allowed
black can color escape the tricks oh my
God he's blundered the perpetual
oh he's sick
he's sick what a chance to beat Magnus
oh my goodness me Miracle safe by Magna
star mamajarov so frustrated at himself
we see a handshake Black's King can't
avoid the checks he got overexcited the
adrenaline was pumping and he let a
winning position slip
Houdini like escaped by Magnus there and
uh Lawrence wow we have to go to another
game
okay we see Hikaru nakamura's game now
we can tell by the shirt that Hikaru is
playing white and by his trademark ring
he's up against Duda I believe
uh do the hair with black let's do a
quick count on the material white has a
bishop Knight for blacks rook and two
Pawns
Lawrence do you take White's position
with the minor pieces or do you back
Judas Rook
I actually think I prefer black here
it's very rare that I would take black
but the reason is the white king is much
less safe than the black king it's only
because of that
now does that mean objectively black is
better no but that's just what I would
do if you force me to take a side
that said the Hikaru has also got a
massive lead on the clock I'm still in a
bit of shock that manager of allowed
Magnus to get away with that that is a
shocking shocking uh way to let it draw
uh slip yeah and uh Lawrence I think
that Duda missed a huge move a moment
ago there was a pin on the second rank I
think it could have played Queen F4 a
few moves ago basically winning the game
but uh dude I missed that one and
Nakamura is back in it 20 over seconds
now for Nakamura he's rotating his
Knight as he likes to say Knight C3
suddenly are we gonna see things turn
the black Rook is still active Okay
Nakamura can't take black Central pawns
that is the key
Lawrence I think you're right the white
king is the more vulnerable of the two
oh until he allowed this check
dude how did he allow that
the White Queen is in the White Knight
is coming
now this has gone horribly wrong but
yeah it's your stuff
he needs a miracle now
to save this this is
green H7 King C6
Knight back to C3 great defense here by
uh by Hikaru finding some
coordination amongst his pieces
Lawrence I've got to say dude has been
playing several moves with one second on
his clock and there we go he went down
to two seconds again
white has gone passive with his pieces
what the White Queen the white Bishop
White Knight they're a bit stuck right
now but there we go Nakamura gets active
again hitting the king with some checks
it's not easy the white Bishop is pinned
you're a bit stuck here but I think Duda
has at least restored some balance uh
here he's still struggling no black king
so open but Nakamura he can't decide is
he attacking is he defending he keeps
changing his mind and now Nakamura under
five seconds
we've got to say anything's still
possible here Black's Rook is on a loose
Square Lawrence
is that going to be decisive okay
Nakamura knocking over pieces both sides
very very visibly nervous we could see a
repetition of the position Duda does
repeat and there we go I think we'll see
a handshake if due to blocks that's
three times we've seen that position
he had a chance
wow oh and Nakamura swapping the queens
that is
tantamount to agreeing a draw there not
enough material left and well both sides
have reason to be unhappy they're missed
chances for both it feels like
whoa what a chance also there you said
for Duda missing uh a spot there
potentially Daniel dubov did beat Dennis
cadrich by the way uh which is uh a
massive result for Daniel and his Gary's
still playing possibly against further
save is that is that true no we're just
not uh that was a draw
uh amikaze did not continue his uh his
good run he does lose to Fabiano caruana
Marty rosian beats blue balm what about
artemisovic
let's see if we have some result there
that was also a draw
wow
absolutely fantastic stuff
yeah lots of draws but uh other than
those games that have been halved out it
does look like the favorites took the
point in most of the games here we see a
clash between real goon and uh Salam
Saleh the strongest player from UAE and
is this one fizzling out to draw Black's
just given up a knight it's Rook versus
porn but the white king is too far away
it looks like that black porn will cost
white it's uh his rook and uh yeah we
will see a draw no way to keep the game
going the white Rook
just too far away the white king one two
one square too far away as well and a
handshake Bill goon knowing it's a
missed opportunity but it is a draw
and uh well will we be taken next
I hate roving cameras
we'll see you can see a lot of movement
now looks as though whenever there's a
kind of crowd of people it looks as
though there's still a game going on and
looks like right in the center there
might still be a game going on
but as far as I can tell uh
I can't I can't locate it at least on
the boards
a massive let off though that's the
story of that round Magnus Carlsen was
dead to riots had no time had no
position and yet still still he finds a
way to salvage the game against manager
of Hikaru Nakamura looked as though he
had a tough position maybe do that for
one move had a winning position
uh but also Hikaru managing to salvage
Daniel dubel throwing himself back into
the mix though with the win and in fact
with that Victory Daniel dubov joins the
leaders as does as does Hayek Marta
rosian from absolutely nowhere I eat
matarosi and the young Armenian
Grandmaster beating Matthias bluebound
also means that he is on 8 out of ten
giri versus a draw so four players on
eight out of ten and Below them at least
five or six players on seven and a half
you've got to be not only good but
you've got to be lucky and you create
your own luck when you're the best in
the world Carlson Nakamura both let off
the hook in that round are they starting
to get tired are the nerves starting to
get there
I suggest David we go for a quick break
before we rejoin the action again
round 11 coming up don't go anywhere
[Music]
I understand 18 seconds for a black so
not too much time there either Rook C7
a7's falling uh it is E4 he pushes the
pawn this is getting a little messy
takes a knight F1
91
. move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played
The Rock I was gonna say King C2 and run
the king
93.4 takes it
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that was me and instead he
played here and you're never losing oh
my God A7 wins for white oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
World Blitz championships you can see a
shot of the playing Hall there that is
min Lee sitting down the
absolute wizard when it comes to Blitz
online chess if you've been playing on
chess.com you would have seen mainly win
countless title Tuesdays and other
competitions an absolute Phenom when it
comes to Blitz
uh the players are waiting for the
moment for uh the following round round
11 there are two more rounds left for
today if you didn't know I'm
International Martial Lawrence Trent
alongside me is Grandmaster David Howe
and uh we've had an incredible day so
far it was smooth sailing for the big
favorites of this tournament Fabio uh I
think Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura but
some chinks in the armor are starting to
appear David they got lucky last round
didn't they
yeah it feels like the favorites have
lost all momentum they're a bit stuck in
the mud right now just unable to get in
the flow again they've been bogged down
by all these drawers and that has
allowed the chasing pack to catch up as
you mentioned there Lawrence Magnus
Carlson
pulling Miracles out the bag in that
last game to survive against mamajarov
when he was almost dead and buried
Nakamura as well an up and down game
against Duda and that has allowed
players to catch up so uh we're
expecting maybe more of the same it's
not going to be easy it's not going to
be plain sailing for those guys at the
top they are facing Elite Grand Masters
every single game now so we are
expecting more shocks more twists and
turns along the way and uh yeah the
women's section meanwhile has uh breaked
until tomorrow and uh yeah it will be
fascinating to see those standings by
the end of today tomorrow of course is
crunch time the money rounds when uh the
states are higher when the players will
have to bring their a game but these
final rounds where they jockey for
position today also crucial
yes they are and uh there are four
players at the top of the table in the
open section
Magnus Carlsen Hikari Nakamura
uh hike matsurosian is up there as well
a name that perhaps a lot of our viewers
won't know so well uh he's a young
Armenian Grandmaster very strong and
Daniel dubov after beating Dennis
cadrich with the black pieces Daniel
not exactly an unfamiliar name part of
the Magnus Carlson team
um one of the most creative players out
there a real character
so they have managed to join the lead
eight out of ten still a monster score
of course and then
just behind them we have uh giri Duda
for to save Carolina Rapport and manager
of what a Chancellor for manager of to
beat Magnus Carlson he'll be desperately
disappointed we will be having a look at
the games for the next round but before
we go there
um don't forget it's not too late for
you to have your say in the 2022
chess.com
Awards with categories like Game of the
Year Player of the Year creator of the
year don't forget to lock in your vote
type in exclamation mark Awards to vote
now to find out more information
um and
vote away it is free and every single
vote is appreciated
David we're going to go into round 11
and we've got an absolutely
mouth-watering Prospect at the top
do Bob Carlson
yup what a match up that is going to be
here we see the standings uh Carlson
Nakamura dubov and matarossian as you
say there Lawrence and uh a huge chasing
pack now a growing chasing pack just
half a point behind we see the top 20.
there's only a point or so between them
and it is going to get dramatic by the
end of the day let's check out those
pairings those matchups you mentioned
the standout the highlight of the round
potentially Daniel dubov against Magnus
Carlson great friends great Rivals
Daniel dubov has beaten Magnus before he
has done it he's especially scored well
with white he's going to go all out I
feel in this game and uh this is his big
chats Mata rosian Armenian youngster
very quick very sharp can Nakamura end
his drawing streak and and take this
point Nakamura he will have flashbacks
to yesterday in the rapid tournament the
last few days he drew nine games in a
row there he doesn't want to allow that
to continue it's three draws in a row
now Nakamura he needs to break that
Trend caruana making his way up again on
board three against fedesaf Anish giri
also in the mix against the Rapport and
manager of Judah equally important for
the standings looks like the players are
starting to take their seats they are
getting ready for the round just a
couple of minutes now uh just a few
minutes before we have liftoff brutal
matchups as said there by chess wind in
the featured chat
I don't think we'll see this run of Jaws
continue Lawrence I don't know about you
I can't see Carson or Nakamura being
halted for this long it must have been
years since they went this long uh
without a blitz win
um
uh yes uh very much so uh I think uh I
think we'll see some some serious blood
this round I'm expecting a lot of
decisive results at the very top players
are now ready to go sat in their places
um
Duke of Carlson Daniel massive respect
for Magnus maybe too much respect
in some ways I think finds it very
difficult to beat Magnus and in the
second board we have
well this young chap here on the left
hand side martirosian
playing against the seasoned genius
Hikaru Nakamura hikara of course big
favor on paper but matarosian 22 years
old
from Armenia he's now number three in
Armenia after the departure of
levonaronian to the us a lot of people
asking why Levon isn't there
David
are we allowed to say do you know the
reason uh firstly I don't know the
reason we can speculate Lawrence level
neuronian uh now in the US firstly it's
a very very long trip over to Kazakhstan
from the US I know a lot of the American
players struggled with jet lag Nakamura
said that was one of the reasons behind
his disappointing performance in the
world rapid championship and uh yeah I
think Levon he's played a lot recently
he's one of the most active players of
2021 so we can't blame him for taking a
break Wesley so another strong American
player who isn't there one player who is
there in Kazakhstan though is
janapomnishi who will play for the world
championship title In classical chess uh
in just a few months time he's climbing
up the table Lawrence he's made it onto
the top 10 boards again and watch out
some of these top players are going to
catch up if Nakamura and Carlson can't
start winning again meanwhile while
early developments in the Nakamura game
I think nakamura's played something
called the two nights Tango very rare
opening uh in his winning attempts
against motorossian this however is
dubov against Carlson those two friends
dubov very well known for making very
calm gestures every time he makes a move
bringing his Bishop out here
quite a rare setup I've got to say this
is something I've seen most players play
before but it's like it's supposed to be
very solid in this type of structure
Magnus though with his moves look at
this night move Knight A6
weird wonderful this shows that he
really wants to win when Magnus takes
risks and plays unorthodox moves like
this
shows he's in a certain mood
what do you think Lawrence will Magnus
and Karu take risks as black to try and
beat their lower rated opponents
it seems they will right I mean this
position here is is definitely an
orthodox it doesn't look too bad for
black though I mean A3 is a
relatively tame move yeah CD4
CD4 H6 how bad can
lacks position B
uh
maybe what wine is still slightly for
preference but
yeah I was going to say look at what
duboff's doing he's just put all of his
pawns on dark squares every single one
he's got a light Square Bishop so uh
those pawns on darkspace complement that
Bishop very well but to me it looks like
he's just trying to set up a wall he's
just trying to erect a wall of Pawns
that blacks Bishops cannot uh kind of
they'll just bite against they cannot
get past and I think he's saying to
Magnus come at me you do you you do what
you want I'm not going to Flinch I'm not
going to create any weaknesses in my
position yeah I'm not sure who's for
Choice here Lawrence you said maybe
white for preference but I think it's
just in the balance it's about where the
magnets can work that magic that we are
so used to as he does finally centralize
that poorly placed Knight
or white is going to try and trade off
the light Square Bishops all the Rooks
are likely to come off on the open C
file at some point
it's not what we hoped for it's not
duboff attacking uh as uh we've seen so
many times in the last few days
Magnus is surely going to be happy with
the outcome of this opening especially
with black it's solid it's stable that
is right up his alley
yeah I think he I think at least if he's
if he's not uh
if he's not uh he won't be he might not
be happy but he won't be unhappy I think
is what I'm trying to say uh he might
have fancied having a real go against
Daniel because he knows Daniel can give
him chances but yeah this position here
is
is very very sound for both players
structure is equal minor pieces both are
kind of working the bishop is not bad
and I can sit on D5 Bishop can come back
to E7
um
I guess can white go E4
in the current position possibly
I wonder if he's gonna play that
it would be very inconsistent for white
to start pushing Pawns in the center now
especially the opponent has Bishops any
opening of the position would favor uh
what would potentially help the black
Bishop it feels like Daniel is in a very
solid very peaceful mood it does make a
lot of sense to push forward but I just
don't think that's uh matching what his
game strategy was he does play 94 white
Knights do look pretty nice pretty
mobile
just dancing around there in the center
looking very very balanced still and
yeah I agree with Brennan Causey there
nice pieces being used over in
Kazakhstan I've been hunting for a
wooden chessboard of my own recently and
this one looks very nice and pretty but
yeah it's uh it's very much dubov who's
kind of trying to maintain the status
quo right now Magnus is the one trying
to
create something black pushes A5 white
pushes H4 on opposite flanks I don't
think either side's gonna make Headway
uh do both though it will be hinting
that he might go towards the black king
if Magnus is careless lacks Queen very
far away from any potential defensive
role
Queen B8 mysterious maybe just trying to
initiate a bunch of Rook exchanges on
the C file
yeah it's uh it's not easy to get too
excited about this position especially
if dubov's playing moves like King G1
just waiting moves purely
and Magnus gets impatient he swaps a
pair of Rooks
now this is strange Lawrence I've got to
say dubov playing Safety First chess uh
it's rare to see him playing this solid
it feels like he thinks the drawer a
draw is a good result against Magnus
feels like the players are thinking of
the tournament as a whole rather than
each game individually is that a good
strategy do you think dubot's gonna be
well ordered here
I don't know I I think uh also tiredness
is kicking in 12 rounds of Blitz in one
day is quite a lot I remember you know
nine round tournaments is is already uh
you know sufficient but 12 is quite a
lot so I think there's a certain level
of pacing going on
um they don't want to get they don't
want to drop points unnecessarily
um
but a small imbalance now on the board
David
yeah there has been an exchange reports
on the queen side so Black's A5 Pawn
white B2 Pawn which is the weaker it's
completely unclear Magnus is being
pushed back though the white knights
with the blocked Central nature uh the
center the nature of the central pawns
uh it does feel like the position favors
Knights I don't really like where Magnus
is planted his Bishop Black's Bishop
looks a bit stuck but his Queen is
getting active still balanced we've got
to say uh you would normally back
Madness against most players in the
world in this type of position but
duboff well known uh as having great
understanding great instincts I'm
wondering uh Lawrence if we will see a
Time scramble and maybe magnus's nerves
uh holding in if we get that but you
know right now we're trying to catch up
with the moves I think black has planted
the queen on B5 there we go Rook C2 by
white dubot's just playing waiting moose
every single turn hesitating seeing a
night trade and with that nitrate a
peace offering a draw has been agreed
this one wasn't too exciting let's
switch over to see if Nakamura is still
going
looks like he is indeed against uh the
young Armenian Mata rosian and uh
there's a lot of knights in this game as
well the position just repeated itself
once just as we entered this game it's
looking very very blocked with a traffic
jam of pieces in the center
yeah those two white Knights block out
the black Rooks the two black knights
block out the white Rooks is this just
leveled that's the question Nakamura
will want to try and push this he's got
20 seconds extra on the clock he has the
pawn breaks black can play a move such
as E5 if he's desperate to try and win
and it is Nakamura he's a very
aggressive player very ambitious player
he does push E5 the Black Knights are
coming in now
we saw Magnus a moment ago curious
watching his rival play
it's King nice and safe again
I don't know about you Loris but I love
those two black knights it feels like
there are tricks there are Forks all
over the place in the air right now
well it's got to be careful I I do think
now I think this is objectively much
harder for white to play
that being said I don't know whether
it's actually bad for white the bar
seems to be only in slightly in Black's
favor that's probably because
objectively there's some kind of dynamic
um uh
the quality somehow but I did the last
move was not loved and Knight F5 hold on
things are now starting to get a bit
more concrete because Knight takes E3 is
a difficult threat to stop and the B5
Pawn is hanging so after rookie two
seconds left for MATA rosian he's
struggling on the clock he's lost a pawn
black has gobbled up a Pawn on B5 he's
got a two versus one Queen side majority
now Magnus was lurking lingering
watching Nakamura but ever since that
has happened Nakamura shrink great
technique he wins a second Pawn
but now Black's Rooks are going to start
lining up on the second rank there we
see Magnus watching Nakamura
can he win and take the lead with one
round to go today he gives a check but
the white king is terrible on the back
rank three seconds for matarosian
he attacks the black Rook all Nakamura
needs to do is double up his Rooks on
the second round there we go double
trouble with those Rooks White's King is
surely not going to survive
the attack incoming all black needs to
do is threaten the background Checkmate
there we go I can take Pawns in the
process that black knight is ready to
join the attack as well Lawrence surely
this is game okay Knight H5 yeah exactly
yeah
superior quality Superior class there
Nakamura takes the win
and uh which gives us massive win
well we should point out that's a
massive win because with that win
card Nakamura goes in Seoul first
position regardless of what happens in
the other games fair to save has beaten
Fabiano massive win for Philadelphia to
beat Fabi that blunts fabi's chance is
massively
uh in this tournament and then there
were a bunch of drawers Gary Rapport
married all draws and Timmy have Beats
blue balm Kmart loses to matlakov
and Dennis lazovic wins another game
this time against cartridge meaning that
he's on eight points so as things stand
it's Nakamura on nine Carlson duboff
feta save on eight and a half and
Lawrence a whole bunch of players yeah
we've got to check in on the chess again
we have another big clash between
tomaszewsky and David Anton guillero uh
two very strong Grand Masters and both
aiming to try and make up some of the
ground that uh that they've lost in uh
the first few rounds of the tournament
black is two pawns out but look at the
time two seconds one second he made that
move with a second left how can he keep
those two black pawns intact
tomachevsky's job as white is to trade
off his Knight for Black's two pawns if
he can draw immediately and uh here we
go black is trying to triangulate lose a
bit of time with his King now some
checks are coming can the black king
start entering going towards the White
Knight you've got a bank on the point
here you've got to say these are going
to be decisive he think he's running
through he kicked out that white knight
two seconds left now David Anton one
second
he's coming through I think he's gonna
win that black pawn he's gonna cost
white his knight and Thomas yeah he let
his clock fall
win for black win for the Spaniard
yeah tomashevsky the professor
not able to find a solution there
against David Anton bigwin for David
Anton he would love to make a good run
in this tournament
um feels as though we are close to the
end of the round
big news Nakamura winning getting some
separation Half Point Clear from Magnus
Carson Daniel
see another game Lawrence but it is
about to end in a draw a bit lower down
the standings there's no way to win this
Rook end game and uh a handshake like
you said all the results are coming in
now
um another peaceful result in this one
it looks like the players are getting
tired now getting impatient for that
final round they want the break they
want the rest tonight uh it is 12 games
today tomorrow is shorter we should
mention nine rounds in the open section
so the players will have enough energy
tomorrow but tonight is the struggle
this is
yeah crunch time in terms of putting
yourself in a position for those prizes
indeed
and uh of course we will
uh come back with the final uh round of
today but I think it's important to also
just point out a little food for thought
Magnus Carlson last few games draw draw
got lucky to draw one another draw in
the final game and if Hikaru wins Hikaru
may actually be a point clear of Magnus
going into tomorrow now that's still a
manageable amount but
we've been talking about is this going
to be hikaru's year what is he going to
need to do to win this tournament well
separation from Magnus as early on as
possible is critical he should be
absolutely over the moon with how things
are going we'll come back with the final
round of today round 12 with the
pairings and more analysis in just a few
minutes make sure you stay with us
this is duck chash you guys this is a
new variant it's called Duchess chess
[Music]
duck chest the duck is a brick pieces
cannot move through the square occupied
by the duck click on a square to place
the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the puns King to win oh wow though
there's no stalemates but still wait
there is still meat but the still made
the player wins ooh if only that was
real chess I think I'm getting the hang
of this game I think I think I actually
am getting the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time winning
duck chest
oh no no no no no no no slip no no no no
no no
one
one yeah duck chess champion give me
those points baby
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
of today's action from the world uh
Blitz championships taking place in
uh almati Kazakhstan it's been an
absolutely thrilling day so far tons of
action but the clear storyline is that
Hikaru Nakamura has been uh exceptional
and has managed to get a little bit of
Separation only half a point from the
rest of the field including off a point
ahead of Magnus Carlson who let's face
it has looked a little sloppy looked a
little
well he's he's lacked a bit of energy
over the past few rounds including
saving a miracle lost position against
Shakira mamijara of the standings are as
follows uh Nakamura online Carlson dubov
who's having a great tournament on eight
and a half and a whole bunch of other
names still very much in it on eight
points including names that perhaps we
don't know that well in for example
Dennis lazovic uh the young player who's
got a fantastic reputation online is
also showing that in over the board
Blitz he's a force to be reckoned with
I'm with David Hal David
um the momentum starting to turn up for
Hikaru Nakamura
yep it's uh still early days as you
mentioned Lawrence uh still plenty of
rounds nine games tomorrow plus one game
uh to finish today but nakamura's fate
is in his own hands he knows that now he
has a slight lead on Magnus Magnus has
drawn four games in a row and if he can
extend that lead or at least maintain it
by winning this final round we see
Nakamura on board two there uh facing
feather save but he's got the white
pieces if Nakamura can take the win he's
got to be a big favorite to uh cruise
home tomorrow and uh take that title
take that gold medal that he's been
craving so badly we do see artemiev
against Carlson another crucial game on
board one there uh Magnus is fixed on
board one we should mention uh for TV
rights and TV reasons I'll tell me I
took down Carlson remember that blunder
in yesterday in the world rapid
Championship dramatic turnaround
magnus's only loss in the whole of this
event so far uh I'll tell me if could he
do it again could lightning straight
twice that would do Nakamura favor
clearly and Magnus will be itching for
revenge in terms of the chasing pack we
also do have Daniel dubov a bit of a
downfloat he faces Maxim Malikov on
board three a former European Champion
another Russian star so these two know
each other very well Duda and ishqiri on
board four will pay attention to as well
and Dennis lazovic that surprise package
the underdog could his rise continue
against another uh unknown package maybe
at the top level hike mati rosian
Lawrence yeah so many clashes report as
well against manager of two of the most
entertaining players of their generation
this is really heating up we're gonna
end on a high today
uh yes uh it's uh it's gonna be a great
round I'm especially interested in uh in
artery of Carlson
um as I said I think this is actually
bad pairing for Magnus always find
artemium to be a tricky customer Magnus
also energy doesn't quite feel there at
the moment I think Magnus will be happy
just not to lose and you know wrap up
today on a really big score go in
tomorrow all guns blazing
but I think this is a great spot for
Nakamura
I think Photoshop traditionally
struggles against Hikaru
and the Hikaru to get to 10 out of uh 12
would be
well phenomenal it's a phenomenal score
and that would set him up nicely for
tomorrow Malikov duboff
great spot for duboff here in my opinion
even with the black pieces uh Duda Geary
can be can go always and lazovic Mata
Rosen as you said two young guys and
slightly less known what a spot this is
for one of those guys to get to nine
points and really be in sort of second
or third position
just uh behind one of the leaders uh
going into day two of course there are
still some fantastic more well-known
names on eight Rapport manager off
should be a great game as well
fantastic spot for one of these guys too
so
looks like it's an a round of
opportunity to me
yeah and Lawrence I have to point out as
well a really an incredible fact we've
had 13 Rounds of Rapid over the last few
days we've now had 11 rounds of Blitz
Hikaru hasn't lost a single game that's
24 games now he hasn't experienced
defeat so he will be riding High he's
going to be thinking he's Invincible
Hikaru Nakamura right now Magnus has
only lost one out of all of these uh
games that we've played so far so he's
also doing pretty well but Hikaru he has
smelt blood now he is on that streak
he's winning so many games any half
chance Hikaru is getting right now he
seems to be converting as we see the
players getting ready around 12 of the
day we saw a handshake there Fabiana
karawana will face Jewel moussard the
French champion and he's Geary adjusting
his pieces as he gets really ready to
face Jan krishnoff Duda on board four
he's not out of it neither is Duda a win
will be essential for both of these
players they want to end the game a on a
high and tomorrow is the Sprint part of
the tournament today ends the marathon
what are the players energy levels like
hikaranakamura arriving early first time
we've seen him uh arrive early to the
game normally he's in the last few
seconds after his opponent he is ready
he means business and with white you've
got to back him feather save as you say
uh Lawrence traditionally has struggled
a bit against Nakamura with black
felices slightly less dangerous uh his
openings maybe not uh at the same level
as nakamura's Nakamura so experienced in
Elite circles for the last couple of
decades and uh yeah I think we will be
following this game most likely just to
see how the new leader does can he
maintain or extend that lead
predictions Lawrence
well it's uh it's an interesting round
uh I'm gonna go against the uh
uh I'm gonna be a bit daring let's say
I'm actually going to go for an Artemis
of win against Magnus Carlson uh
something's up I can't put my finger on
it but this is artemio's chance I'm
gonna go for a Nakamura win
I'm gonna go for a Dube of win
I'm gonna go for a dooda win and I'm
gonna go for a lazovic win five decisive
results on the top five boards wrap up
mama drop I'm gonna go for the
unexpected result which is a draw
so I'm going completely against the
grain
could be wrong but
doesn't matter
do you think I'm completely off point
here or do you think uh I'm onto
something
I hate to disagree with you Lawrence you
know that but I do think we'll see uh
yeah a few surprise results I do think
we might see Maxine matlikov upset
Daniel duboff I think maklikov just so
principled
um and he's been on a roll winning a few
games in recent times I have a feeling
like you say artemia will be feeling
confident against Magnus but feather
save despite his track record against
Nakamura despite having the black pieces
he's not gonna lie down he will put up a
fight so yeah we'll see we'll check in
on these other results I'll tell me if
they're getting ready for the arrival of
Magnus Carlson
will he adopt the same approach we
should mention although I'll tell you
has been the only player to beat Magnus
in Kazakhstan although he beat him in
the rapid portion it was a totally equal
position when Magnus just hallucinated
London a moment of blindness uh so
artemiah didn't necessarily outplay the
world champion he just took his chance
when it came in okay we're off Lawrence
The Moose we are on the board
Nakamura against it's a Kingsport
opening
King's Pawn opening let's see
our Hikaru goes for an early Bishop C4
okay Knight F6 E3 Bishop C5
Knight C3 this is a similar opening they
deployed against uh sorry
yeah and he went for this early
yep exact same recipe I was gonna say
that he used against Aaron
C6 is different C6 is the most ambitious
move in the position aiming to push
forward in the center as soon as
possible for black but uh Nakamura
preempts that by retreating his Bishop I
must say this last move by white I'm not
too familiar with and uh what is up his
sleeve Nakamura do you think he's going
to go really aggressive Lawrence and
play Akin's gambit-esque F4 is it too
soon no
no way he plays F4 here
um he's going to play Knight F3 or H3 or
something and he does go H3
maybe he wants to put the Knight on E2
he plays a tree to prevent Knight to G4
so he might you know you know another
move by fair to save that if you gave me
10 moves to choose Queen E7 just doesn't
exist as a move
I would have chosen castles 957 A5 B5 H6
again commentating on featherserve
literally I'm hopeless Knight G2 played
I just don't get Queenie so A5 again
just do me a favor
um
really tough to get us to move some
Knight G3 you can guess your car is
moves this makes a lot more sense I'm
not even sure how good this is but
okay at least it's an interesting novel
position
yeah and that's all that Hikaru is
trying to achieve he's not trying to
blow his opponent off the board that's
never been uh nakamura's strong point in
Blitz occasionally he goes on the attack
and is rewarded but he has Superior
understanding to a lot of his opponents
he's happy to slowly outplay them and H6
on the board Nakamura are now getting
ready to play A3 giving his Bishop a
nice safe hiding place on A2 yeah
Nakamura his recipe for Success
throughout this tournament has been
going for the long rides out playing
them in the end game when the margin for
error is smaller and look at this
Lawrence he's got everything he wanted
an orthodox position Queen F3 White
Knight is getting ready to jump into F5
feather save seems unflusted unbothered
just uh calmly bringing his pieces out
on the queen side I'm really not sure
what his Knight is doing on the edge of
the board over there but uh yeah
Nakamura can he keep his time advantage
that's been another key factor in his
lead in the tournament he's always up
with the clock Nakamura Lawrence have
you ever seen nothing
lose on time never He's just never down
on the clock it's it's incredible really
all right Castle Slade yeah
and Bishop B6 another mysterious kind
well Bishop B6 makes a bit more sense
because Knight C5 is coming
okay
and uh
festim J here in the future chat does
does pick up on how fedes presses the
clock I've played him many times over
the board fair to save and he does move
the pieces uh press the clock in a very
unique manner uh it shows his calmness
that is reflected in his uh chest style
never flustered Bishop d8 Lawrence you
would never guess any of these moves you
mentioned I wouldn't I mean
just no chance it's probably a bad move
probably probably a bad move hence why
the bar shot up uh Hikaru goes 95 should
F5 Queen F5
now Queen to D7
you're going back to F3
okay
nakamura's got the bishop pair he wants
to keep the Queens on the board he's
ready to break out in the center White's
Pawn is coming to D4 maybe uh White's
quickest side step and play F4 okay he
does push in the center Nakamura he's
going for broke now
I like it open up the position when he
goes to Bishops
just a quick Point Magnus has already
drawn artemiev was not in the mood to
push neither was Magnus I felt as though
Magnus wanted to make a quick result if
his energy was off the past four games
now he has time to regroup but what a
chance this is now for Hikaru Nakamura
white pieces minute up on the clock two
Bishops
better position to get a full point uh
distance between himself and Magnus that
would be absolutely massive let's see if
he manages to do it
yeah I think he's a huge favorite to do
so look at the clock Lawrence nearly two
minutes for Nakamura 30 seconds for
feder Save it's a beautiful position on
the board for white it's uh just the
ideal uh position he could never have
hoped for more from any opening and uh
yeah Magnus drawing five games in a row
you don't win tournaments uh by doing
that
can Nakamura capitalize Queen C7 weird
move again from her feathersef every
turn surprising us but not in a good way
uh Nakamura I think a bit confused by
that black queen move and while tactics
on the board Knight takes B5 blow right
up in the position
giving up his night we've got to mention
after C takes B5 after the pawn takes
the Knight
is nakamura's idea E5
he's calculated this so well E5 hitting
the Rook hitting the Knight winning back
the material with interest had to say
down to almost 10 seconds now
and disaster on the board so tactically
sharp nakamura's in blistering form
and uh it's simply winning black tonight
on A6 was also attacked there was no
time to win White's Bishop on D4
nakamura's won the exchange Lawrence
Rook for Knight if I'm counting
correctly you can just take on E5 here I
mean you can just do do that is what and
he does and this is resigns time guys
rookie five rookie five I mean Rook
takes C5 is coming next Queenie five
okay this is just just an exchange
relationship takes F7 exists any move
you want
Hikaru
just cruising
maybe he wants to protect this how he
takes on A5
also makes so much to be done here
and the save needs a last ditch
counter-attack maybe against the F2 Pawn
he needs to combine his Queen and
knights but it's desperate too much
material Nakamura is up
Four Points in exchange and two pawns
okay one of the pawns drops but that is
irrelevant yeah I mean seeing that
tactic Lawrence Knight takes B5 yeah in
Blitz in what did he spend 10 seconds
that is another level he's just a boss
at Blitz chess and uh okay we see Hikaru
beautiful tactic by Hikaru Nakamura look
at featherface indecision he made that
move with one second left if that Rook
on A4 was captured by the other Black
Knight then Queen takes E4 would have
been a winning double attack and uh yeah
here we go we are going to go down to
the end game with Nakamura and exchange
and a pawn up even without white speed
Pawn easily winning and fedes of flags
Nakamura takes the win
just so smooth so impressive
Nakamura
flawless flawless flawless flawless in
fact the whole day
he has been the most impressive player
he's never really been in serious danger
Magnus we've seen had a couple of dodgy
positions especially against mamajarov
and he's going to be a point clear going
into tomorrow Lawrence let's go to the
game between Duda and giri now Nakamura
was spectating he was convicting this
game looks like uh Duda and Gary I mean
it's very tense position giri visibly
nervous black has an extra Rook oh but
Gary I think he's blundered Queen D5
check is gonna be a killer okay he
doesn't Spot It
checkmate
now okay he's given give him a second
opportunity Anish Gary can he cling on
whites King not safe either
this is what happens when those players
are down to one or two seconds the brain
goes out the window what happens
just a moment of blindness black is now
winning
like his willing to Rook up Lawrence
it's not over white still has some
counter-attacking chances against the
black king but look at this dude is
laughing okay we've transitioned to an
endgame black has an extra Rook Duda he
missed a mate in three or mate in four
wow Gary living a Charmed Life and a
handshake Duda resigns
yeah what a game
wow what a that's not just a point
that's a two-point a swing really if you
think about it for anushkiri instead of
losing a point he's gained the whole
point and uh massive bit of luck
for Anish Gary in that game he needed
that to stay in touch
Martin rosian did beat lazovic by the
way and Rapport beat mamajarov
uh neponishi making a late run he's had
a great second half of Laurie by the way
go to another key game this is between
Alexander shimanov and Yu Yang Yi it
looks like Yu Yang Yi is about to resign
uh White simply has an extra Bishop in
this position White's b-pawn is going to
cost black his Rook
game over you only playing another move
out of inertia and resigns
great win shimanov another player on
form on fire today now we see video in
the background there as well this is on
board eight so crucial to the standings
absolutely great day for sure much
shimanov on eight and a half points
only rated
2605. doing brilliantly in June there's
a name we haven't spoken about what a
second half of the day he had he scored
six and a half out of his last seven
including defeating Fabiana caruana on
board seven that means Jewel is also in
the mix and it is so tight at the top
and we've still got a game you against
Harry Krishna ongoing
to decide if we're going to get another
player on eight and a half but as things
stand Hikaru Nakamura a full point clear
on 10 out of 12 followed by Gary Carlson
dubov Martin rosian Rickard Rapport all
online and then on eight and a half
better save artimia of shimanov Saturn
matlikov Russo
and potentially either you or Harry
Christian well it won't be Harry Krishna
will it be you
Lawrence uh it would be me it would be
you and uh you Yang either I think
there's some controversy Lawrence we see
on the camera uh Iranian Grandmaster guy
in megamy is claiming something he's
called The Arbiter
he's playing a very young opponent
okay he's protesting against something
it's unclear what there has been
controversy remember in this tournament
already yesterday there was a
controversial moment between vladislav
kovalov and a strong opponent uh you can
go check that out on YouTube but
meanwhile the Arbiters are calling the
players away they're going to discuss
this away from the board so they won't
mess up the position this can happen in
Blitz okay wow a draw has been agreed
but uh one of the players is furious
foreign
yeah you get of course you do get these
kind of disagreements the position
didn't look anything but kind of equal
though so I'm not sure where the big
Scandal is uh nonetheless obviously
these five players fighting for huge
amounts of money
um so you know every Point does count
and the nice touch there I've got to say
the young player setting up the pieces
afterwards very uh classy classy stuff
it's always nice to do that after a game
and uh controversy
solved
there we go
all right
we've only then got I believe one
game sort of remaining from the
from the top games and that is
Christopher you against Harry Krishna
doesn't look like we've got the video
coverage there the position does look
stone cold dead well it is dead now all
the pieces have been exchanged that's
going to be a drawing none of these
players get eight and a half yes
talking of drawers we see another
position that should be headed towards a
draw it does feature European Champion
Matthias bluebound he's facing Uzbek uh
Prodigy uh mukidin Madam I think his
name is pronounced white is a pawn up
black has a knight it should be possible
to set up a blockade here but oh taking
down to four seconds three seconds
has oh has the blue band blundered blue
bum is massively blundered
can't remove
he can't blockade White's pawns any
longer just take the pawn okay white has
six seconds panicking there that's a
check two pawns up it should be game
over looked like black had a draw had a
fortress but he let it slip now I could
just make a new Queen in the next few
moves you have to be careful there there
was a tricky night Fork that's a nice
technique from the Uzbek youngster it's
been the year of Uzbekistan prodigies
calculated well well that's a running
through
yeah
yeah when's the game
bit of an angry reaction there by lubam
he was not happy
losing that one that was a frustrated
resetting of the pieces because uh you
know getting to eight uh you're in a
you're in a great position eight would
have been shared with a whole bunch of
players but seven is a different story
and amigazi after a cracking first half
of today lost his last three in a row
lost against Carolina lost against
sadwani and lost against irrigation
meaning he's going to be in the middle
of the field
and that pretty much is that for today
um
it's been uh everything we expected
David
yeah it's been everything we could have
hoped for and more we do see now
Nakamura in the lead he will be chased
down there's nine important games
tomorrow still plenty of action plenty
of chances for him to slip up
but remember so much is at stake it's
not just the world title it's so much
prize money so much honor and a
breakthrough event of course for some of
these younger players that will be the
main storyline we will focus on tomorrow
uh of course Nakamura can he get his
first ever World Blitz title
uh Lawrence he's got to be one of the
favorites to do it but yeah still plenty
of action ahead
yep uh it's it's been the Hikaru
Nakamura show today really he's been
phenomenal dominating from start to
finish hasn't looked in trouble
um and is rightfully a point clear of
the field going into the final day
Magnus Carlsen started off nicely he
arrived nearly
the full three minutes late for his
first game got there with 30 seconds
left still managed to win showed some
nice form early on and started to fade
got very lucky against mamajarov but
magnus's Magnus he's staying there a
bunch of other players also there as
well but it really is the Hikaru
Nakamura show today he's gonna have to
maintain the same form and the same
energy tomorrow if he's gonna pull this
one out the Hat it's been a title he's
been desperate to get in all of his ears
playing chess it would mean the world to
him to become World Blitz champion
is he going to do it we're going to find
out tomorrow and as for tomorrow we do
start
I believe uh let's get the schedule up
I believe it is an hour earlier than
normal so tomorrow the games kick off an
hour earlier than today do bear that in
mind
um and there will only be nine rounds in
the open and there will be
uh six in the women's as well so a much
shorter day there reason being of course
is the prize giving and if there has to
be a playoff or anything like that we
need to accommodate that
also want you guys to remember that
uh we if you're at just.com if you're a
if you're a streamer if you're looking
to be a streamer and to grow your
audience just like we've seen Hikaru
Gotham the boater sisters who have
become worldwide Superstars have done
then make sure that you get yourselves
involved with the chess.com Community
streamer program
it allows you to bring your stream to
chess.com which is the world's biggest
chess platform there are tons of new
features to promote your presence in the
chess community and all you have to do
is connect your Twitch account to your
account on chess.com set your Twitch
category to chess and start streaming
news exclamation mark start streaming in
the chat for all the details
well
final thoughts of today David
I think uh it's been pretty clear it's
been
action-packed drama everything that we
love about this tournament that's why
it's one of the most certainly in my
opinion my favorite tournament to
commentate on in the whole year
um the quality is still excellent
uh but for me it's it's been all about
Hikaru Nakamura today
yep it's been a long day Lawrence but a
fun day it feels like years ago now that
Magnus almost defaulted round one where
he turned up two and a half minutes late
uh he only had three minutes on the
clock so uh he started that game with 30
seconds feels like so long ago but as
you said uh Hikaru Nakamura he's been
the man of the moment can he keep it up
I can't wait to see tomorrow's action of
course the women's section as well that
is dramatic with all two joint leaders I
can't wait Lawrence I'm looking forward
to joining uh watching all the action
with you it's going to be a wild up and
down Journey but but uh yeah we'll see
how the titles are decided tomorrow
certainly will make sure you join us
remember an hour earlier compared to
today
it will be full of ups and downs we want
to thank everybody from chess.com for
watching this show today thank you for
all your nice comments apologies that we
can't really get to everybody we do see
the super chats but as you know the
action is so fast and so Furious that we
simply don't have time however keep
those comments coming and we look
forward to seeing you tomorrow an hour
earlier but from me from David Howe from
the rest of the team here for day one of
the World list championships it's
goodbye tomorrow is the final day are we
finally going to see Hikaru Nakamura as
World glitch Champion only time will
tell see you tomorrow
however life is full of exciting events
but it is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
forgettable emotions from the first date
the first expensive things you bought
when you got your first paycheck and
your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]